ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest
is Jocko Willink.
Jocko Willink is a
retired Navy SEAL
and author of numerous important
books on leadership and team
dynamics and the host
of the Jocko Podcast.
During his 20-year
career with the US Navy,
Jocko served with SEAL
Team 3 as commander
of Task Unit Bruiser
in Ramadi, Iraq,
and elsewhere in
the Middle East,
as well as deployments
in Asia and Europe.
After retiring from
the Navy, Jocko
used his experience
and knowledge
gleaned from his time in
the SEAL teams as a way
to develop tools
that anybody can
use to develop their
leadership skills,
both for leading themselves
and for leading others.
That took the form of
several important books,
the first of which
was published in 2015
and is entitled
Extreme Ownership:
How US Navy Seals Lead and Win.
He has also authored
several books
for kids about leadership,
personal development
and how to navigate
various aspects of life.
I've read both Extreme Ownership
and The Way of the Warrior Kid,
and I found them to
be immensely useful
in terms of actionable
information and understanding
of oneself and different
kinds of relationships,
both in and out
of the workplace.
Typically, guests on
the Huberman Lab Podcast
are scientists
and/or clinicians.
It was some time ago that I was
a guest on the Jocko Podcast.
And during the course of our
conversation on his podcast,
we quickly realized that many
of the science-based tools
that my laboratory
has focused on
and that I've used
over the years
and shared on the
Huberman Lab Podcast
had direct overlap
and parallel with many
of the tools that Jocko and
other members of the SEAL teams
had arrived at
independently-- that is,
without knowledge of
the underlying science.
And in fact, he
had many more tools
that he had incorporated during
his years in the SEAL teams
as well as in
business leadership,
in family and elsewhere
in life, that I quickly
realized it would
be an enormously
valuable conversation to
have him on this podcast
in order to share those tools
with the general public.
During today's episode,
we discuss numerous tools
that Jocko has taught and used
over the years in a number
of different contexts,
including tools for generating
more physical energy and
for generating more focus
and cognitive energy.
And for navigating
sticking points,
that is how to deal
with lack of motivation,
how to deal with
difficult relationships
in the workplace and elsewhere.
And perhaps most
importantly, how
to think about and
navigate the self.
In fact, we spend
quite a bit of time
talking about this notion of
the self and one's self identity
and how self identity
plays into our ability
to engage in actions of specific
types consistently over time,
where it can hold us back,
how to gain better perspective
and how to help others
gain better perspective so
that we can work better
with them and them with us.
We also go deep into the
likely scientific mechanisms
underlying why the tools
that Jocko teaches and uses
are so effective.
In fact, one thing that
you'll immediately notice
is that Jocko was
writing things down
and I was writing things down
throughout the conversation.
And that just reflects the
fact that he's not just
an immensely powerful
teacher, he's
also a practitioner
and an avid learner.
He's always seeking knowledge.
So we kick back
and forth our ideas
about what likely does and does
not underlie different tools
and techniques, focusing,
of course, mostly
on what works in the
practical sense in the world.
What I can assure you is that
by the end of today's episode,
thanks to Jocko's immense
generosity and curiosity,
you will come away with
a large number of tools
and much richer understanding
of how to navigate and enhance
mental health, physical
health and performance
in all aspects of life.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Maui Nui.
Maui Nui he is venison
that is by far the most
nutrient-dense and delicious
red meat commercially available.
Maui Nui he spent
nearly a decade
building a USDA-certified
wild harvesting system
to help balance invasive
deer populations
on the island of Maui.
The solution they built
turns the proliferation
of an otherwise invasive
species into a wide range
of nutrient-dense products, from
fresh butcher cuts and organ
meats to bone broth,
jerky, and even pet treats.
The quality and nutrient
value of Maui Nui meats
is extraordinary.
For instance, their bone broth
has an unmatched 25 grams
of protein per 100 calories.
As I've talked about with
guests and in solo episodes
of this podcast, getting
adequate protein intake,
and in particular,
high-quality protein intake,
is extremely important.
Current research
suggests that most people
should be getting
about 1 gram per pound
of body weight of
quality protein per day.
And Maui Nui meats are of
the absolute highest quality
in terms of the amino acid
profile and other nutrients
contained in their venison.
If you would like to
try Maui Nui venison,
go to
mauinuivenison.com/huberman
to get 20% off your first order.
Again, that's
mauinuivenison.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress
covers with cooling, heating
and sleep tracking capacity.
I've discussed many times
before on this podcast
about the key importance
of temperature
in regulating the
quality of your sleep.
Put simply, in order to fall
asleep and stay deeply asleep
throughout the night,
your body temperature
has to drop by about
1 to 3 degrees.
And waking up, conversely,
involves your body temperature
increasing by about
1 to 3 degrees.
Now, people vary in their
core body temperature
and whether or not they
tend to run hot or cold
throughout the night.
But with Eight Sleep
mattresses and mattress covers,
you can literally program
in the exact temperature
that you want to sleep in.
And that allows you
to fall deeply asleep,
go into slow wave
sleep and REM sleep--
that is rapid eye movement
sleep-- in the exact sequence
that you need to in order to
have the best quality sleep
and it will even track
your sleep for you.
I've been sleeping with
an 8 sleep mattress cover
on my mattress for
about eight months now
and it is incredible.
My sleep was already pretty
good and now it is fantastic
and I feel so much
more alert and focused.
My mood is far better
throughout the day.
I thought I was optimized
and with Eight Sleep,
now I realize I
had a lot more room
to improve my sleep and
my daytime wakefulness.
If you'd like to
try Eight Sleep,
you can go to
eightsleep.com/huberman
and check out their Pod
Pro cover and save $150
at checkout.
Eight Sleep currently
ships in the USA, Canada,
UK, and selected countries
in the EU and Australia.
Again, that's
EightSleep.Com/Huberman to save
$150 at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by LMNT.
LMNT is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need
and nothing you don't.
That means the exact ratios
of electrolytes are in LMNT,
and those are sodium,
magnesium, and potassium
but it has no sugar.
I've talked many times before on
this podcast about the key role
of hydration and electrolytes
for nerve cell function, neuron
function, as well
as the function
of all the cells
and all the tissues
and organ systems of the body.
If we have sodium, magnesium,
and potassium present
in the proper ratios, all of
those cells function properly
and all our bodily
systems can be optimized.
If the electrolytes
are not present
and if hydration
is low, we simply
can't think as well as we would
otherwise, our mood is off,
hormone systems go
off, our ability
to get into physical
action, to engage
in endurance and strength and
all sorts of other things,
is diminished.
So with LMNT, you can
make sure that you're
staying on top of your
hydration and that you're
getting the proper
ratios of electrolytes.
If you'd like to try LMNT,
you can go to DrinkLMNT--
that's L-M-N-T--
slash Huberman, and you'll
get a free LMNT sample
pack with your purchase.
And right now, LMNT
has two special flavors
for the holidays, chocolate
caramel and mint chocolate.
By the way, both of those
taste extremely good,
cold and, even better, I find,
heated up, believe it or not.
You can have them as kind
of a tea, they're delicious.
And all of their
flavors are delicious.
For the ones that you
drink typically cold,
I like the raspberry flavor
the watermelon flavor,
and frankly, I like the
citrus flavor as well.
They're all delicious.
So again, if you want to try
LMNT, you can go to LMNT,
drinklmnt.com/huberman.
The Huberman Lab
podcast is now partnered
with Momentous supplements.
To find the supplements we
discuss on the Huberman Lab
podcast, you can go to
livemomentous-- spelled O-U-S--
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And I should just
mention that the library
of those supplements is
constantly expanding.
Again, that's
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And now for my discussion
with Jocko Willink.
Jocko Willink, welcome.
JOCKO WILLINK: Thanks
for having me, man.
- I'm super excited and
super happy to have you here.
- I'm glad to be here.
I know that you and I did five
and 1/2 hours on my podcast.
So schedule is clear, let's go.
- Let's go.
And actually-- and people
will see the Jocko GO drinks.
This is not some sort
of promotional by me,
but these are the
energy drinks I drink.
So this could be called the
bring-your-own-GO podcast.
It is the energy drink I drink.
And no, I'm not
told to promote that
or paid to promote that, it's
just the one that I drink.
So there you go.
No pun intended.
I was just saying
to our producer
a moment ago that rarely
do I sit down and do
a podcast with somebody
that's skilled in podcasting.
Lex Fridman would
be the only person
that I've had on this
podcast, I believe,
who's also a podcaster.
Since you're a podcaster
and many other things,
I confess I'm a little
bit intimidated.
- Well, it's a weird thing
to actually call a skill.
Because it's something that
I just kind of started doing.
It's something that you
just kind of started doing.
It's something that Lex
And I never practiced
it, I didn't
sit down before my first
podcast and think about how
I should deliver things.
I just kind of did it, so.
Maybe it's just luck
more than skill.
- Well, you and I
actually go back further
than that conversation that
we had on your podcast.
I think it might
have been 2014, 2015,
and you were on the
Tim Ferriss podcast.
And at the time I was
living with my girlfriend,
we had moved from San
Diego to the Bay Area.
We were living in this
little, tiny apartment
in a basement in Oakland,
trying to save up to buy a place
or rent a place that
was decent to live in.
And we both knew a
lot of team guys,
she knew more team guys
than I did in San Diego.
Had dated a few,
just to be direct.
Great woman, those guys
were cool to me, mostly.
And I remember when I saw
the photo on the top card
for Tim's podcast.
It was your face.
And I said, do you know
this guy from San Diego.
And she goes, nope.
But if you had to draw a Navy
SEAL, that's what you'd draw.
So I think for a
lot of people, you
embody their notion of a
number of different things,
some of which you talk about.
But some of which,
when you open up a bit
and really get specific
about work in the military
and work in daily life and what
it is to be you, but really,
what it is to be a human being,
some important contradictions
also emerge, right?
Obviously, discipline is a theme
that people associate with you,
right?
In my view and I think in
the view of a lot of people,
you embody discipline.
So today, I definitely want
to talk about routines,
but also mindsets.
But also things
that you do and ways
that you approach things that
might not contradict, but not
be so obvious to people.
Might be a little
bit counterintuitive.
And in addition to that, you
have a lot of different aspects
to your life.
In addition to
running businesses,
you're a family man,
you have children
and married a long time.
And so you have a
lot of knowledge
from different domains of life.
So with your permission, I'd
like to dive into all of them
over the next 26 hours.
- Let's dive.
- Great.
I'm fascinated by this
idea of sense of self.
I feel like all of us can look
back to a time early in life
when we first had
some experience.
Could be in art class,
could be fishing,
could be sport,
doesn't really matter
what the exact experience was.
But where we first realized
that there are really
cool things in the world.
Like something that turned us
on at the level of excitement.
Or maybe scared us, or
something like that.
Do you have any recollection
of such an event?
Maybe not the first
one, but you ever
remember hearing or seeing
something as a young kid,
and maybe you could tell us
how young, and just thinking,
yeah, more of that please.
[JOCKO CHUCKLES]
- A lot of times when
people ask questions
along this line of when
was there a moment--
when was there a moment
that you realized discipline
or when was there a moment
you realized leadership
you realized detachment,
kind of like your
question, when was there
a moment you realized, for lack
of a better way of saying it,
I'm a person.
I'm a person with
my own thoughts
and I can make things happen.
And for me, all those answers
are usually fairly gradual.
There's a little thing that
indicates, you get a clue
and then you move a little
bit further down that road.
Then you get another
clue and then
you move a little bit
further down that road
and you get another clue.
So that's what I
would say, for me,
life was like when
I was a little kid.
I was kind of slowly
discovering that I was a person,
I was a human.
I remember my mom
took me shopping.
I was probably
about 10 years old
and I needed to get
pants for school.
And my mom took me shopping.
And when I went into the store,
there was a girl that was--
I don't know what they're
called in a store.
A retail sales girl?
She was probably about 16.
And I started chatting her up.
And I kind of recognize
it a little bit
but I sort of didn't too and I
just was chatting to this girl
and I was making her laugh.
And I was having a good
time with the whole thing
and putting on the pants
and spinning around,
and she was laughing.
And I remember when we left
the store with the pants
and my mom was sort
of talking to me
about the fact that, "What were
you trying to do to that girl?"
And I was thinking to
myself, well, I kind of
liked that girl, she was pretty.
And I don't know why
that popped into my head.
But I just remember
thinking, hey man, there's
a whole world out there and
let's go make it happen.
- Yeah, it's a great story.
Because I think it really
speaks to this thing
that you mentioned, which
is that when we first
start to realize we
have a sense of self,
it has something to do with
cause and effect on the world,
like we can have an impact
in some way on things outside
of us, outside of our home.
Lately I've been reading
a lot of psychology
and I've been listening
to some of your content
and I definitely want to
talk to you about a study
that you covered
related to these--
it's a brutal experiment with
these kids that either had
stutter or didn't have stutter.
I want to get into that
a little bit later.
But what we do and
how we treat people
and how we receive feedback and
give feedback has a big impact.
But I think some of that happens
just in our own relationship
to things in the world.
The older Hungarian
psychologist, I'm learning,
had this idea of
two kinds of people.
They literally thought there
were two kinds of people.
There are generators
and projectors.
And generators are
people that are just--
from a very young
age, they realize
they can impact other people,
positively, negatively.
And they want to create
things in the world,
they want to generate stuff.
And they go wow, I can actually
build stuff and break stuff.
Blow stuff up, maybe,
but also help things.
And then there are
these projectors
that like to just
reflect on what they see.
And they made the really
important point, I think,
that it's not the generators
are good and projectors are bad.
The world needs both,
that they really work
in a kind of symbiotic way.
But your story
captures the essence
of what it is to be
a generator, which
is that by doing certain
things, you can have an impact.
And it feeds back to
you and it's likely
that they receive
something from it as well.
- Yeah.
And where this all came to
fruition, as I now piece
together as you're talking
through this stuff--
Look, when I joined the
military, you join the military
and you get a blank slate.
So no one cares
where you came from,
no one cares what you did.
You were the captain
of the football
team, captain of the
soccer team, no one cares.
No one cares what
your grades were,
no one cares what
you got on the SATs.
No one cares about anything.
You're a blank slate.
And then with that
blank slate, it is, hey,
if you do this thing,
if you perform this task
and you perform it well,
you will get recognition.
You will hopefully
get more control
over your own destiny, which
is the ultimate in compensation
for human beings.
To have more control
over your own destiny
is the ultimate compensation.
You and I were talking
before we hit record,
you can have all the
money in the world,
but if you don't
control what you're
doing every day or
at least you don't
control most of what you're
doing, then it's not worth it.
The reason people
try and make money
is so they can have more
autonomy in their life.
And so in the military,
it becomes very clear--
and it became very
clear to me very quickly
that if I performed well, I
actually got a lot more freedom
with what I did.
Even in boot camp.
If you pass an
inspection in boot camp,
you don't have to
redo your locker
or you don't have to make your
bed again because you did it
right the first time.
And so you have an
extra 15 minutes.
And so for me,
really, that's when
I started to realize, oh,
what I'm doing right now is it
going to impact not
only what's going
to happen to me
in the next hour,
but in the next two years,
three years, five years.
And I think that's the
biggest miss that we have
when we're growing up.
And I know you had your
challenges and tribulations
as you were growing up because
you didn't realize, oh,
what I'm doing right now
is going to affect where
I'm going to be in the future.
And it didn't happen until
you were out of high school,
when you went to junior
college and you're like,
oh wait a second, I can
actually put my life together
in a positive way.
When you're 14,
you're thinking, hey
what am I going to do tomorrow.
That's basically
future operations or--
what am I going to do tomorrow.
- Would've been far
ahead for me at 14.
I was like, where am I going to
get the Slurpee, which curves
am I going to hit
skateboarding and where are we
going to play
video games tonight
or what girls are we
going to hang out with.
That was kind of
the mindset at 14.
- Yeah.
And then at some point,
you learned, and so did I,
oh, the actions that
I take now are either
going to positively
impact my future
or they're to negatively
impact my future.
And the more I focused
on doing things
that are going to
positively impact my future,
the better my life became.
And I think that's
a very huge lesson
to learn that I know I didn't
figure out for quite some time.
- Yeah the idea of
investments and withdrawals,
or understanding
that early in life
in terms of health behaviors
and intellectual behaviors.
And your point
about the military
is a really interesting
one, I never
thought about the
military that way,
that there's this blank
slate when you get in there.
And before we started, we
were talking a little bit
about the kinds of
mindsets and people
that the military attracts.
And I'd love for you to
elaborate on that again.
You mentioned
something interesting,
this notion of garrison.
- Interesting word
in its own right.
What kind of people do you
think the military attracts?
And then within the
military, do you
start to see some kind of
predictable bifurcations, where
certain people go down
one track and other people
go down another?
I have a few friends from the
SEAL teams, as we both know.
And I've heard sometimes
about the distinction
between officers and enlisted
guys, this kind of thing.
But maybe this
question I'm asking
is more across the board
for all of military.
And for people
listening, whether or not
they are interested in military
or not for their own life,
I think there's an interesting
lesson, this idea of who
is attracted to the military.
Is it like people who want to
instill order on themselves
or is it people who want to
instill order on other people,
or both?
- Yeah.
There's a really good
book and I ended up
doing about four podcasts
on this book, which
is called The Psychology
of Military Incompetence.
And when I first saw that--
- What an amazing title.
- I know.
And when I first saw that
title, I thought to myself,
oh, this is some academic that's
going to look at the military
and bash it.
But I did a little
research and it turned out
that the guy that had
written the book--
I can't think of
his name right now--
he was a guy that had served
in World War II, was wounded.
I mean, this guy understood
what he was talking about.
And it's really
an obvious concept
once you think about it.
The basic premise is
this, the military,
when you look at it
from the outside,
it's this orderly place.
It's a place where
everything has a place.
It's a place where if you have
a certain rank on your shoulder,
you will command respect and
people have to listen to you.
That's what it looks like.
So it's an attractive
place for people
that have an authoritarian
mindset, for people that
want to just, hey, don't
question what I'm saying,
just shut up and do
what I tell you to do.
There's people that love that.
There's people that
want to live like that.
You've worked for them,
I've worked for them.
We've experienced those type
of people throughout our lives.
That authoritarian
mindset that just
want to bark orders and
have people listen to them.
And so when those people are
14 years old or 16 years old
or 18 years old, they
look at the military
and they see a uniform.
And they see people
saluting and they
see orders being carried out.
And they think, that's
where I'm going to go.
And I can get the
respect that I deserve.
And the military certainly
attracts people like that.
And those people that have that
highly-disciplined and orderly
mindset can do well
inside the military,
especially in garrison.
Again, we were talking
about this earlier, the word
garrison.
I don't think there's a civilian
equivalent to this word,
but it basically means
the noncombat situation.
So when you're out
on the parade field,
when you're going
through schooling where
there's no combat involved,
when you're marching.
Those kind of things,
we call that garrison.
It's in the rear.
It's not in combat.
And the people with an
authoritarian mindset
actually do pretty well
in garrison situations.
Why?
Because things are orderly
and you can predict what's
going to happen.
And you do get a
certain issue of gear
and that gear is going
to be delivered on time
and you're going to shoot
this number of rounds
down at the range.
And everything is going
to go according to plan,
that's what garrison is.
And so those people
join the military,
they're attracted to
that and they end up
doing well in peacetime.
Now unfortunately for them,
combat is a lot different.
Nothing goes the way
it's supposed to go.
The bullets don't get
delivered on time,
the enemy has a vote on the
way things are going to unfold.
And you end up in combat being
in very chaotic situations.
So the type of person
that thrives in combat
has a more open mind,
has a more flexible mind,
is paying more
attention to the input
that they're receiving
as opposed to someone
with an authoritarian mindset.
They don't listen
to anybody else.
They make up their own
mind, they bark orders.
With someone that has
a more open mindset,
they're listening,
they're taking input,
they're evolving their plan.
And those type of people
excel in a combat situation.
Now unfortunately, and this is
sort of the stereotype too, you
take that dog of war
and you put him back
into a garrison environment,
he doesn't do well.
He's not showing up on
time for the inspection,
didn't get his haircut, he
doesn't have his weapon cleaned
the way it's supposed to
be cleaned because he's
got his weapon ready for combat,
not ready for inspection.
And so you get this-- there
are these two different types
of people.
And of course, with those two
different types of people,
there's degrees going
one direction or other.
But what you hope
for is someone that
can play the game
on the garrison side
and yet when it comes
time to go into combat,
they can also open their mind,
be flexible, be creative.
That's what you really want
is you want someone that is
very good at solving problems.
And to do that, you need to have
a creative, open mind to figure
out how we're going to
deal with something.
So I think that's
the stereotype.
The stereotype is that
everyone in the military
is sort of robotic and
falling into the hierarchy,
and we bark orders and
people follow orders.
And that's just not true.
There is an element
of truth to it
but it's not the whole truth.
And certainly, if you look at
it history, the people that
excel in combat are the
people that maybe have
a little bit of a
rebellious streak,
people that are just more
creative and more open minded.
- Some of my friends
from the SEAL teams
will sometimes throw
out stereotypes
about the different
divisions in the military.
Is there any truth to this
idea that Air Force types are
one way and Marines are one
way and Navy is one way,
army is a certain way?
Sort of a general
contour of personality
or is that just kind of
inside ball, joking around?
- It's a little bit of both.
I mean certainly, the Marine
Corps is steeped in tradition.
And if you make a guess
at what a marine--
if you had to guess what a
marine is going to be like,
you're probably going
to be pretty close.
Marines have an
incredible program
to indoctrinate their people
into the culture of the Marine
Corps.
And the Marine Corps has an
incredibly strong culture.
It's a powerful culture.
I love the Marine Corps, I've
worked with the Marine Corps
a ton and they're outstanding.
As a generality, certainly you
could make those assumptions
about the Marines in general.
Now, does that mean that
every Marine is the same?
No, absolutely not.
Same thing with the army,
same thing with the Air Force,
same thing with the Navy.
You've got these
kind of stereotypes
that exist for a reason.
It's interesting too.
One of my friends
named Ben Milligan
wrote an incredible
book called By Water
Beneath the Walls,
which I've given him
a huge hassle about because it's
the worst title of all time.
But it's certainly
the best book written
about the SEAL teams'
history and where
the SEAL teams came from.
And it's interesting,
it's something
that I had heard from
a SEAL officer that
had given a speech years ago
at his change of command.
And what he said
was he was trying
to emphasize why the
SEAL teams were good.
And one of the things he
said was in the army--
and he was talking
historically-- he goes,
hey, in the army, if you
start to lose a battle,
you can just retreat
and run away.
In the Navy, traditionally,
we're fighting on board a ship.
And if that ship--
we can't run away.
We're fighting and
if we lose, we die.
So SEALS can't quit.
It was this, a little
over the top, expression.
But when you take that
a little bit further,
when you look at the
history of the Navy.
If we were in the
Navy 150 years ago,
you would have to
go on deployment.
You would take your ship
and you would sail somewhere
and you wouldn't be able
to talk to me anymore.
So you would have
to understand what
it is you were
trying to accomplish
and then just go out
there and make it happen.
That's decentralized command.
And that's something that
exists in the SEAL teams
without question, very
decentralized command.
And that's one of the absolute
strengths of the SEAL teams
is you've got leaders at every
level inside the organization.
That if they don't
know exactly--
if they're not told what
to do, they're going to go,
OK, I haven't been
told what to do
but I'm going to
go figure it out.
And that's one of the
strengths of the SEAL teams.
We have more doctrine now, but
when I came in the SEAL teams,
there was no doctrine.
It was all word of mouth.
And so the army and
the Marine Corps,
if you have to
conduct an ambush,
you can pull out
a manual and you
can look up how to conduct
an ambush-- platoon ambush,
how to conduct it-- and
it's all written very clear.
And they're great documents.
That's the FM 7-8 infantry
platoon and squad,
I think is the army doctrine.
- I can see the little neurons
in your hippocampus firing
in sequence.
- Yeah.
- It's embedded
in there forever.
- And it's a great manual.
And you can pull that
thing out and you
have a place to start from.
In the SEAL teams, we
didn't have that at all.
So you would hear from
your platoon chief,
this is how you
conduct an ambush.
And he had heard it from his
platoon chief, who heard it
from his platoon
chief, who heard it
from his platoon chief, and that
platoon chief was in Vietnam.
So it's getting passed down but
you can make adjustments to it.
And you can alter the plan
a little bit because hey,
the terrain is
different, or hey,
the night vision we now have.
So there's changes
that we can make
because there's no doctrine.
So not having any doctrine,
in many ways, is a strength.
Also it can be a weakness.
Because if you've got a new
platoon commander that's never
done an ambush before and he
has no idea what he's doing,
this platoon chief has been
out of the loop for a long time
and he doesn't know what he's
doing, there's no reference.
So there's strengths
and weaknesses,
just like any characteristic.
Everybody's characteristics,
you've got strength
and you've got weaknesses.
And your weaknesses
can be strengths
and your strength
can be weaknesses.
To get back to your
original question,
are there stereotypes inside of
each of the military branches?
Sure.
But are there outliers in
each of the military branches?
There are absolutely.
And that's why you can't
judge a book by its cover.
- For people listening to this
who are not in the military,
maybe have some military
lineage in their family
or not, but who want to
understand a little bit better
about how structure
and lack of structure
can both support being
effective in life,
in relationships, in daily
life, in fitness, in business,
in school--
I think those are
the big domains--
in creative endeavors.
I think it would be useful for
them to understand a little bit
about how you in particular
balance discipline
and structure with,
dare I say, lack
of discipline and structure.
- Well, you could
actually just say
the word freedom, because
that's what it turns into.
- Or maybe even play.
I bring this up in
part because I've
seen some posts that you put
up of you playing the guitar
with friends or music.
One of them was a
tribute to someone
who either was killed in
combat or had passed away.
So these moments of
connection between people
sometimes are working
together, but sometimes
are in relaxation and play,
in these kinds of things.
I think it was a really
important post for people
to see that while Jocko Willink
kicks back with a guitar,
not trying to take over stages--
maybe you are.
Maybe you have a plan.
If anyone could do it,
you'd probably be the one.
But what is the balance for
you in terms of structure
and lack of structure?
And I'm not going to ask
for your daily routine.
We know that you get
up early, you train.
But I do have some
specific questions
that I think would be
helpful in putting some meat
on the notions about you.
And again, this isn't
a pick into your life
but more to grab-- well,
it's to pick into your life.
The-- so a question I
asked you in the lobby
because it's one
that having seen
your content for a long time
and really benefited from it,
I was curious.
You get up early
at about 4:30, you
train every morning, how
long do you train for?
And is there any global
structure to that?
And, of course, everyone
needs different programs,
but is it like weight
training one day,
cardio training the next day,
or you're combining them?
Is it always an hour or
is it always half an hour?
I think people would benefit
from getting a little bit
more understanding of what
that looks like for you,
with the caveat that
everyone has different needs
levels of background,
et cetera, but I'm
intensely curious
about this and I'm
certain I'm not the only one.
JOCKO WILLINK: So do you want
to talk about weightlifting
or rock and roll on the guitar?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
want to talk about--
let's your let's talk about
the most structured first part
of your day, and then let's talk
about the least structured part
of your day, at least
the part that you
can share with the world.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
waking up early
and I'm going to work out.
And depending on what's
going on that day,
if I have an early
flight, I might work out
for eight minutes.
I might go in and do
2,000 meters on the rower,
get a sweat going as hard
as I can, and then I'm done,
and-- because I've got
to go catch a flight.
So that could be happening.
Maybe I'm supposed to go surfing
in the morning, I wake up,
the waves are terrible, and
so now I've got nothing to do.
I planned out to be surfing
for two or three hours,
and now I'm not
going to go surfing,
so I'm going to go lift and
I'm going to go play in the gym
and do a bunch of stuff.
I'm going to spend two
or three hours in there.
I love doing that.
So the workout could be
anywhere between what
I just say 8
minutes and 3 hours,
and it could be
anything in between.
I fully enjoy the physical
aspect of working out.
So if I have more time to spend
in the gym, I'll spend it.
I remember my dad
saying at one point,
if I retired I wouldn't
know what to do.
And I was thinking to myself,
are you serious right now?
If I didn't have anything to
do, I'd spend six hours a day
in the gym, I'd spend four hours
doing jiu-jitsu I could fill
my day--
I could fill every day with
just physical activity, things
that I just like doing.
So wake up early,
get a sweat going.
And do I lift?
Yes.
Do I do cardio?
Do I run?
Yes.
Do I sprint?
Do I lift heavy weights?
Yes.
Do I swing kettlebells?
I do everything and anything,
and I enjoy all of it,
and I'm not really
good at any of it.
I'm not really good at any one
aspect of physical activity.
There's people that are
infinitely better at me
in every aspect,
and I'm not just
talking about, Oh, this
guy's a world-class, no.
There's like a guy named
Fred down at the gym that can
deadlift more than
me, there was a guy--
when I was at SEAL Team 2,
there was a guy who was,
it's probably 5'7", and
he looked kind of chubby,
and he was older than me, and
he could run faster than me,
and he could bench more than me.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Those
guys are out there.
JOCKO WILLINK: It was
just so bothersome.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
they're out there.
They've got some engine in
there related to something.
I mean, I do think there are
genetic differences in terms
of people's resilience
and workout,
but even just grip
strength is highly, highly
subject to like
genetic influences,
maximum grip strength.
But of course,
there's a huge range
in what people can develop.
But I guarantee your grip
strength is greater than mine.
People ask me this
all the time, who
would win in arm wrestling
between you and Jocko.
JOCKO WILLINK: You know
there's a lot of technique
in arm wrestling.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
I have to imagine
they're putting
their body behind it,
their back in that.
JOCKO WILLINK: There's
a legitimate technique
in arm wrestling--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Which
worked for me yet.
JOCKO WILLINK: No, if we could
bring a female arm wrestler
in here that knows how to arm
wrestle, because I don't know
how to arm wrestle either,
and she would beat both of us
because there's a lot more
technique in arm wrestling
than most people recognize.
There's all these little
games that are going on.
There's all this little
arm position that you get.
So just like everything
else, it's technique.
There's a lot of technique
in arm wrestling.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
That's good to know.
I didn't know that
about arm wrestling.
I think we all start off with
some genetic predispositions,
both good and bad, for different
things, and then there's--
as far as we know,
there's a huge range
based through neuroplasticity
and muscle adaptation,
et cetera, in what
we can obtain.
So I never want
genetic predisposition
to serve as a barrier.
No one knows also what the upper
limits of any of these things
are.
And some of the best examples
we know from sport and certainly
from academia are
people who knew
they were at a
disadvantage and just
worked 10 times harder
than everybody else
because they had
an ax to grind with
their genetic
disadvantage, which is
really cool at the face of it.
I'd like to take a quick
break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors,
Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens, now called AG1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Green since 2012,
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take Athletic Greens
once or usually twice a day
is that it gets
me the probiotics
that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by
gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the
immune system, and basically
all the biological
systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long term health.
And those probiotics
in Athletic Greens
are optimal and vital
for microbiotic health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains
a number of adaptogens
vitamins and minerals
that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs
are met, and it tastes great.
If you'd like to
try Athletic Greens,
you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman,
and they'll give you five
free travel packs that make it
really easy to mix up Athletic
Greens while you're on the road
in the car, on the
plane, et cetera,
and they'll give you a year
supply of vitamin D3/K2.
Again, that's
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel
packs and the year supply
of vitamin D3/K2.
So you get the training, and
do you track your training
in a detailed way?
Are you keeping
track of lists and--
JOCKO WILLINK: So I
write down what I do,
and I'll write down--
I write down what
I do every day.
And that way, I can
go back and say,
what was I doing back then?
Because I might go
through some phase
where I'm trying
to do more pull ups
or I'm trying to deadlift
more and I'm trying--
whatever the thing
is, I'll go back
into-- because I get bored
of deadlifting after a while.
And let's face it, if you just
want to be a good deadlifter,
you're not going
to be that fast.
You're going to be
slow on long runs,
so you don't want to go
too deep into deadlifting.
And you also don't want
to be so good at long runs
that you can't deadlift
a good amount of weight.
So I kind of go through
phases, and I'll
get into something
for a while, and then
I'll get into something else.
So I do log down what I'm doing
so that way I can look back
and say, Oh, dang, I'm not
even close to as strong
as I used to be, need
to get back to that.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'm fascinated
by the concept of energy.
I think it's one of the most
interesting aspects in all
of biology, all of
psychology, and all of life.
And when I say energy,
I mean the distinction
between being back
on your heels,
flat footed, or
forward center of mass.
And I get the
impression, and I think
everyone gets the
impression that you're
somebody with a lot of energy,
and I wonder whether or not
you wake up with a
lot of energy and you
feel like you have to burn it
off with this physical activity
and work and other
demands in your life,
or do you find that you
wake up and your energy
is kind of neutral, and
exercise and physical activity
gives you energy?
Because I think this is one
of the key things out there,
I think, that acts as
a barrier for people
doing more with their
body because maybe they
don't want to tire
themselves out
or maybe they don't feel
like they have enough energy
to begin with.
It's also feeds into this
idea that some people just
have a lot of energy.
They're really physical,
and other people aren't.
So let's just say
on most days do
you wake up feeling
like you want
to burn off energy,
build energy, what
is exercise mean to you?
And then maybe we
can talk about some
of the underlying stuff going
on there because I think we
both might find it interesting.
JOCKO WILLINK: I
would say it's both.
There's no way I could sit
here and say, oh, yeah,
every day that alarm
clock goes off,
and I'm like, oh, yeah,
let's rock and roll.
No, certainly
that's not the case.
It's also certainly not
the case that every day I'm
like, oh, god, not again.
No, I'd say most of the time
the alarm clock goes off,
and I don't think a bunch.
When my alarm clock goes
off, I don't think a bunch.
I don't debate with myself.
I'm not negotiating.
The thing goes off, and I'm
doing what I'm supposed to do.
Sort of robotic.
Now this much I can say,
when you go and work out,
you're going to feel better.
You will get energy
from working out.
That is a guarantee.
If you go work out, you're
going to feel better.
If you go break a sweat,
you're going to feel better.
You're going to get
more energy from it.
And look, you got
to go really, really
hard to where now you feel
more tired when you're done.
And even that, I mean,
you've got to go psycho.
I'll do that occasionally, but I
don't do that on a daily basis.
At the end of the day, if
I wake up, lift, run, surf,
and then I do jiu-jitsu
in the afternoon,
at the end of that day,
I'm tired and I feel tired.
But normal day working out
just makes you feel better.
Definitely gives you--
definitely gives me energy,
I should say, because I
guess I'm not everybody.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, I think
it's a very important point
because one of the things that
we are learning from circadian
biology, time of day effects
and sunlight and all that stuff
that we talk about
in our podcast
that you've done
intuitively, this
is what we kind of arrive to.
JOCKO WILLINK:
It's kind of crazy.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: As last
time we had a conversation
is that so many of the
things that science
is telling us to do
and that we emphasize
on this podcast
you've been doing
or are built into military
schedules, and one of them
is this notion of
waking up early
and getting physical
early in the day.
And I suppose if we were
to just throw one blanket
rule on the table to encompass
the broadest number of themes
it's that once every 24
hours, we each and all
get a big increase in this
release of the hormone
cortisol, which everyone says,
oh, cortisol it's terrible,
he's going to burn you
out, adrenal burnout, all
that stuff, but it's
a non-negotiable peak.
And you want it to arrive
early in the day and viewing
sunlight, physical
activity, caffeine,
and in particular
intense exercise,
all amplify that cortisol peak.
In fact, I think the
numbers I'm seeing
is just sunlight
viewing gives you
a 50% increase in that cortisol.
Exercise on top of that,
another 50% to 75% increase.
So this huge release in this
hormone that everyone thinks
is terrible but actually
sets this huge wave
in motion for the rest of
the day, which gives you
more energy, higher levels of
immune function, more focus,
et cetera, and does
indeed as you mentioned
in your example of
your daily life sets
a timer so that about 14 to
16 hours later, you're sleepy,
which is what you want 14 to 68
hours later, unless, of course,
you're running vampire
shifts in the military
or you're on shift work, but
most people aren't, of course.
So I think the idea that
movement and exercise gives us
energy I think is an important
idea and it's something
that frankly I was hoping
your answer would be that, as
opposed to that you
wake up every day
and you just want to just attack
the world because you have
so much energy getting out
of bed because frankly, I
never feel that way.
But I always feel
better after I train.
Always.
And of course,
there are times when
I crash in the early afternoon
if I train really, really hard,
but usually that's
when I over-caffeinated
to an outrageous degree, and
then I don't nourish after,
or I over nourish.
So this is the other thing
that eating, the whole rest
and digesting, the digest
word in there is meant to--
it's there for a
reason, which is
that when we eat
a really big meal,
we actually need to slow down.
So I hate to get
into daily schedules
at the level of
nitpicking, and nutrition
is about the most controversial
topic on the internet,
but do you nourish
after you train?
And if you do, do you
do it to the point
where you're kind of like, OK,
I'm mostly full or I'm full?
Are you trying to
really nourish yourself,
or do you find that
eating slows you down?
JOCKO WILLINK: I find
that eating slows me down.
And I would say, again, it's
weird how some of this stuff
is.
The main reason I got in
the habit of waking up early
and working out is
because if you do it
before anyone else is awake,
then they can't bother you
and you can get stuff done.
You go to the SEAL
Team and you get
there before anyone else is
there, no one can say, hey,
can you help us with this?
Hey, no one sent you an email.
So you get that time, you
get it done, and it's yours.
I remember when you
were on my podcast,
and I don't wear sunglasses
when I run in the morning
because I sweat and it
fills my sunglasses.
It's not because I want to
let the UV light into my eyes,
that's not cortisol.
It's not for the cortisol.
I didn't know that.
It's cool that I know it
now, but I just did it
because I don't like to
sweat in my sunglasses,
can't see, so I just run
without, I don't put a hat on.
As far as eating, I don't like
to do physically active things
with food in my stomach.
That's just the way it is.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, me either.
JOCKO WILLINK: And
so I don't want it.
And what really
keeps that in line
for me is I'm doing
jiu-jitsu in the afternoon,
and so if I'm
eating a big lunch,
by the time the afternoon
rolls around, I'm kind of I
got food in my gut, and I
just don't like that feeling.
So no, I don't eat
a big meal until I'm
kind of done with the physical
stuff for the day, which
is usually at night,
6, 7 o'clock at night,
which I guess there's some
bad things about that I
eat too late.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Well,
the data say if you're--
yeah, we could go down
a rabbit hole with this
and then someone's
going to pull up
some little clinical
study and then another one
that counters that.
I mean I think the
data essentially
say that having a regular
meal schedule that
allows you to sleep well at
night, whatever that means
for you, and that allows you
to be active and focused when
you need to be
active and focused,
that's the ideal schedule.
JOCKO WILLINK: When I'm
working with clients,
so I have a leadership
consulting company Echelon
Front.
When I'm going to
work with a client,
I'm not eating because
they're going to be asking me
questions, we're going
to be diving into what's
happening inside their
business, there's
a lot of stuff going on.
It's a lot of cognitive work.
So I'm not eating
before a podcast.
I'm not eating before a podcast.
Before I'm recording
a podcast, I'm
not eating because
I don't want to have
a bunch of food in my stomach.
You get a certain
level of mental clarity
when you haven't
eaten a bunch of food.
So going out on
missions, I never
would eat before I
go out on a mission.
I would eat when I come home.
You get home at 4
o'clock in the morning,
3 o'clock in the morning
from doing operation, cool,
then I'll eat because
then I'm going
to do a debrief for 15
minutes, clean weapons,
and then eat a big
meal, go to sleep.
Cool.
Yeah, I don't want to
have food in my stomach
when I've got to perform
or execute anything.
So again, I think that's
just kind of a fluke
that I ended up
living like that,
but that's kind of how I live.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's
a fortunate fluke
for all of us because so
much of what you embody
and what you do I think centers
around this idea of discipline,
of course, but also energy.
It's the intuitive sense I
get about why people are so
drawn to your messaging and
what you do and how you do it.
Energy we know, of
course, is caloric energy.
And I think that's what
most people default to.
They go, oh, how many
calories are energy
and how many calories in
that and you need calories
to fuel things.
But the energy that
you're describing I think
is the one that--
well, it really maps the
Eastern traditions more directly
to how yin and yang thing--
yin and yang, I always
get that wrong-- so which
is the notion of neural energy.
And so there's a particular
cluster of chemicals in us
as a fancy name called
the catecholamines.
But that's dopamine,
epinephrine,
which is adrenaline
and norepinephrine,
and then you've got cortisol.
And those four hang out
together and basically give us
enough energy to run our
brain and body for 50 days.
50 days.
So the idea that you have to
eat before you train, sure,
for some people that might
work better than others,
but I think what
people don't realize
is that anytime we're
taking in caloric energy,
it takes neural energy in
order to digest that and put it
into storage.
And so the way you
describe your day of, yeah,
I also don't eat before I train.
I like to hydrate
and caffeinate.
I have been drinking
these before I train.
I have to limit myself to two
before because otherwise, I'm
like picking up--
I'm already quaking a little
bit at the second one.
But I have a pretty
high caffeine tolerance.
So I like to train first also.
And then I find it
gives me energy.
But then the moment that I eat a
meal that's a little too large,
all of a sudden
I'm out of energy.
And what's the deal?
These calories
are energy, right?
You're supposed to have energy
in order to think and move.
And I think I think a lot of
the world has this backwards.
And this isn't a push
for intermittent fasting
or any particular
style of eating really,
I don't care if people
are carnivores, vegan,
doesn't matter to
me whatever works.
I happen to be an omnivore.
But I think once
people understand
the energy to do
things is neural,
and yet, of course, it relies
on having glycogen and all
this stuff around, but neural
energy is what's really about,
then your schedule and
the way you function
and the way you
describe your schedule
really makes a ton of sense.
So you described getting up
and lifting, running, surfing,
and jiu-jitsu in the same day.
So on a day like that,
you're hydrating, correct?
JOCKO WILLINK: Oh,
yeah, definitely.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Because that's vital.
And I know in the Teams,
in the SEAL Teams,
there's a lot of discussion
about hydration is important,
even though you guys
I know are supposed
to be able to eat sand and
survive on sunlight and dirt
and drink your own blood.
JOCKO WILLINK: Not me.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Hydration
is taken seriously, right?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
and different people
need different
amount of hydration.
And I, unfortunately, was one.
I always needed to
bring a lot of water
in the field which sucked
because water is heavy.
And I have friends.
One of my friends, Tony, BTF
Tony, he'd go in the field
with like a can of Copenhagen
and coffee in his canteen
and go like three
straight days--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: He's
like a desert turtle.
JOCKO WILLINK: He's
a desert rat, man.
He could just survive.
And I would always have
to bring this water.
I sweat a ton when
I work out or when
I'm doing anything that
requires physical output.
I sweat a ton, so I have to
drink a lot of water for sure.
But not everyone's the same.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, I think
if most people focus more
on hydration and movement.
They would find they have two--
I'm going to venture
a guess here,
this is not a scientific study,
but two to four times more
energy than if they focused on
caloric energy and what to eat.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, and I
think the cool thing about this,
you're using the term energy.
And what's cool about this
is you or I create energy.
I create energy by, like I
said, by going and lifting
in the morning, by
going and doing--
you go do burpees?
You go do 100 burpees like
you're creating energy.
You're going to be tired,
you're going to be sweating,
but you just created energy.
So that stuff is
totally true I'm
glad there's neuroscience
to back it up.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, I'm actually
thinking about devoting
some of my lab to this.
One of the best examples,
another familiar territory
for you is cold water.
Nowadays there's a lot about
ice baths and cold baths
and showers and all that, and
I always like to just say,
listen it's all just a
reliable source of inducing
adrenaline release.
And you get out of a cold
shower, you have more energy,
and that energy couldn't
have been caloric energy,
it's adrenaline.
And again, it's fair
to say I'm obsessed
by the ideas of identity,
which is a little bit how
we started off and I want to
get back to it, and energy.
I feel like identity
and energy can
account for 75% of what
it is to live a good life
if you can master
those, because then it
all seems to fall into bins.
Of course, you need sleep.
Why?
Well, to restore
your neural energy.
At some point, you just
fade out of neural energy
if you don't sleep.
So sleep then falls
into a particular bin
with a particular
purpose, and then exercise
becomes not a way
to burn energy but,
as you said, to create energy.
And we actually are
starting to understand
why this is if you'll
indulge me for a second
on some neuroscience.
We didn't talk about
this last time.
We have neural circuits that
control deliberate action.
control deliberate actions
that when we forget that
we're doing like walking.
And then we have
neural circuits which
are called central
pattern generators.
And these are the
neural circuits
that love to just work on their
own, and in the background
just kind of hum
in the background
and take care of all the stuff
like heartbeat, breathing
and movement that is repetitive.
If you're just
marching and you don't
have to adjust
your cadence much,
or maybe you're hiking even
and stepping this rock,
that rock, once those central
pattern generators get going,
it's very automatic.
And we know that once your
central pattern generators get
going, there's the release
of those catecholamines,
those three or four
molecules that then feed
all the other neural systems.
They're called neuro
modulators for a reason
because they set
the gain higher.
So when you go out for a run
or a jog or a hike or something
or you pedal or
you row, and then
your whole system
is at a higher RPM
so when you say create
energy, neuroscientists
are starting to understand what
that is, repetitive movement
that allows you to forget
the motor commands that
are required to
generate that movement.
You might think about your row
stroke or something like that,
but you can do it
without thinking much.
You come off of that and you
now are set at a higher RPM
to do more deliberate stuff.
And none of this, again,
involve like eating
enough carbohydrates or making
sure you had enough ketones
or enough protein.
It's like you got
plenty of that stuff
provided you nourish at some
point every 24 hours or so.
I think we know a little bit
about the science behind Jocko
Willink's schedule now,
but I will ask this,
are there certain
forms of exercise
like weight lifting
versus cardio
that you find give you
an especially big boost
in what we're calling energy?
And here this could
be cognitive energy,
it could be physical energy, a
readiness for the next thing?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, first I
got to back you up on this.
I love backing up your science.
So do you ever ruck march like
put on a heavyweight and ruck?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
sorry to interrupt.
Yeah, Peter Attia
got me into this.
He got me into doing
a long Sunday--
instead of a long
Sunday, run throwing
on a lightweight vest
or a ruck, and going out
for like three hours.
And the first 20
minutes, I find I always
want to go faster
and get it over with.
But then I've learned
that the real pain in it
sets in around an hour,
and then the beauty
sets in around 90
minutes, where you're
like, I could do this
all day, all night,
and I never want to stop.
JOCKO WILLINK: See that's
when you were describing
how these chemicals
get released,
and once you're in
that automatic mode--
because in the
SEAL Teams, you're
doing Maritime
operations for a month,
and then you're going to
do some kill shooting,
and so you're not carrying
a bunch of weight.
And then you go
out to the desert
and now you're
putting on 80 pounds
and you're going on day
one, and you get out there,
you're going on an
80 pounds ruck march.
And the first freaking 17
minutes, the first 23 minutes
just suck.
They just suck.
And what was beautiful
was by the time I
was 23, 24 years
old, like, oh, yeah,
this is going to
suck for 17 minutes,
and then it's going to be--
I'm going to be a robot and
it doesn't matter anymore.
I can just keep going forever.
So now it sounds
like what you're
saying is what I experienced
basically my whole adult life.
There's going to be a little
break in period mentally
where you think
this totally sucks,
and then you just can keep going
for a really, really long time,
and it's not that big of a deal.
To your question of is there any
form of exercise that gives me
that energy, I would have to
say like the high intensity
sort of anaerobic blast,
whether it's on the bike
or on the rower or swing and
a kettlebell hard, something
like that that lasts
10, 15 minutes, that's
a really good way to peak
my mentality for the day.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Do you
do the cold water thing?
I mean, you certainly did a
lot of it in BUD/S. I mean,
do you force yourself into cold
water and the you release--
JOCKO WILLINK: I have a
cold bath in my house,
and I get in every day.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: How long
are you spending in there?
JOCKO WILLINK: Usually
around five minutes.
Five minutes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Before you
train or after you train?
JOCKO WILLINK: After.
So this is something I
haven't played with yet,
and for me, I'm like such a--
I don't like to make a bunch
of effort for something.
So for me going downstairs
getting in the ice tub--
and I guess you
only need to do it--
before you work out, you
only go a minute, right?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You
do a minute to three.
Joe and I have been texting
back and forth about this.
There's a lab at Stanford,
Craig Heller's lab that
works on cold and
performance, and the athletes
at Stanford, mainly
the cross-country team
and the football
players are doing
cold before their training
because of the huge increase--
huge long lasting increase in
dopamine and adrenaline that's
caused by that.
They're finding it
increases performance
mainly by waking people
up and getting them--
it creates energy, basically.
And students, everyone
thinks of like, oh, athletes
are all super motivated.
This is no pick against
Stanford athletes in particular.
A lot of athletes
are excellent at what
they do because they're very
lazy when they're not training.
This is true.
Not all athletes, but
a lot of athletes are.
And so they're really good
at resting and recovering
so they can train more.
But a lot of athletes have a
hard time getting into gear
to train every day, and the
cold is a great stimulus.
It's like a four shot of
espresso kind of stimulus
without all the jitters.
JOCKO WILLINK: I think maybe
going in there for a minute
would be cool before a workout.
I will say this.
So I had a long workout and
it was a Saturday, which means
on Saturday I do jiu-jitsu in
the morning around 10 o'clock,
and I had like a long
workout, went for a long run,
it was hot, and I just
got in the ice bath
and I sat in there for like 7
minutes like the deep chill.
I got out and then I went right
to jiu-jitsu, and I felt awful.
I felt absolutely
awful like tight cold,
and it took me an extra three
rounds to get warmed up again.
So that kind of left a bad taste
in my mouth for pre-work icing.
But I'm going to try this
short because I was talking
to another friend of mine,
they're like, oh, no,
only go a minute before.
Maybe I'll give that a try.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: If it's really
cold, 30 seconds to a minute
is going to get you
this big release
and adrenaline and dopamine.
JOCKO WILLINK:
Actually one time I
did try the chamber that
blasts cold air on you.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: The cryo.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
the cryo, and I
did that for like a
minute or whatever,
and that did make me feel
pre-workout pretty good.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, I think
that the whole notion of cold
for metabolism,
people say, well, it's
not that big of an increase
in metabolism, look,
as far as I'm concerned,
the main function
of the cold for
most people is going
to be the discipline of doing
it, the sense of resilience
that you can build up over time
just being familiar with having
adrenaline in your system.
And then the fact that the
dopamine increases are huge
and long lasting, I mean,
they're like 2.5x increases.
There's a colleague
of mine at Stanford,
an alumni who runs our dual
diagnosis addiction clinic.
She had a patient getting
off cocaine addiction who
decided to use cold ice baths as
a way to kind of assist himself
along the way.
He wasn't getting dopamine
from cocaine anymore,
so he decided to get
it from the ice bath.
The difference is cocaine
gives you these sharp increases
and then decreases that
drop you way below baseline,
so what do people do if
they go seek more cocaine,
it's really pernicious that
way, whereas the ice bath
and cold showers will give
this long arc lasting two
to three hours or more.
And that's really
something to treasure,
the idea that you can basically
save on your heating bill
give yourself this
huge dopamine increase.
And I think everything
points to the fact
that it's healthy
and good but I mean
obviously it's working for you
to do it after your training.
I think all the gym rats who
want more hypertrophy you're
trying to get an extra 1/8
of an inch on their tricep
or whatever, they freak out
because they hear that it
can inhibit hypertrophy.
And then for whatever
reason, there's this--
JOCKO WILLINK: So
am I doing it wrong?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Well, I
mean, yeah, clearly you're
doing it right now.
No, you're not-- I don't think
your hypertrophy is suffering.
I actually am of the
mind that if you're
training really hard, sure,
getting in the cold afterwards
might blunt some hypertrophy
that is what the data tell us.
Andy Galpin is kind of the
expert on that literature.
But frankly, I don't
know anyone that
trains really hard
with the weights
and then gets into the cold
that looks like they're
suffering from hypertrophy.
I know a lot of
people, however, who
love to point fingers at
and poke at cold exposure.
This seems to be a big
thing on social media.
People who don't like the
cold love to point out
the studies showing that the
cold screws up everything,
and most of them look like they
can eat a few sets in the gym
to me.
And I feel comfortable
with poking at them
because I feel like all
of these are just tools.
And in any case, I'm a big fan
of deliberate cold exposure,
mostly for the neural effects.
Again I'm obsessing over
this concept of energy,
and it's something that
I can't help but ask
that is the cognitive side of
this and the effects of winning
and losing.
So you obviously have
a lot of deployments
and a lot of wins, whatever
in the context that meant.
Kill the target, capture
the hostage, et cetera.
And then as is
the case with war,
there have been some
cases of losses.
You've lost people.
Maybe there were targets
that weren't accomplished,
this kind of thing.
And you've posted about
these, and these are always
things that are
hard to see, but I
think it's really it's
important that you
post about people that you've
lost because, first of all,
these people served, but
second of all, things
don't always work out
the way that we want,
and sometimes to really
catastrophic consequences.
There's a theory in
biology that when we win,
we somehow get more
energy to win more
through the release of,
no surprise, dopamine
and some related molecules.
And in fact, testosterone
in both men and women
is another close cousin
of the dopamine system.
They're actually released
from the same general--
patterns of release are
from the same general areas
in the brain, believe
it or not, and body.
But when we win, we feel
like we can keep going.
You look at the team
that wins and it's
like they'll play another game.
The Super Bowl
winners you imagine
they're jumping up and down,
and they could probably
play another Super Bowl.
Losing we know can
sure can drop things
like testosterone and dopamine
for some period of time.
But when you were
in the Teams what
was your observation about
how winning and losing
would impact people in
the short and long term?
In other words,
would you observe
people that had a
quick reset button
and could just say that was
terrible, and then transmute, I
guess I'm getting into
the Eastern language
now, to convert that into energy
to go do better the next time?
Whereas we also see
people, military
and in the civilian
world that a loss,
in particular severe
losses, basically set them
down the path of less
energy, and certainly
is in less calories.
In fact, most of the
time it's the other way.
They start consuming
more calories
and that doesn't get them going.
So again, this notion of
energy, and now I'm asking,
wins versus losses
what did you observe
and from the perspective
of leadership,
and maybe more importantly from
the perspective of yourself,
how do you work with that?
How do you calibrate
wins and losses?
How do you transmute
losses into energy?
Because winds we know
we convert to energy,
but losses oftentimes can
sup our energy way, way down.
JOCKO WILLINK: To
start with, I think
that the selection process
to get into the SEAL Teams
is going to weed out a bunch of
people that can't recover very
quickly from something bad.
So you probably heard these
type of stories before.
The kid that was the star
of the football team,
the star of the basketball
team, the captain of this,
the captain of that, he's
been winning his whole life.
He goes to BUD/S and he quits,
because in BUD/S, you're
not going to win.
You're certainly not
going to win everything.
They're going to find
what you're not good at,
and they're going to exploit
that, and you're going to lose.
This is what happens.
So a lot of guys
that may lose and it
disrupts their motivation,
they're probably
just going to quit.
And so that's why you get
this massive attrition
rate with guys that are studs.
I mean, we're talking
Division 1 athletes.
Division 1 athletes,
Division 1 wrestlers,
Division 1 football
players, Division 1 runners
and swimmers.
They all come to
BUD/S. They all quit.
all of them quit
but there's plenty
of examples of the highest level
of collegiate athlete in sports
that translate very
well to what you're
doing in basic SEAL
training, and they quit.
And sometimes it's because
they don't know how to lose,
they don't know how to recover
from a loss, and they're just--
so I think already once
you get to a SEAL Team,
you've got people that
are generally speaking,
going to be pretty
resilient when it
comes to dealing with a loss.
Not only that, I
mean, you just get
used to talk about
losing people,
you're friends
with this guy, you
meet this guy in SEAL
training, hey, this guy
seems like a stud, oh,
he's just going to quit.
And you're going
to lose five, six,
seven people, eight people.
People quit so fast you cant'
even keep track of them.
So you're just going to lose.
You're just going
to get used to it.
So there's that.
Now once you're in
the Teams, what you're
talking about is now you
start taking much more
significant loss, you're
not losing a race,
you're losing of
one of your friends.
And this is what from a
leadership perspective
you have to pay attention to.
So when you're a leader
in any organization,
you're basically
in charge of a mob.
When it comes to what their
morale is, they're a mob,
and they feed off
of each other, just
like a mob riding in
the streets going,
oh, we can break this window.
Let's break all the windows, and
they move this mob mentality.
And that happens with
morale inside of a team.
And you as a leader can't
get caught up with the mob.
You can't let that happen.
You have to detach yourself
from the mob mentally so
that you don't get caught
up in their emotions
and their morale because if you
get caught up in their emotions
and you get caught up in their
morale, you can't correct it.
So we go out on a mission,
the mission goes great,
we get into a gunfight,
kill a couple of bad guys,
everyone's OK, high fives,
everyone's feeling great.
You come back to base, hey,
we don't need a debrief.
That was perfect.
Hey, we don't need to
get our gear maintained,
we can just go to
bed, we're awesome.
That's when the leader has
to say, oh, we've got the mob
and the mob is becoming
slightly arrogant.
Hey, guys, real quick,
that was a good op,
but there are some
things we could improve.
You got to bring that mob
back and bring them back
to center line.
Same thing in the
other direction.
You go out an operation,
it doesn't go well.
you take casualties.
Now you come back to base,
you see guys moping around,
you see the spirit starting
to break, and same thing.
If you're part of that
mob, you'll be with them,
your morale will be breaking,
your spirit will be breaking.
You've got to look up and say,
oh, I see what's happening.
Hey, guys, listen up.
That was tough.
Didn't go the way
we wanted it to go.
We need to learn some lessons.
Here are some things
I can do better.
What can we do better to make
sure that never happens again?
What can we do to make sure
we have the opportunity
to go out and avenge our
brother on the battlefield?
What can we do to move
this thing forward?
So as a leader when it
comes to winning and losing,
you're generally going to be the
person countering what the mob
mentality is because when
the mob starts winning,
they want to keep winning
and they might get arrogant.
When the mob is
losing, they might
start to lose more because their
attitude goes down the drain.
So that's where you
have to pay attention to
from a leadership perspective.
For me personally,
I know what I did
when I lost guys was
focused on, all right,
we need to celebrate the life,
we need to mourn the loss,
and then we need to go to work.
We need to get our gear back on.
We need to lock and
load our weapons.
We need to get back out there.
I know that that's
what we needed to do.
So often, the best way
to contend with problems,
with issues, with adversity is
action, is by taking action.
The more you sit
and the more you
wait and the more time you
spend with that adversity
with the upper hand
inside your head,
the worse it's going to get.
So for me always taking action,
making something happen,
it doesn't have to
be huge, it doesn't
have to be some mammoth
triumph that you're
going to go and
pursue, but if you say,
hey, listen, this what happened.
Didn't go the way
we wanted it to.
We're going to get
our gear back on.
We're going to go back out.
We're going to do
this other mission.
And that's what I think.
Taking action, and it's
in your personal life too,
something doesn't go the
way you wanted it to go,
you didn't get the
job you wanted,
you didn't get the hire, you
didn't get the promotion,
you can go home and sit
there and dwell on it.
That's not getting
you any progress.
Or you say, OK, you know what,
let me do a quick analysis why
didn't I get that promotion.
Oh, it's because I didn't
get this qualification
or I hadn't jumped
through this gate.
OK.
Cool.
What do I need?
Let me look into how do I
get to jump through that gate
so next time I will
get the promotion?
And you start taking action.
So action for me is a
cure for a lot of problems
that we have in life.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I love this
because the image that's
arising my mind, I'll
share it with you
and tell me where it agrees with
and maybe violates what you're
telling me, but what I was
imagining it when you were
talking about leadership in
the mob is a bunch of candles,
but not wax candles,
these are oil candles.
And you're talking
about a win, so it
could be an op to go out
and win, it could be a team,
it could be an individual taking
an exam and they get an A-plus,
it doesn't matter, but
they're riding high.
I mean, those winds we know
crank up those catecholamines,
and it's as if the
intensity of that flame
starts going up
as a consequence.
That's natural.
But the oil and the candle
is continuing to burn down.
Like you need to celebrate wins,
but you're burning that oil.
And so what we're really
talking about here
is how to moderate and
then reclaim energy.
And I was imagining
as the leader who
like OK, guys,
great, but listen,
you're burning that oil.
That oil is what
got you the win.
Let's not just clamp it like
we can do a few fist bumps
and maybe celebrate
it in some other ways,
but then let's take
the energy we got
and put it to the next thing
rather than just go crazy.
Drugs of abuse, in
particular drugs
that tap into the dopamine
system, namely cocaine
and amphetamine, and just
because there's no way
to avoid this if we're
being true to the biology,
the energy the
dopamine system was
designed for foraging
for all sorts of things,
food, so people that
overindulge food or seek out
food, sex, people that
overindulge in these things.
Those things, and
again this sort
of leans to Eastern
philosophy a bit but,
there's Western
neuroscience or neuroscience
we should just
say to support it,
you start to deplete
these dopamine systems.
The baseline starts to drop.
And so I'm imagining that
the leader, you in this case,
is saying like, listen,
let's tone it down,
use the energy that we've
gained and put it to good use,
rather than just burn
it up enjoying it.
And then, of course,
after a loss when those--
I sort of think of the
candles going dimmer
but the oil reserve
is still there,
and it's like how do
you start to tap back
into the oil reserve?
Well, you have to actually
ramp the candle up again.
You can't just sit there waiting
for the intensity of the flame
to come back.
You actually have to
do something in order
for that to happen.
So maybe this isn't
the best analogy
because it lacks exactly
what is the person turning
the intensity up and
down on these candles,
but that's what comes to mind.
And in Eastern
traditions, there's
this idea of Qi of
energy, energy to fight,
energy to seek mates, energy
to seek food, energy for sex,
energy for all of it
is the same energy.
And I actually believe that the
energy that they're referring
to are these catecholamines.
I really do.
Now there are other
energy systems too
relating to child rearing,
pair bonding, oxytocin,
all the kind of fuzzy warm
stuff, that's super important.
I mean, we wouldn't
exist as a species
the way we do we didn't honor
that energy system also.
And that energy system that
we normally think of as love
as opposed to forward
center of mass synergizes
with this system.
When you're working with
and training with and people
that you love, this could be
your brothers, your sisters,
whatever, your family, I
think there's an amplifying
effect on this whole thing.
If is just for
more dopamine, just
for more money, just four more
wins, just four more trophies--
I'll never forget
this as an aside.
When I was a kid, I had
this weird experience
where Tony Hawk's dad rescued
me from a skateboard contest
in Linda Vista.
The Linda Vista Boys
Club, everyone else
left, I was left there alone.
I was 14 because of my home
life at that time, et cetera,
and he was like,
where are you going?
I'm like, I'm going to
take the bus to Lancaster.
I know this guy.
And he was like, no, no,
you're coming to our house.
I was like, OK.
So he took me at Tony's house,
and I went into Tony's room
that he had grown up in.
Tony lived in
Fallbrook at that time.
And the room wasn't
filled with trophies.
The room was trophies
and I remember just
thinking like, holy cow.
And when I think
about that and I
think about what a healthy
person Tony turned out
to be because I
happened to be blessed
to know him a little
bit, it's amazing
because a lot of
people that had those
trophies whatever
domain of life,
they converted all that into
ways to just burn the oil down
in their candle.
He's a guy who's still
going in his 50s.
So that's a little
side story, but I
think this notion
of energy to me
is so important
because, as you said,
when we move toward action
and we complete something,
the oil in that candle
starts to get replenished,
and the flame burns hotter.
I'd like to take a brief
break and thank our sponsor
InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA
to help me better
understand your body
and help you reach
your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact
your immediate and
long term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
The problem with a
lot of blood and DNA
tests out there, however,
is that you get data
back about metabolic
factors, lipids, and hormones
and so forth, but you don't
know what to do with those data.
InsideTracker
solves that problem
and makes it very easy
for you to understand
what sorts of nutritional,
behavioral, maybe even
supplementation
based interventions
you might want to
take on in order
to adjust the numbers of those
metabolic factors, hormones,
lipids, and other
things that impact
your immediate and
long term health,
to bring those numbers into
the ranges that are appropriate
and indeed optimal for you.
If you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit
insidetracker.com/huberman and
get 20% off any of the inside
trackers plans.
That's
insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
JOCKO WILLINK: What
you're talking about
and I'm very
interested in this now,
and I don't know if there's
already been measured
or not, but what essentially
we're talking about
is the confidence level.
So if I go out and win,
I feel good about it.
And let's say I'm doing
a jiu-jitsu tournament,
and the first match
I go out there
and I submit the guy in 30--
take him down, submit him
in 30 seconds.
I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling confident.
So what does that mean?
My dopamine is up because
I got that victim.
My testosterone was up
because I got that victory.
My confidence is up
Same thing other direction.
If I go out first match
and I lose to somebody,
my dopamine goes down, that
chemical thing goes down,
my confidence goes down.
And what I have to
do is I have to learn
how to maintain a level of
confidence because if I get--
if I win that first match,
win the second, I'll say,
I'm going to kill this next
guy, and I go out and I'm sloppy
and I don't care.
That's when I get caught.
If I lack confidence,
I go out there
and there's nothing I will
do to beat this guy, that's
going to be horrible.
Of course, I'm going
to get smashed.
So it's a similar thing
that we're talking about.
I just wonder how
much if you start
measuring because they
say, hey, if you win,
your testosterone goes up.
And then if you win more, your
testosterone goes up high.
Your dopamine goes up high.
Your confidence is going up,
but you can get to a point
where your confidence
is too high,
and now you're getting sloppy,
and now you don't care.
And you mentioned cocaine.
You see like videos of
people that are all coked up
and, hey, I can do this.
They think they
can do everything.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
All possibility.
JOCKO WILLINK: Over confident.
They're over they think
they can kick your ass off.
That's like too much
dopamine, too much ego,
too much confidence.
The other side of
the spectrum is
someone that's on some
kind of downer drug,
and they don't feel like
they can do anything.
They're lethargic,
their confidence is low,
and they're just depressed.
So there's an interesting
tie-in between dopamine, ego,
confidence, and
probably testosterone
that you get from
winning and from losing.
And once again as a leader,
from a leadership perspective,
you can't get
wrapped up in that.
You can't get
You have to detach from it.
You have to be able
to take a step back.
And then if you're good
even as a competitor,
you'll say, oh, yeah,
that last match was easy,
but I need to prepare
for the next match.
I can't bring over confidence.
Look, I don't want
to lack a confidence.
It's a balance.
It's that flame on
the oil burning lamp
that you're talking about, that
you want that steady flame.
You don't want too much
going to burn out of control.
You don't want too little,
the flame will go out.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, earlier
we talked about this notion
that some of these older
Hungarian psychologists
had which this notion of
generators versus projectors.
And their idea was that
people sort of divide
into these different categories,
and the world needs both.
It's not a that one is
better than the other,
but the world
absolutely needs both.
And there is this idea now
based on some neuroscience
and some other
psychology that I've
been kind of glazing into
which is that generators
know how to tap into the system,
and they love this system.
I think back to your story about
being taken to shop for pants
and it turns out to
be a trip to shop
for a number of different
experiences for you.
A really telling experience,
having an action effect
on the world and something
coming back to you that still
sits with you inside.
In fact, there's
a dopamine circuit
there still related
to this young woman
or then young
woman at that time.
Some people are
generators and I think
that they are more attuned
to this dopamine system.
And so as we're having
this conversation,
I'm guessing that
about the estimate
is that somewhere between
50 and 65% of people
are going, yeah, I get it.
More workouts are going
to give me more energy.
I need to do more of that.
I need to win I'm
back on my heels.
I need to think about the things
I can complete, et cetera.
And then the other 45% or
so or 35% might be saying,
I don't really get it.
Now the idea is that
the projectors can
tap into these same circuits.
Everyone has these catecholamine
circuits, dopamine et cetera,
but that they tend to be more
of observers in the world
and they like being
partnered with
and symbiotic with these people.
Now this starts to take on
stereotypical masculine,
feminine things, but this exists
on both sides, it really does.
There might be some
biases by biological sex,
there may not be.
We could argue that.
It's probably an
argument that'll
get us into more
trouble than to answers,
and doesn't really matter.
The point is that some
people are perfectly
happy to be in the
company of people
winning because they feel good
to see other people winning.
They like to be a support staff.
That's what makes
them feel good.
Other people would rather
stick hot forks in their eyes
than not be the person
engaged in the activity.
Maybe not every activity
but the activity.
So we're talking about the
generators and the projectors.
I think that in the context
of moderating these systems,
it's so key.
I mean, it's key to have a
long arc and a career path,
military, science, or otherwise.
I think it's key in
every domain of life.
And I think for me,
one thing that I've
learned both the hard
way and I've also
benefit from the
positive experience of,
I think in relationships,
l this could
be romantic relationships,
but also friendships
and in family, because there
are generators and projectors
almost always in those kind
of symbiotic relationship,
romantic couple or a family,
some kids are more generators,
some are more projectors
just by something, who knows?
Maybe it's hardwired, maybe not.
As the leader of
your family, I'm
going to assume one
of the two leaders,
but as a leader in
your family, I'm
not going make any
assumptions here,
as the leader of
your family, and also
as a father in
particular, how do you
apply these same
sorts of ideas when
you know your kid is
kind of down because it's
hard to be a 14-year-old or
because it was a bad day,
or when they're up?
I think the up states are as
interesting as the down states
like, yes, got the
degree, got the win.
How much do you
let them celebrate
before you're like,
hey, listen, you just
got yourself another
couple of milliliters
of oil in your candle, what
are you going to do with that?
You're going to burn
it, or you going
to save it for the next thing
so you can climb the staircase?
JOCKO WILLINK:
Well, clearly it's
a very similar thing to
what I just talked about.
If your kid is doing well and
wins the wrestling tournament
and is like, yeah, I won
the wrestling tournament,
and what do they want to do?
They want to eat a
triple cheese pizza,
I mean, they want to go
crazy and you as a leader
and as a parent and as a
friend, you'd say, hey, man,
I mean, you did good.
That was awesome.
You had a great
day, but let's start
thinking a little bit
about next week too.
How about we just have a few
slices of pizza as a reward?
So this is the same
in any situation
that you could be in interacting
with other human beings.
You want to be the person
that kind of modulates
the confidence and
the ego or the way
you put it, the dopamine and
the celebratory activities.
So no matter who you are,
and this goes with yourself
as well, you do something, you
have a success and you say,
Oh, that's great, but
all glory is fleeting,
and I need to get back to work.
And look, and do people
go too far with that?
Sometimes yes, absolutely.
Sometimes people, they don't
stop and celebrate at all.
And those are the kind of people
I think that get burned out
eventually because they never
say, hey, that was awesome.
We had a big win.
Cool, high five.
They don't even say that.
So I think as a
leader, as a friend,
as a parent, as a
spouse, you want
to be able to modulate
that, help modulate that,
don't shut it down.
Your kid walks off the
wrestling mat for a high five
and you say, you could
have won by more.
No, I'm not talking about that,
or your kid walks off the mat
after losing, you say,
you got what you deserve.
No you've got to be the
counterweight to the emotions
that other people have.
And I think that when you're
doing a good job as a leader,
as a friend, as a
spouse or whatever,
you're doing a good
job as a counterweight.
I think that's a good
way to look at it.
You want to provide
some balance for people
to make sure that they
don't get out of control.
And you notice when
people have a downfall,
it's normally because
they've surrounded themselves
with people that
there's no counter to,
there's no counterbalance.
If you were my best friend and
I went out drinking last night
and had a great time and
partied all night and met a girl
and you're like, heck, yeah,
let's do it again tonight,
eventually, where
are we going to be?
We're going to be in
the gutter somewhere.
But if you say, hey, that
was awesome, but remember we
got school on Monday, and
you kind of pull me back,
we got to find balance
in life and ourselves,
and then we got as much
as we can provide balance
for other people because
people are emotional
and they get caught up
in what they're doing
and you want to keep
people balanced.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I think
one of the reasons people
are really drawn
to your message,
and I put myself
in that category,
and I remember 2014 was a
very different picture for me,
it doesn't really matter
what the contour was,
things were working,
but they weren't working
the way I wanted them to.
And I remember arriving
at your content
first through the
Tim Ferriss podcast
and then eventually the
Jocko Willink podcast,
Joe Rogan podcast, those
were the big two ones
that kind of like introduced
me to you and your content,
and it was really a
case of at the time,
I didn't have a
lot of friends that
were doing similar
things to me or that
matched my daily
routines in a way
that I could kind of
synergize with in this way.
I think one reason why you
are so helpful to people
is that not everybody
has these friends.
You can have the friend
that's like, let's go out
and tie one on again,
a lot of people
don't even have that friend,
or they have a friend,
but they're not really
close with that person.
There's some ideas
nowadays about 80% of males
don't have a close friend
that they could call.
I don't know, I mean,
I'm guessing girls
and women feel the same too that
a lot of stuff is superficial,
and there's a lot
of communication
but not a lot of connection.
And so I think that you and
a few other people in the--
let's call it social
media public facing space,
serve as archetypes
of the friend that's
going to tell you when
you're up, great, but let's
clamp it after a while,
or that when you're down,
let's get going and
here's how you get going.
And so I do want to highlight
that because I think
it's really important and it's
but one reason why people are
drawn to your message and the
message of some other people
who are out there trying
to do similar things,
but you in particular
because yes, you
have this military
background, very
intense military background,
wartime background,
but also you bring it into
the daily routines that
certainly apply to everybody.
Most everybody can
access non-heated water,
one would hope.
There's another
dimension to this
that I want to just bring up and
get your reflections on as it
relates to military, work,
school, relationship, family,
et cetera, which is somewhat
counterintuitive idea but then
once you hear it, it
makes perfect sense,
which is that even though
the catecholamines are
responsible for drive, and
that that's what we're really
about when we're
forward center of mass
and we have to control the
intensity of the candle
and the level of the oil, I
don't know what those actually
mapped to exactly.
We could probably figure it
out if we really parsed it,
but that's the idea
here, the analogy.
In a kind of
surprising way, we know
that for sure one way to restore
levels of motivation drive
enthusiasm, and to some
degree confidence that things
could be different is through
deep rest, things like sleep.
When things are
really, really hard,
when kids are just like they
were like falling apart,
it's like you put them
to sleep, they wake up
and they're like
delightful, they're
running around their
pajamas when they're little,
and a teenager wakes up
after a good night's sleep,
they might be a little
like surly, but we're back.
Adults are like this.
The world is falling apart.
You go to sleep, wake up,
OK, I might be able to manage
this kind of mindset.
So sleep.
And then the other
one is we know
that play, the kind of physical
activity or mental activity
where it might be a
little competitive,
but the stakes are low, and it's
really more about connection
with the activity or
connection with somebody else.
Like we're going to
play a game of whatever,
I won't play chess with Lex
because he'll kick my ass,
I won't do jiu-jitsu
with either of you
because you'll beat me
up both of you, kindly,
but you'll do it.
But if we were to play a
game, it's just us yeah,
we might be a
little competitive,
but the stakes are low.
We know that play and
social connection and sleep
are basically the
reservoir or the location
that you go to refill the oil
in the candle every single time.
And so for you, where do those
things play into your routine?
You mention you can go hard all
day and then in the evening,
is it dinner with family,
typically if you're at home,
and what does that look like?
I know we're kind
of parsing in--
I don't want to carve into
your personal life too deeply,
obviously, there are
boundaries there,
but what does that look like?
Is it everyone at the
table, phones away,
and you're talking
about the day?
Or is it-- yeah, share
with us a little bit
of what that looks
like because I think
it is an important contour
to what you're about
and what we're talking
about that most people just
don't have a window into.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
so, well, first of all,
I mean, just the refilling
the tank with games, I mean,
that's what jiu-jitsu is.
You're going to go
and you're going
to have social
connection with people,
you're going to talk to
people that you know,
you're going to
joke about whatever,
then you're going to roll.
You're going to have
a good time rolling,
you're going to get
a little sweat on,
you're going to feel good,
then you're going to high five
like there's huge--
that's there, and your
brain is kind of off.
When you're training
jiu-jitsu at a certain level,
you're not going to
be thinking anymore.
Same thing with surfing.
You go surfing and
you catch a wave.
I mean, you're not
thinking about, oh, I
need to put my
balance over here.
No, it's happening and
you're having a good time.
So I would say that restoration
for me comes from those two
things for sure.
And then yeah, I mean, my wife
and my kids when I get home--
and my kids are older now, and
they're out of the house except
for one.
And when I was in the
Navy when they were young,
I wasn't around at all.
We would rarely have dinner
together because I was gone,
coming home late, you're
working all the time,
you can never get all your work
done, I'm training jiu-jitsu,
we rarely ate dinner as a
family when I was in the Teams.
And now when I'm home, we
can eat together for sure.
My daughter that's
still at home,
she's going to-- we sit out
there and eat dinner and talk
about just normal things
that people talk about,
like how to conduct
a night ambush or--
let's talk about normal daily
things and what's going on.
And my daughter,
she's 13 right now
and she talks to me
about all kinds of stuff,
and it's awesome.
Yeah, I'm definitely
enjoying that aspect
of being around more than I
was when I was in the Teams
and we didn't have dinner.
Didn't happen.
So I would take my
kids to jiu-jitsu,
I taught jiu-jitsu
classes when I could
when I was in the Teams,
would do workouts with them
in the morning if I had time
on the weekends for sure,
stuff like that with my kids,
that's kind of what I did.
But now yeah, we--
my wife is awesome, and
she is a great cook now
because when we first got
married, it was questionable.
I just was harassing her
about this the other day.
She's an unbelievable cook
now, and it's awesome.
And when we first met,
by her own admission,
she will tell you she was not.
She's from England,
and so they're just
not cooking what we're liking.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: No,
the food over there,
at least when I was growing
up in the few times I made it
over there, the food
was pretty dreadful.
I mean, there were some
exceptions to that,
and they drank a lot over there.
So I've been to some
scientific meetings over there
where they would start with
like Sherri in the afternoon,
and then beer after work.
It was outrageous.
I mean, the amount of alcohol
intake was just absurd.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Sorry, Brits.
And again I'm not trying to--
I did an episode on
alcohol, a lot of people
were angry about that episode
because it's basically said,
once you get past
two drinks a week,
you're starting to
head into territory
that can deplete
your health, so you
got to do a lot of other
things to offset it.
But they drink a lot.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
the Brits drink a lot.
I have spent time over
there with my father-in-law,
my brother-in-law, and we
definitely drank a lot.
So I'm glad I don't live there
and had to drink with them.
I'm glad I don't have to
drink with them all the time.
I'd probably be dead.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You were
straight edge growing up,
right?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, I
mean, when I was a kid,
and then when I joined the
Navy, I started drinking.
That's like part of the
culture that I bought into.
And I wanted to be
a good SEAL, and I'm
looking around at the guys that
were considered good SEALs,
oh, so we're drinking?
OK, that's what we're doing.
And that's what I did.
Looking back now,
I didn't really--
I didn't think of it as
a big deal at the time.
I wasn't like-- well, first of
all, even when I was growing up
and I didn't drink and didn't
smoke, didn't do drugs,
I wasn't like a guy putting an X
on my hand, although my friends
and I, we all didn't
drink, didn't smoke.
So we definitely-- look, I
was listening to Minor Threat
when I was a kid.
I mean, I get it, but
I wasn't I running
around telling everyone
I was straight edge,
but I was on that path for sure.
And then when I got in the
SEAL Teams, it's like, OK,
this is a different culture.
I'm not used to it.
And I didn't really even
understand what drinking was.
I mean, I never had been drunk.
So got on the SEAL Team
so I was like, OK, well,
once I turned 21, hey, these
guys were going to have fun,
and I kind of just, OK,
that's what we're doing,
and then I drank a ton while
I was in the SEAL Teams.
And then as I retired from
the SEAL Teams and went out,
we basically went to every
bar that we would normally
go to like as SEALs.
I think we closed out the
night at the Park Shores in OB.
And when I went
home that morning,
I woke up the next
morning, worked out,
and then I just kind of
stopped drinking because--
and now I just
definitely, I mean,
now I just don't
really drink anymore.
So that's that.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, when I had
my lab in San Diego
for five years,
that's where my lab
started, I definitely
saw a lot of Team guys in bars.
You guys would come
in and take over bars.
These were little takeovers.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
I wouldn't leave
because I wouldn't like
give them the satisfaction
or me the dissatisfaction, but
it was a little frustrating.
You're in there, you're
having a decent time
and then just this
enormous pack of Team guys
comes in and sort
of like, all right,
maybe it's time to
close out the night.
I was friends with
enough of them,
but if you're not
really a part of it,
you're not really a
part of it, and I always
knew that and understood that.
One thing that I think really
comes through now especially
but throughout our
discussion and all the things
I've seen of you,
and it gets me back
to this thing that came
up at the beginning,
I'd really like to
return to is that you
seem to have a very strong
sense of context and self.
I'll just say it, I'm
not a psychologist,
I'm not here to play
one, but what you just
described was that
in one context,
you know it made sense
to be straight edge,
and you mentioned Minor Threat,
great band, straight edge band,
but when it came time to run
around with your friends then
and it made sense to be without
alcohol or drugs or anything
at that stage and then you
get into another context,
it's like OK, I can do this.
I can drink and still
perform well and do
all the things I need to do.
And then when that closes out,
I'm going to do something else.
And some people are like
that because they're
kind of a chameleon.
They're switching themselves
depending on the context,
and they're kind
of getting accents
when they're in one
location or another,
but that's not you at all.
I can tell with certainty
that's not you at all.
There seems to be a very
strong sense of self
so that when we have a
sense of self that's firm,
we can go into
different contexts.
We can even change
our behavior, but we
don't lose who we
are, which means
we can always return to it.
The image in my
mind is like I've
done a little bit of
scuba diving, not a lot,
but during some of the more
advanced training for us,
this wasn't SEAL
training, of course,
was following a line in the
dark, like a night dive.
And you're following a
line, and sometimes you're
navigating with tools,
but suddenly you're
following a line underwater.
And this idea that you
can let go of that line,
but you have to remember where
it is you can return to it.
And that's kind of how I
imagine the sense of self
because in different
contexts, most healthy people
modify themselves a little bit.
We act differently at
a wedding or a funeral
than we do in class or
out with our friends.
Of course, it's
an important part
of being a functional human.
So it seems to me that
from a pretty early stage,
you had a pretty
good sense of self.
Now I don't know if
you sit in your room
and meditate on who is
Jocko Willink and touch
that central chord of self.
I'm guessing you don't.
But as I say this,
I have to ask,
was there something in your
upbringing, your parents
or was it just kind of how
you always imagine yourself is
like, yeah, this is who I am.
No matter what happens around
me, I kind of know who I am.
Even if I'm engaging in
some of the behaviors
that I might not do
in another context,
I know who I am
because I actually
think that many people do not
have a very firm sense of self,
or their sense of self is
so rigid that they can only
operate in this narrow
trench of one domain of life
and they end up
very, very isolated.
So I'd love for you to share
with us what your recollections
are like the first time you
realized like, yeah, I'm
good in a bunch of
different places.
I'm safe or I'm whatever,
because I think this is also
relates to confidence.
JOCKO WILLINK: I'm
glad you are giving me
the benefit of the doubt
on going in the Teams
and being like, oh, hey, man,
looks like guys are drinking
and I haven't
really drank before,
and it seems like these
guys are having a good time.
Let's go have a good
time with these guys,
and that's kind of
what I did right.
As far as, and I look at it
now and unfortunately for me,
I look at alcohol now as just--
I've seen it destroy
so many people
that I've now kind of look
at it and go, man, I don't
think people should drink.
And look, I get it.
I'm kind of an example.
I used to drink and go
out and have a good time,
and it wasn't that
big of a deal.
It didn't negatively impact
me in some dramatic way,
but I have so many friends
that it is horrible for.
It is all but
ruined their lives.
And it's totally legal,
which is kind of bizarre.
So I think that figuring
that out when I look back,
and the culture in the
SEAL Teams was very--
there was very alcohol centric.
And part of that is because
it's just like a fraternity is
alcohol centric,
or a football team
is because you got a
bunch of young dudes
that are going to drink
and have a good time.
So it's just sort of a
young dude kind of thing,
and unfortunately, it ends up
ruining a lot of people's lives
and they make bad decisions
and they do stupid things
and it's just not good.
And I think the culture
is moving away from that
a little bit in the SEAL Teams.
My alcohol brief
used to say, I used
to tell my guys if you
go out, you get a DUI,
you get put in jail
for a fight, you
get hurt because you're
doing something drunk,
you just did Al
Qaeda's job for them.
You just did al-Qaeda's job.
They want to take you
off the battlefield,
and you just took yourself
off the battlefield.
You can't go on deployment now.
And that would always hit guys.
And I think that
that's the SEAL Teams
kind of leaning in
that direction more,
realizing the
negativity of alcohol.
I wish I would have
realized that earlier.
been a better leader
and recognize that
in an earlier stage,
and recognize that just because
I was kind of getting away
with it, meaning I didn't
wake up in the morning,
oh, man, I can't wait to quit.
I never really had that feeling.
I wish I would have realized
that there's other guys that
do, and there's people that
can operate and be functional
and it doesn't really
impact their lives,
but there's a lot of
people that don't.
And I don't think it's worth
the dice roll to start drinking.
I just don't think it's
worth the dice for what
do you get out of it?
So I think that
overall that's why if--
when I think about alcohol, I
just think about all the lives
that it's ruined,
and I don't like it.
And I wish I would have
done a better job of saying,
you know what, this
is probably not good,
and we shouldn't do this.
And unfortunately I didn't, and
I try and convey that message
as much as I can now.
And it did bring me back to my
roots because when I was a kid,
it was like alcohol is weak,
and you look at these guys,
they don't know
what they're doing,
they're acting like idiots,
I'm not going to be like that.
And so as I got older, once
I got on the SEAL Teams,
I went back to that.
As far as where I became
me, I just actually
have to give a lot of credit
to the music that I grew up
listening to, and the attitude
that we had back then listening
to hardcore music,
being able to stand up
against what other people were
saying which is what you're
doing when you're in that scene,
and the whole DIY nature of it.
Hey, we can just
do this ourselves.
We can just make this
happen for ourselves.
We don't need anybody else.
We can do this.
And that hardcore attitude
and sticking by your friends
and standing up and
getting in fights
and that's what you're going to
do, that's kind of my attitude.
And I got interviewed
for a documentary
that they're making about Harley
Flanagan and the Cro-mags,
and when I was a kid and
actually through my whole life,
that music is the
soundtrack to my life.
And so I always would have
that music running in my head.
But to your question,
I had something in me
that when I heard that music for
the first time, I was like, OK,
here it is.
Here it is.
I hear the Beatles, I
hear the Grateful Dead,
I hear the Rolling
Stones, I hear whoever,
and you go, OK, that's fine.
But when I heard hardcore
music for the first time,
when I heard the Cro-Mags, when
I heard Agnostic Front, when
I heard the Bad
Brains, I thought
that was just like it
was part of me already.
And then it was the
attitude, and again you
can listen to my podcast
with Harley Flanagan,
the way I viewed Harley
Flanagan, the way I
viewed the Cro-Mags was not
the way they actually were.
I mean, Harley was doing
drugs, I mean, horrible drugs.
He was on heroin,
everything else,
but his image was like straight
edge, kind of spiritual,
they had all that stuff going
on and I thought, OK, well,
that's who they are.
But I didn't know,
I'm like a kid living
in the woods in
Connecticut, I'm just
glad to be hearing
what I'm hearing.
He listened to
the lyrics, listen
to the lyrics of Minor
Threat, listen to the lyrics
and you go, OK, this stuff,
I agree with this stuff.
And I just think
that that kind of
set a datum in my head of
being OK with being outside,
being OK with saying no,
being OK with being a rebel,
being OK with not
going along with what
everyone else is doing.
And that came that became
very important when
I was in the
military, and I looked
at what leadership might
be telling me to do
and might think to
myself, hey, that
doesn't seem like a
good idea, and having
the wherewithal
to say, hey, boss,
I'm not sure this
is a good idea.
Not to be a jerk
about it, but just
to say there might be a
better way to get this done.
What do you think of this?
Or, hey boss can I ask
you a question about that?
So I think if I had to trace it
back having Black Flag My War
side too on my record player
for like a year and a half
straight, that's going
to leave a mark, man.
And I think it
left a mark on me.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I love what you
just said, and when I say love,
I really mean it
because as we both know
we share a common love
for certain music,
in particular Minor Threat and
some stuff from the punk rock
scene.
In particular for me, the
Northeast punk rock scene,
the Bruisers, all borrowed from
the Bruisers, and now people
know him as the lead singer
for the Dropkick Murphys.
Before that was the Bruisers.
And we run the
risk of going deep
down a rabbit hole of music
that most people may or may not
be familiar with,
although most people have
heard the dropkicks, but yeah,
I'm right there with you.
I mean, I remember
the first time
hearing Stiff Little
Fingers or Rancid
and even Bouncing
Souls for New Jersey--
not even Bouncing Souls.
Sorry.
Sorry, Brian and Greg.
No, the Bouncing Souls
and going, yes, that's me.
That's it.
But as you said, it
was already in you.
It's like a recognition,
and I bring this up,
and I want to highlight
it, not because we
share this, although I do find
that to be an amazing kinship
that we felt right away, and
it was like we probably riffed
for 25 hours just on that.
But it brings me back
to this idea that--
certainly is not my idea.
Actually the first
time I heard about it
was from Robert Greene
who wrote the book
Mastery, and some important
writings, what was it?
I think it was the--
I forget how many laws of power,
but those books, Robert Green
Mastery is actually a book
that I highly recommend.
People read because it talks
about mentorship and finding
mentors and the fact that we're
supposed to break up and move
on from mentors, and that
mentors aren't always people
that we know or that
know us, et cetera.
Amazing book, really.
But he was the
first person I ever
heard describe this idea that
if we think back long enough,
there's some seed moment, they
were shopping for the pants,
it sounds like it was, but also
music where you see something
and it's like, yes,
that's me and I'm that.
And then that becomes
a sort of soundtrack
or visual image or
something for your life
that you carry forward with you.
The neuroscientist
in me wants to say
that that is the first
time that we really
tap into this dopamine system
in a way that is unique to us,
because every child
responds to food
with a little bit of dopamine
when we're hungry, responds
to warmth when we're cold,
responds to a warm dry diaper
after we just wet
ourselves, which we all did.
I don't know maybe, Jocko,
you change your own diapers.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm guessing that
someone changed your diaper
at one point, not an image
path we need to go down.
But the idea is that we all
have these universal sources
of having our needs met,
going from discomfort
to comfort and back again,
which is basically childhood.
But at some point,
something comes along
that we really feel
is unique to us,
and it may be the thing
that everyone else likes,
maybe it's top 40
or whatever it is.
Maybe it's the shoe
that everyone's
wearing that seems good.
But I do think that there
are certain people who
are kind of 10 or 20 or maybe
even 180 degrees off from what
everyone else likes and
they're like, that thing
is what's really cool,
and it's a felt thing.
And so along the lines of felt
things as opposed to things
that everyone values, what are
your sources of motivation.
And I'm going to guess that
some of them are internal.
We could point ahead or
we could point to heart.
Doesn't really
matter, but like when
you think of sources
of motivation,
do you have a palette of
them that you can dip into?
Do you even feel the
need to dip into them,
or is it really just
all about action steps
throughout your day?
Or if I can even venture
into somewhat harder stories
that I've heard
you talk about, do
you sometimes
think back, listen,
I'm going to do this because
there are a bunch of guys that
are dead now that
can't, and so I'm
going to do it because I can.
What are the paints on your
motivation pallet, if you will?
JOCKO WILLINK:
Well, you probably
heard me say that
motivation isn't something
that I am going to count
on because it's just
an emotion that's
going to come and go,
and it's just like
feeling happy.
You feel happy
right now, maybe you
won't feel happy in 15 minutes.
You feel sad now, maybe you
won't feel sad in 15 minutes.
You feel motivated
right now, you might not
feel motivated in 15 minutes.
Therefore I can't rely on it.
So I'm not going to put any--
I'm not going to put
any money on just
being motivated because it
doesn't really matter to me.
So the daily actions that I
take aren't from motivation,
they're just from discipline.
Like I said earlier,
I'm not going
to get up and go through
some big debate about,
well, do I really
feel like doing this?
No, I don't feel like doing
it, but doesn't matter,
so I'm just going to go do it.
Now if we start to look at a
broader movement through life
and continuing to try and
move forward and move on,
my buddy Seth died, and he was
the Delta Platoon commander
in tasking a bruiser.
And he died in 2017, and it
was in a parachute accident.
I mean, it's
definitely unexpected,
and also he'd already been
through multiple deployments,
was with me in the
Battle of Ramadi,
he then went back into
Sadr City and led a ton
of very dangerous operations.
And then he did
other deployments,
and was kind of done with his
deployments, kind of done.
And now he's just talking about
when he's going to retire,
and he's a couple of years
away from retirement,
and I'm talking
about, hey, we're
going to work together again.
And it all seems like
we're on a pretty good path
to just move forward.
And then he ends up dying
in a parachute accident.
And he's a guy that was
really just kind of you're
not going to be able to replace.
There's a uniqueness to him that
is you're not going to find,
and I've got some
stuff that he wrote.
He was an incredible writer,
and I try and write something
like him, and we
can't do it because he
had a bigger vocabulary and a
more articulate way of writing.
And so I can't write anything
as well as he wrote it.
He was incredible at guitar, he
played guitar, played ukulele
like sick, like an
incredible at playing guitar,
and he's a total
knuckle dragger.
Like a total meat
head knuckle dragger.
His nickname was
Unfrozen Caveman
because he just look
like a big caveman
and yet he spoke French, and
could recite French poetry.
And was really good
at learning languages,
and he was an artist,
and he had-- do
you know what synesthesia is?
Do you know that is?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: A
merging of the senses
so people that can
see colors and--
JOCKO WILLINK: So he
didn't know what it was--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'm
sorry, see colors.
I hope most people can
see colors-- sorry,
that can hear colors and can
associate particular colors
with sound like particular
keys on the piano.
It's pretty rare.
Some people think they have
it, but true synesthesia
are pretty rare, but they don't
have to fight for this trait.
It just kind of
emerges for them.
JOCKO WILLINK: He
didn't know it.
But one day he
was talking to me,
and he was embarrassed
to tell me.
He's like, what's weird is
when I think of numbers,
I have colors in my head.
And I go, what do you mean?
And he says, hollow was zero,
and I remember seven is yellow.
I don't remember any
of them, but he just
rattled off like 123456789.
He says, hollow, white, clear,
just rattled off these colors.
He had that synesthesia,
and it gave him
some kind of weird ability
to memorize numbers.
So he'd be in a bar and talk
to some girl and he'd say,
what's your number?
And he would just-- he
would know it for two years.
He would just know it.
And that also made
him incredibly
good at playing guitar
because now like the scale
and the fretboard of a guitar,
it's a mathematical thing
that he has all in this weird
coloration scenario going on.
So he's this guy and
a very emotional guy.
A very emotional guy who would--
I was talking earlier about
being a balance for someone.
I had to balance this dude out
on a daily basis sometimes.
He'd be so mad about something.
One day he'd be,
I hate the Teams.
I hate all these guys.
And I'd say, yeah,
I get it, man.
And the next day, I'm never
getting out of the Teams.
He would oscillate that
bad, and I would tell him,
hey, bro, you're
oscillating again,
and just would do anything.
And he loved these guys and
would do anything for his guys.
And so when he died, we're at
his-- it's not his funeral,
it's before the funeral.
It's like the open casket
thing, the wake thing,
and myself, his brother,
Alex, Leif Babin who
I wrote Extreme Ownership
with and JP O'Donnell, who's
one of my brothers who works
with us at Arsenal on Front
now is with us in Ramadi
and was very close to Seth,
and everyone kind of
cleared out for us.
And we go in there, and
I think JP gave him--
JP had one of those Memorial
bracelets with guys' names
on it that had died and
JP gave that to him.
And I think Leif gave him some
surf wax because also Seth
was a surfer, and I gave Seth
his black belt because he
started training jiu-jitsu with
me and he had his purple belt.
He had gotten his purple belt,
I gave him his black belt
and everyone was just quiet.
And JP was telling the
story the other day
and I just said, we
will not fail him,
meaning that him Mark,
Mikey, Chris, Seth,
and countless other
guys they're not here.
They don't have the opportunity
to do the things we do.
to get up in the morning.
So that's what it is, man.
I won't fail those guys.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Thanks
for sharing that.
Yeah, thank God.
Anyone listening
to this feels what
I feel right now, which is very
clear that the depth of emotion
for people that we
care about and lose
has everything to do
with our love for them.
There's just no
question about it.
The grief and love are
so intimately tied.
They are a direct
reflection of one another.
And I hesitate to kind
of stay on hard themes,
but I think it's really
important for a couple
of reasons.
Last time we spoke, it was in
your office and your podcast,
and after we wrapped
up, we started
talking about some
people we know
and some things that had
happened in your community,
and kind of spooled
into some discussions
about things that happened
in nearby communities
and civilian culture.
And one of the things
that's so perplexing
I think to people, including
me but maybe with time less so,
and this actually came up last
night in a discussion at home
because of some recent events,
not close to me, but is
that some people go through
things where there's loss,
they go through life
and there's hardship.
I think most people experience
some hardship certainly
some more than others.
And every once in a while
and far too often, and even
in the SEAL Team community, and
even in the various communities
within the SEAL Team community
where one would never
expect it, these are highly
trained tight community,
hard guys, that's the
language we sometimes hear,
but as you point out,
these are people often
that have tremendous
emotional depth.
And I'm so glad that you
brought that up because I think
we sometimes think of emotion as
weakness, but there was a time,
not long ago, 40, 50 years ago,
where emotions like jealousy
and intensity,
think the character
Sonny and the Godfather, he
would get so pissed, he would
bite his own fist, that's
a pretty emotional response
where intensity and emotion were
kind of interchangeable words
at some level.
I'm going to be direct.
There have been a lot of guys
coming out of the SEAL Teams.
I've been surprised to
hear they kill themselves,
and yesterday there
was a major suicide.
I didn't know this
guy in person,
we actually followed each
other on social media,
but I admittedly was not close
to him, didn't know him at all.
In fact, his name was Twitch or
something, and he was this guy,
he was a public facing figure.
But listen, happens all
too often, and even happens
in former operators.
And suicide is something that
fascinates me and intrigues me
and scares the hell out of me
because for the life of me,
I cannot map it to any specific
thing in the brain or body that
we're aware of, and yet I've had
several friends commit suicide,
had my undergrad advisor
committed suicide.
The point is not
them or their story.
The point is what in the
world dictates whether or not
somebody who has a community,
who's doing well and then less
well decides to offer themselves
to end their own life,
versus decide I'm
going to keep going?
I mean, this is I'm
raising this as a question.
I wish I had an answer I used to
have ideas like, Oh, it's time
perception.
These people are so miserable,
feeling so miserable
that they feel it's
going to go on forever.
But then you start reading
the literature on suicide,
and I've started
to go into this.
For those of you
that can stomach it,
and I don't know that I
want to recommend this movie
but I'm just going to say it
exists, the movie The Bridge
where they fix the camera on the
Golden Gate Bridge for a year,
it turns out one person a day
on average tries to jump off.
They talk to a guy
who survived it.
By the way he jumped off the
moment he went off there.
He thought I wish
I hadn't done that.
He survived.
This kid with bipolar.
Bipolar disorder, especially
males, 20 to 30 times
higher incidents of suicide.
Massive increase.
The point is that
there's something
that happens in the brain
where somehow people also
will get the idea, and you hear
this, that this is something
they're excited to
do, or that they're
going to write the world
somehow by doing this,
or that somehow it's like
a gift to themselves.
Again, I'm not encouraging
anybody to do this.
I want to be very clear,
but these are the things
that you hear.
And sadly, your community
has lost a number of people
through suicide, and yet there
are a lot of guys that thrive.
And so more as a
template for trying
to understand mental health and
depression and suicide, what
are your thoughts on why
some people seem to thrive,
and some people just
go all the way down?
JOCKO WILLINK: Clearly, that's
a very complex question,
and there's probably a
lot of different answers.
And I certainly am not one to
be able to answer that question.
However, probably
where my thought
has gone on this
lately because I've
known some guys that have
killed themselves and I've
been totally shocked, and just
been completely and totally
shocked that guys that I
knew killed themselves.
Guys that you would
think, Oh, this guy
would never do this
in a million years.
And that's the feeling I've
had about a lot of the guys
that I know that have
killed themselves.
I had a woman on my podcast
named Sarah Wilkinson,
and she's an awesome woman,
and she was married to a SEAL.
His name was Chad.
I didn't know him.
He killed himself.
And to hear her
describe the story,
the shocking thing
about the story
is that the guy that she
knew, the guy that she married
was not the same guy
that killed himself.
Something happened to him that
made him a different person.
And look, they're getting
all this information
now about CTE and the brain
trauma that you go through,
and people are exposed to that.
And I think if you've ever
seen George Foreman, he
seems totally normal and
good to go, and Muhammad Ali,
not so much.
And I've known
fighters, and you can
look at any number of boxers
that have had a career,
and some of them are
fine, and some of them
have some real significant--
what is it?
Pugilistic.
There's a pugilistic syndrome.
They've been punched too
much and they have problems.
You can expose different
people to blast impact,
and it's going to have a
different impact over time.
And I think that, again, to
hear Sarah explain that story
and what she saw
from her husband
and how different
he was when they
got married compared
to where they ended up,
it's totally different.
A totally different person.
I had another friend of mine
on who named Marcus Capone,
and his wife came on with him,
and she said the same thing.
The guy that she married
was not the same guy
that was ready to kill himself,
and he didn't, thankfully.
It was a different person.
Look, if Fred is
married to some woman,
and Fred and Jessica
grow apart over time
and he ends up with some other
girl, it's still the same guy.
it's still the same guy that
is now, look, they grew apart,
they're getting
divorced, we get it.
But the way that both of
them described their husbands
as being different people.
That's what stuck with me
more than anything else.
So I-- again, I'm
throwing this out there
only because it's what I've
observed through the people
that I know, and
seeing and hearing
those stories of people
being totally different.
And I've known a few people--
one of my friends,
Dave, killed himself.
I never would have
guessed in a million years
that Dave would kill himself.
It just it doesn't compute.
It doesn't compute.
And so my suspicion is there
has to be something going
on mechanically or chemically
with the brain that causes them
to get into a mode
where they're depressed
and they don't see a
way out, and that's
the way they feel now.
And again, what's
interesting about this is
we already talked about the
fact that the selection process
weeds out guys that are
going to take a loss
and not be able to get up again.
No, you've got--
SEALS can take a loss
and get back up again.
That's what you learn
how to do in bed.
Well, that's what you-- you
don't lean how to do it,
you have it.
And if you make it
through that training,
you have that ability to
take a loss, all right, cool.
Shake it off, get
back up, keep going.
They're going to do that to you.
So now you've got guys
that are taking a loss
and they don't see
a way out anymore,
in fact, to such a
point that they're
going to take their
own lives, it's
my suspicion is at some point
they're going to figure out
that this exposure to the
adrenaline, the explosions
all the time--
I mean, you go out
to a range-- just
in peacetime-- you
go out to a range,
and you shoot a Carl Gustav.
And you're a range
safety officer,
so you go out there
with every guy that's
shooting a Carl Gustav, it's
a big, giant, like bazooka
looking weapon.
And every time you shoot it, it
rattles your cage a little bit.
Well, if you're a range safety
officer, and you're out there,
and you're going to watch
everyone in the platoon
shoot three of those, it's
going to have an impact.
Then you go overseas,
and you're a breacher,
or you're part of
a breach team--
I mean, I had a time
where one of my guys
were doing an assault
on a compound.
I'm on the ladder--
most buildings in Iraq
have a wall around them.
So the way we would conduct
these raids, put the ladder up,
the assault--
breach team would
climb over the ladder,
and I would go right
behind the breach team,
and I would stand on the ladder.
So I'm looking at the
building, observing,
making sure there's
no waking up,
make sure there's no threats.
And then as I'm watching,
this guy in particular,
he puts the breach on the
door, explosive breach,
so he's going to
blow the door up.
He's got his little
team with him.
He puts the breach on the door.
He starts to back away, and
there's like an obstacle there.
It was like a freaking table,
or a lawn chair, or something.
And he couldn't get around it.
And I'm sitting there.
It's dark.
I mean, it's the
middle of the night.
It's 2:00 o'clock
in the morning.
And I'm like, I wonder
what he's going to do.
And he seem stuck for a second.
And then I just
see him lay down.
And I'm like oh, he's just
going to take this thing.
And sure enough, three
or four feet away
from this breech point, he
lays down and just clacks off
this explosive charge.
And I jump over the wall.
And as I'm going in, I'm trying
to get the rest of the platoon
to go and commence this
assault. I look at him,
he looked like he just
got hit in the head
with a baseball bat.
And guess what he
did the next night?
Another breach on
another target.
Guess what he did
the next night?
Another breach on
another target.
So you get guys that have
that exposure, which is--
I mean, every seal
is eating a breach.
I mean, you're
eating flashbangs,
you're eating breaches,
you're shooting 50 cals.
You're eating some
traumatic brain injury.
But then you must
have some people
that have some
genetic propensity
to have this negative
thing happen.
And I can only
guess, man, that this
has something to do with
it because otherwise, we
wouldn't be hearing so
many of these stories.
And of course, we're just
talking about the SEAL Teams.
We're not talking about the
military writ large, which
is in the same exact boat.
I'm also nervous about the
social contagion of suicide
within the veteran community.
I'm nervous about that.
It's one of the
things that makes
me apprehensive about
talking about it,
but I obviously I've
talked about it.
I've had people on my podcast
to discuss these things,
but I am worried about that
social contagion of man,
Fred did it.
He got all this attention,
and he doesn't have
to deal with anything anymore.
I'm going to do it too.
There's got to be some level
of that going on as well.
So it's a horrible situation.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
the social contagion part
is one that hits home from
a different dimension.
The high school I
went to which is--
name isn't important.
But Gunn High School, G-U-N-N.
Gunn High School is famous
for being one of the
better public high schools.
Not that I attended as
much as I should have.
I can tell you more about
the curbs in the parking lot
than I could tell you
about the classes I took.
And that's just not
encouraging people
to not attend high school.
Please do it.
Took a lot of really hard
work to climb back up
to where I should have
been when I graduated.
But it has an
infamous reputation,
or I'll say reputation
as an infamous school
because it's one of the
highest suicide rates than any
of the schools in the
country because there's
train tracks that
run through town,
and there was a contagion
of kids throwing themselves
on the train tracks.
This was happening a lot.
This was written up in
various newspapers, et cetera.
Fortunately, it seems
to have died down.
Again, I'm also hesitant
to talk about this
because no one
wants to spark this.
But there does seem to be
something about lack of ability
to see into a future obviously.
Or the future that
people are seeing into
is so dark that somehow they
lose touch with the idea
that emotions come and go.
You said it about motivation,
emotions come and go.
But somehow people
lose touch with that.
And then I will venture a guess.
And here I'm hoping someone's
going to figure this out
at some point so
we can have a more
concrete conversation
about the mechanisms
and what to do about it.
But I think there's also
something about identity,
about loss of a place
to put one's energy.
Something useful in the world.
If you're agenda-- what
you're talking about here
are guys that are generators.
They are not projectors,
they're generators.
They live to have effective
action on the world for good
and then end up
killing themselves.
In youth, it's a little more
complicated to put a finger
on because what's
going on there.
We assume depression.
But then in learning
more about suicide,
there is also this
excitement for certain people
about solving
something that seemed
unsolvable any other way.
And again, I'm certainly
not encouraging this.
I-- strongly discouraging people
from taking their own life,
obviously.
But something about time and the
loss of perception about time.
And one thing that
we know for sure here
we can really hang
our hat on something
is that if you do the forensics
on somebody that was suicidal,
attempted, or took their
life, in the preceding
days and weeks, their sleep-wake
schedule was completely wacked.
They exit the normal
routine of most people.
They isolate through
inversions of time.
And I do wonder
sometimes whether or not
the vampire ships,
as they're sometimes
called, the
nighttime deployment,
and the back and
forth, I mean, that's
a lot for a system to take.
Shift workers kill themselves
far more than nonshift workers.
So I do think there's
something there.
And again, I'm not
saying everyone needs
to be in bed by
9:00 and up by 4:00.
Although that would be a great
schedule for most people.
But I do think that there are
some universal laws of what
makes the human body
and brain healthy.
And if you violate
those laws long enough
with CTE, or with disruption
in your schedules,
you run the risk, especially if
there's a predisposition there.
And then other factors
start to layer in.
Again-- and I have to
apologize because I
don't have any real answers,
or more biology, or psychology
to firmly throw out
this except the warning
for people who are bipolar or
know somebody with bipolar.
They are 20 to 30 times more
likely to kill themselves.
And males in particular
are more likely to use
methods that will kill them
in the first time as opposed
to survive.
There's a big sex
difference there.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
You throw alcohol in there too.
And Marcus is running
an organization now
where they're taking vets
down to do the psychedelic--
what do they call it?
A journey.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
this is Veterans Solutions?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: They
are a great organization.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And I
should mention a very
bipartisan organization.
I attended one
event on Coronado.
And there were people
from the far-left,
the far-right politicians,
and everything
in between talking about
how critical this is.
So this is not a
political issue.
This is a mental health issue.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, and even
when I reflected on Marcus
talking to me, he
was talking about how
he's in this downward spiral.
Part of the downward spiral,
he was drinking every day.
And I'm thinking to
myself, man, like--
I didn't think of
it during the show.
I was thinking
about it afterwards.
I was thinking, man, if
you're drinking all the time,
you're on a downward spiral.
That's one thing you
should just stop.
Let's stop that immediately.
So I just wanted to
throw that out there.
I think that's another sign
from the outside looking in.
If someone's self-medicating
with alcohol,
it's not a good place,
not a good place.
They're not in a good place,
and they could probably
use some help.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I appreciate
you saying it again.
We did this episode on alcohol.
I went into it
totally open minded.
I've never been a big drinker.
I've had it.
I can drink or not drink.
I was never really
into drugs at all.
Dabbled a little bit
when I was younger.
I regret it frankly.
Brain is plastic early
on, I didn't need that.
Never did hard drugs.
Never touched cocaine,
amphetamine, or anything
like that.
And if I had, I would say.
I'm comfortable enough in my
position in life that if I had,
I'd certainly say.
But I think that it's pretty
clear that alcohol is bad
for us certainly past a
certain two drink a week limit.
People especially with a
propensity for alcoholism
or who are dealing with other
issues, that's especially
the case for not drinking.
And I guess we've gotten into
some hard territory here.
But I think if this
conversation cues up
an awareness to anybody,
which I hope it would,
either people that are in
that space of wondering
if they should continue or not,
or that know somebody who might
be, I do think that the
takeaway is very clear,
which is that there are
ways to avoid these traps
and to avoid making
these traps worse.
And I think with regular
sleep-wake schedules,
understanding that--
and I wrote this down
that you've particular have
said several times that
rather than looking for sources
of things outside like a job,
or a relationship,
which are all great.
But as sources of energy, or
motivation, or inspiration,
to use positive action
as a source of energy.
I think is just--
if I could put that up on a
billboard in Times Square,
I would.
And I'd put your
name next to it,
which is that positive
action is a source of energy
that then you can
recycle into more things.
I think--
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --going back
to the fundamentals, right?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
And positive action is when you
have to contend with something.
When there's something that
you're afraid of, step into it,
move towards it.
That's how you're going
to solve that problem.
You don't you don't
solve problems
by running away from them.
You solve them by
moving towards them
and figuring out
what's going on.
And I mean, alcohol is
obviously a clear way
to avoid the problem at least
for the next four hours.
And you wake up, and that
problem is still there.
And that's not good.
But when you've got some
problem-- and listen,
then we could go
down the whole path
of talking about the
indirect approach, which
is a theory of combat which
I completely believe in.
But it also applies to
interacting with other people.
If you have a problem with
some other person, to think,
oh, I got a problem with Andrew.
I'm going to go
confront him on it.
And that might not
be the best solution.
In fact, it's probably
not the best solution
for me to go confront
you with the problem
because now we're going
to have a confrontation.
It might be better for me
to take an indirect approach
and not confront
you but instead,
engage in a
conversation with you
about something that's maybe
adjacent to the problem
that I have.
And then eventually that
builds our relationship
to a point where you
start to recognize,
oh, I bet Jocko feels
something about this thing.
And we can move towards a
solution instead of me trying
to punch you in the
face with some truth
that I believe versus the
truth that you believe.
And now we're engaged in
combat, and that's bad.
There's going to be casualties.
I'd rather take an
indirect approach
and build a relationship
where we can solve problems
in a more positive way.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I love that.
And I love it because
it really speaks
to the power of thinking
carefully and being
patient and a little
bit slower at times.
I also heard you say
something earlier that's
still flagging in my mind,
which is not thinking too much.
I think seems to be a time
where thinking too much
is very dangerous.
And again, we can
keep the discussion
that we were having
about mental health,
or we could even just call it
what it is, mental illness.
I think everyone would agree
suicide is some reflection
of an unhealthy state.
We can keep that in the
backdrop as we talk about this,
but this isn't necessarily
only about that.
You seem to have an
ability to engage in things
without thinking too much.
And yet also to sit back
and be pretty observant.
And you've talked about
third personing of the self.
I'd love to talk a little
bit more about this
even though it's a topic
you've delved into before.
And in particular the
topic of meditation.
I've been reading
more about meditation.
I've meditated for different
stretches in my life,
different amounts of time.
And there are two basic
forms of meditation
that I only recently
learned about.
One is a focused
attention meditation.
Your sitting, closing your eyes,
focusing on your breath, body,
body surface, or
even a visual target
in your environment
and just focus.
And we know that enhances
one's ability to focus.
If you do too late
in the day, it also
enhance your ability
to not fall asleep.
A lot of people don't realize
that meditation too late
in the day, if it's
a focused meditation,
you're just ramping
up the activity
in the prefrontal cortex.
It's a great tool for
getting better at focusing.
But then there's also
this type of meditation
called open observer meditation
where you purposefully
don't include a target in
your mind, or in your vision,
or in your hearing.
And you just sit there, eyes
closed, your eyes open, and you
go into a place of
whatever comes up,
but you don't hover
there too long.
The goal is to not
hover on any one thing,
which sounds like deliberate
attention deficit disorder.
But it's actually a
pretty cool method
it turns out for
restoring our ability
to engage in focus but also
for one particular thing
that you mentioned earlier,
which is creativity
and creative problem solving,
which of course, requires
accessing, let's
just say, more colors
on the palette than
your vision might be on.
Realizing, oh, there's
also all these other colors
over here in the
periphery that I'm missing
because I'm hyperfocused.
Do you meditate?
If you do meditate, is it
more of an open monitoring
or a focused meditation?
And if you don't do a
standard meditation,
are there times throughout
your day, and your routine,
and your week where as
I'm describing this,
it maps to something that
feels like open monitoring
or focused meditation?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, so
no, I don't meditate.
I haven't ever.
I don't think I've
ever actually meditated
for one second in my life.
And I--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
And I refuse to.
JOCKO WILLINK: --no, no,
it's not that at all.
I know Sam Harris
sent me his app,
and we were going
to do a podcast.
And I said, dude, I'll
do it for two weeks,
and we'll do a podcast, and
I'll be more enlightened
and everything.
And I didn't even give
Sam Harris two weeks.
So I still owe Sam Harris two
weeks on his app of meditation
so we can see how it impacts me.
But no I've never
done it before.
I've never tried to do it.
And that being
said, if the goal is
to take a step back and
detach from what's going on,
I do that all day, every day.
And so that is something
that I've talked about,
and it's something
I tried to teach.
I tried to teach the
young SEAL leaders not
to get caught up in
what's happening right
in front of them
but to take a step
back, detach from the situation,
detach from their emotions.
See more of what's happening.
You're talking about seeing
more colors of the palette,
well, on the battlefield,
I want people
to be able to see more
angles, more maneuvers, more
opportunities, more of
what the enemy might do,
more perspective.
That's what I always
try to achieve.
And so I'm sorry, I
apologize, I can't give you
any good discussion
on meditation
because I haven't tried it.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: No
apology necessary.
But I will ask,
when you go surfing,
and you're sitting in the
water waiting for a wave,
are you focused on one
particular location
on the horizon, or are
you in open monitoring,
just enjoying just bouncing
up and down in the water.
Like where is your attention
during activities like that?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
So surfing-- oftentimes
surfing, you're a monkey mind,
and you're just not
thinking about anything.
Same thing with jujitsu.
Also with surfing, if
you're waiting for a wave,
your mind is just going.
I mean, it's in another
universe sometimes as you're
sitting there waiting because
you're just looking out
at the horizon.
And your mind-- I mean, my mind,
I'm thinking about all kinds--
I have to come home
sometimes and write notes
because I thought of this,
I thought of an idea,
I thought of a perspective.
That happens to me at jujitsu.
That happens to me talking
to people where someone's
talking about something,
I'm like oh, I
got an idea right now.
I would go write that down.
I have to go and write it down.
I have notes in my phone
like pages and pages
and pages of notes in my
phone of ideas that I have,
and I write them down.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Do you
voice memo things or do--
JOCKO WILLINK: No, I type them.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --yeah.
JOCKO WILLINK: I only need
to type like seven words on
and then I have the
whole ideas in my head.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I put a lot
into the notes in my phone
as well.
And it probably looks like
gibberish to a lot of people.
I go back through them when
I'm on the plane, especially
problems I was challenged with
10 years ago or something.
And I look like, oh,
my God, I'm dealing
with the same thing, different
situation, same me, right?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: We had
an amazing psychiatrist
on the show, but I'd love
to hear a conversation
between the two of you.
His name is Paul Conti.
He was trained at
Stanford and Harvard.
He's an amazing guy.
Actually, talks openly
about the tragedy
that his brother killed
himself, which was
what drove him into psychiatry.
And he's an interesting guy
because he's obviously highly
educated, incredibly smart.
He wrote a book on trauma, but
he has incredible knowledge
about a number of other
areas of psychology,
including narcissism,
sociopathy.
He's worked in a lot of
really interesting domains
with interesting people
that everyone listening
on his podcast would recognize.
Of course, he's not going to
reveal who those people are.
And he talks about
the fact that you
can look at different people.
He was actually the one that
shared with me this notion
of generators and
projectors, and directed me
towards that literature.
But when he came
on the podcast, he
talked a little bit
about that stuff,
but he talked
mostly about trauma.
But then we were
talking about ways
in which people engage in the
world and different archetypes.
And how you start looking at
stories throughout history,
and you start seeing the
same themes over and over.
Westerns, this
idea of a guy rides
into town and does
some repair work like
defeats the sinister
person or things
that are imposing all the time
then rides to the next town.
It's always like it ends with--
it's going to keep continuing.
But then when he got into this
discussion of relationship,
he talks about-- he said this
on the podcast of a patient who
said, I've been in 10
abusive relationships.
And he'd say to that
patient, no, you've
been in one relationship 10
times, which is essentially
it's all about your issue.
That's not you.
I'm not-- purposely didn't point
at you for those listening.
And I think that those
features of ourselves
that we bring from condition
to condition can be negative
or they can be positive.
One thing that's
interesting-- and here I'm
not trying to solve or
understand the SEAL team
community per se, but
I think they represent
an important archetype
because they are selected
for this ability to take
hard conditions and failures
and turn them into wins.
That's one of the selection
criteria, seems to be.
They're finding who
has that capability.
I see a lot of-- and I happen to
know a few people from the SEAL
Teams who get out
and do really well.
They have great business.
You're a shining
example of this.
And you have a
family, and you know
you've got German shepherd too.
We'll talk about
animals in a little bit.
You have a dog.
And it's like you
surf, and you train.
And I'm sure you have your
dark places, dark moments
and challenges
like anybody else,
but things look to me like
they're going pretty well.
And then I also know
people from the SEAL Teams.
OK, they don't go down the
path of suicide fortunately.
But it's they don't do as
well as I would have thought.
And I'm certainly not
picking on this community.
I also see this from people
who are professional athletes.
I know kids that were
phenomenal in high school.
I mean, these are
like early admission
to all the Ivy League
schools because that
was what happened in the
town that I grew up in.
And I look at them now, and
I'm like, wow, That-- gosh,
it didn't-- somehow
it's not working out.
And I think it's
important for people
to hear that yes, winning
creates the propensity for more
winning.
But then why do you think
it is that in a community
where people are trained to
solve problems, adapt, and make
things work, some people
flourish outside the military,
and some flourish
less, and some--
we already talked about--
really go down the dark traps.
What do you think is
the quality that allows
people to be really adaptable?
In particular, because most
of us live in a landscape
where we have to deal with
people who are not us.
Like people that are not
good at what we're good at.
And sometimes that's an
asset, sometimes it's not.
You seem to be particularly
good at understanding
the human animal and
working with that.
So again, this is
a broad question.
We're going very broadband here,
and we'll get narrower again
in a little bit.
But I'd love your
thoughts on why is it?
How is it?
What determines
whether or not somebody
thrives in novel environments?
JOCKO WILLINK: I have
to start off just
by saying I wrote a note
as you were talking.
I just put SEAL and then
I put the not equals sign.
Because you can't say that
a SEAL equals anything.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Excellent point.
JOCKO WILLINK: I
mean, there's guys
that have been in the SEAL
Teams that are murderers.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Like
real life murderers.
JOCKO WILLINK: Like murderers.
Like rapists and murderers that
went through SEAL training.
Rapists, murderers,
and they're in prison
for the rest of their lives.
Like that's a thing.
There's people that have been in
the SEAL Teams that got kicked
out of SEAL Teams for drugs.
I mean, you name it,
and we've got that.
And we've got guys that are just
lazy, and we've got guys that--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
And physicians-- you
could say this about physicians.
There have been sociopathic
serial killer physicians
and then there are ones that
are in third world countries
right now that would not
accept $1,000,000,000 to stop
serving people at the
level of the basic medicine
that they deserve.
JOCKO WILLINK: So
there's the seals
that get out and just volunteer
to go help in the worst
places in the world.
So you've got a full
spectrum of people.
So to say a SEAL equals
success in any domain,
the only domain you can
say that they're successful
is they made it through
basic SEAL training
because guys make it
through basic SEAL training,
and they're not good SEALs.
That happens.
So you get guys that make it
through basic SEAL training,
and they make it through
SEAL qualification training,
and they make it to
a SEAL team, and they
get kicked out of the SEAL Teams
because they're not good SEALs.
They weren't meant
to do that job.
That happens.
So all they've proven by making
it through basic SEAL training
is they can suck
it up for a while.
And there's also guys that make
it through basic SEAL training
because they learned how to
maneuver through the system.
They learned what
to do, and what
the minimum requirements
were, and how
they could skate through this.
There's guys like that.
It's not a huge number, but
they're absolutely there.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: We
see them in science.
People that go to a lab, figure
out who the director of the lab
is at the level of psychology--
and this is actually
one of the more dangerous
aspects of science.
It actually negatively
impacts all of society.
I'll just say it.
And any scientist will know
what I'm talking about.
They find the big famous
labs, they figure out
who that leader of the
lab is, and they get
that person the data they want.
They might not make the data
up, but they will certainly
discard the data
that don't fit, which
is one way of making
data up by exclusion.
It's not literally like
painting pictures of cells
that aren't there or something.
But that happens a lot, and
those people often go far.
They rarely go all the
way because pretty soon
their reputation
expands to the point
where people go like, yeah,
no one can repeat that result.
But these people sit
in very high positions.
Not at Stanford.
I will say, I don't know
any of my colleagues
at Stanford that
meet those criteria.
But you see them, and you
see what they're doing,
and they're basically solving
a social engineering thing.
They just happen to be
doing it in science.
Now, why anyone would
do that in science?
I don't know because you
don't get rich in science.
You certainly don't get famous.
But for whatever
reason, they figured it
out that that's where
they're going to do it.
And I'm sure you
see it in law firms.
I'm sure you see it in
every single domain--
JOCKO WILLINK: Everything
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
JOCKO WILLINK: Now,
you pointed out
that there's some people that
make it to the Ivy League
schools, and they graduate
from an Ivy League school,
and they don't do well.
And to me, that's very similar
to someone that might make it
to the SEAL Teams, do
well in the SEAL Teams,
and then they get out,
and they don't do well.
It's probably because of what
I talked about earlier when
I went to Navy boot camp.
Here's what you got to do.
If you do it well,
you'll be rewarded.
Well, if you're in high school,
and your mom and dad say, hey,
if you do good in
high school, you're
going to get into this
Ivy League school,
and you get into that
Ivy League school.
And here's what you need
to do in high school,
you need to get good grades.
You need to be part
of the Glee club.
You need whatever the things
are that you got to do.
You've got to speak
a different language.
You've got to go volunteer in
Guatemala in the summertime.
You've got to do these
things, and then you'll
get into the good college.
Once you get into
the good college,
you've got to get this degree.
Once you get that degree--
So they've had a path laid out
for them of boxes to check,
and they go and check the boxes.
And then when they
get done, no one
has put any more boxes
out in front of them,
so they don't know what to do.
And that can certainly happen
from someone in the SEAL Teams,
or someone in the military
that what they've been-- hey,
this is your mission.
This is what you've got to do.
Here's what you need
to do, do it well.
Check the box.
And then it's time to retire,
and there's no one putting
a box in front of him to check.
And so unless someone--
some guys get out
of the SEAL Teams,
and they go into a big corporate
structure, and they kick ass.
Because there's someone in
the corporate world saying,
hey, here's what
you got to do next.
And they do great.
And that's super good for
them, and they actually
really like it.
I was talking to a
guy the other day.
He's like full on
in a corporation.
He's doing a great job.
He likes what he's doing.
It's awesome.
But I think you get some
guys that they don't really
have the open mind to see
where opportunities are.
And one thing that's
nice about the SEAL Teams
is there's a lot of--
you get a lot of
freedom of maneuver.
You can really do a lot of
stuff that you want to do.
And so when they look
at the corporate world,
they don't see that,
and they think,
oh, I'm not going to do that.
But then they're not quite
sure how to take the next step.
So I think that's why you
might see some guys that
aren't super successful
because they don't really
know what to do.
And they don't really
have a mind that's
open to look for opportunities.
And also you got some
guys that success for them
is they're going to hang
out with their family,
and they're going to
get in good shape,
and they're going to run some
triathlons or compete in--
whatever they're going to do,
they're going to go do it,
and that's what they're looking
to do, which is also awesome.
Go take time, go enjoy
your family, man.
You gave enough to your country.
Go hang out with your kids.
That's success as far
as I'm concerned too.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I agree there.
I know far too
many people who are
successful in their
professional lives
but who have very
diminished personal lives,
and it is not a pretty picture.
You mentioned the parent driving
the kid, do this, do that.
In that scenario, I
sense tons of fear.
It's all about not
being a failure.
It's not actually about love of
your craft or what you enjoy.
Pretty early in
my science career,
I learned that there are certain
people are just ambitious.
They just like to win.
And I used to joke around.
It's not polite,
but I used to go,
we should all just
tell that person
that the new cool thing
is trying to understand
the biology of like--
and I would say
feces or something.
And they'd probably work on it.
They'd be like, yeah, it's
like the greatest thing
because they actually don't
care what they're working on.
For them it's just the hunt.
And I learned that
actually people like that
can serve an important role
because like well, there's
actually a whole microbiome.
There are actually labs
that do work on feces,
so forgive me my colleagues
that work on microbiomes.
But in all seriousness,
people who are just ambitious
can be very
effective because you
put a problem in front of
them, and it's like a dog,
they'll just retrieve.
It's they're just go.
As opposed to love
of retrieving--
for retrieving sake.
It's like you give that same
dog-- the analogy here would
be give that same
dog a high jump,
and they're into high
jumping, or whatever
it is, or diving underwater.
But I think of people
more like animals and more
like different dog species.
Like we-- as your case was
with music, particular music,
and communities, or the example
of shopping for the pants
and that experience
of the first time
you tap into something that
really feels unique to you.
You're like there's
something here.
To be able to find work that
includes that but also is
hard and also allows
you to evolve over time,
I mean, I think that's
the real gift that I
think most people are seeking.
And of course,
there's no shortcut
to that except
perhaps one, which
is to be able to sense the
difference between ambition.
And there's no
better word for it,
let's just call it what
it is, which is love.
Like I love this.
And the reason I think
that love is so powerful--
and here I'm sounding
like Lex Fridman--
but I don't mean
interelational love.
I mean, being able to sense what
that feels like is that I do
believe that it allows us to
tap into an enormous number
of things that fear alone and
ambition alone and just being
a hard driving person alone
will not allow us to tap into.
Things like
adaptiveness, creativity.
And I think there's a really
obvious reason for it, which
is that the one thing we
know about our species
is that we want to
make more of ourselves
and to take good
care of our young.
Whether or not everyone has
kids or not is irrelevant.
The point is that every species
not only wants to do that
but need to do that.
And the feeling
of love is really
what allows us to be adaptable.
I don't think there's anything
that trains up adaptability as
much as being around kids.
You just have to be
adaptable because they're
one moment they're
up then they're
down then they're disappointed.
And you shared a
really important story
about loss of somebody
that clearly you loved
and that clearly loved the
community he worked in.
It wasn't just that
you guys loved him,
It's that he loved you guys.
And I think that being able to
tap into these feelings of love
for things, for people,
and for experiences,
I think is so critical.
And I don't meditate
much these days,
but I have heard of this
love and kindness meditation.
And it sounds so soft to me.
I was thinking like, gosh,
what am I supposed to do?
Then float like
levitate at the end?
And wear a mumu or
whatever it's called.
I don't know what's the thing.
But my friend who I'm
fortunate to call a friend.
Not trying to name
drop here, but I'm
very fortunate to call
Rick Rubin, the music
producer, a friend.
And he was the one
who started turning me
on to different
forms of meditation,
the ones I mentioned before.
And this idea that there
are forms of meditation
which put us in touch with
what he calls the source.
Now, this is really
getting a little mystical,
but I think this all maps
back to the same thing, which
is that there are
sources of dopamine
and the other
neurotransmitters in us that
give us a super power
to adapt to anything.
And I think it's at
least includes love
because that's the most
adaptable emotion by definition
because of what's
required for evolution.
So the question
therefore is, in yourself
and in your observation of
people that you've worked with,
did you ever sense that just
being hard driving was great
but it was limiting?
Did you ever sense that
by liking the people
you work with you could perform
much better even if they
perhaps were not as hard--
to kind of borrow the common
parlance around this--
they weren't as hard
as everybody else?
That because you
like each other so,
so much that you
can do anything?
JOCKO WILLINK: Well, if you
have a team of 10 people,
and you all have a
great relationship
and you get along well, and
you're going against my team
and we all hate each
other, who's going to win?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: The team
that loves each other
is going to win, I would hope.
JOCKO WILLINK: It's
not even close.
It's not even--
a matter of fact,
if you work for me
and you don't like me,
what performance are
you going to give me?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's
going to be tough.
JOCKO WILLINK: What
if you love me,
and I've looked out for you, and
I've done everything for you,
and I've taken care of you,
what kind of performance
are you going to give me?
Everything you've got.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
I'd die for you.
JOCKO WILLINK: So
yeah, earlier you
asked about the human
animal and human nature.
And this is part of leadership.
I got asked this question
the other day by--
I was working with a company.
And the guy says,
how do I identify--
what are the characteristics
of someone that can execute,
and how do I identify those
characteristics in a person
so that I can get those people?
And I said, well, first of
all, the characteristics
are the characteristics that
everybody is-- obviously,
someone that's driven, someone
that communicates well,
someone that's going
to make things happen,
those are pretty simple to know.
We know what they are.
How do you identify them?
It's pretty simple as well.
I give you a task.
I give Andrew a task.
It's pretty simple task.
If you get it done, cool.
Give you a little bit
more complex task.
Do you get it done?
Yes.
I give the same task to
Fred, he doesn't get it done.
He comes back with a
bunch of questions.
He slow rolls it.
He's got all kinds of
excuses and problems.
I give you an even
more complex task,
you come back, you get it done.
And then I'm going
to realize, OK,
Andrew is the guy that
makes things happen.
He's a guy that can
actually execute.
A little bit what you said.
I mean, there are certain breeds
of dogs but even that is--
they're not as different
as human beings are.
And there are-- so now
there are some guys--
I've got Andrew who
will make things happen.
Here's the problem with Andrew.
When I say, hey, Andrew, here's
this nebulous idea that I have.
Can you turn this
into a reality?
And you're like,
where do I start?
I'm not sure where
you want me to go.
Meanwhile, I gave
it to the guy that
didn't make anything happen with
specific tasks that I gave him.
And he comes back and says--
I said, hey, I got
this nebulous idea.
Can you see-- he goes, oh yeah.
And all of a
sudden, he takes it.
He says, hey, I figured out
a way to make this happen.
So you might have someone
that's very good at executing,
but they're not very creative.
I might have somebody
that's very creative,
but they're not very
good at executing.
So what do I do?
I build a team where
I've got Andrew and Fred,
and they work together.
And Fred comes up
with good ideas,
and we bring them to Andrew, and
Andrew goes and executes them.
So that's what we're
doing from a leadership
perspective is we're letting
people's nature execute.
We're putting people
into roles where
their nature is beneficial.
I'm not going to take someone
that's shy and introverted
and put them out in
a lead sales role.
I'm not going to
take somebody that's
boisterous and extroverted
and put them into a cubicle
where they're
going to be looking
at spreadsheets all day.
Clearly, I'm not
going to do that.
So what we have to
do as leaders is
we have to find the right
people for the right role,
and we place them
into those roles.
Now, does it mean
that I abandon all
hope that the guy
that's an introvert
will ever develop more
communication skills?
No, I'm still going
to work with him.
And over time, we'll
get him a little bit
moving in the right direction.
But I'm not going
to take somebody
that's a total
introvert and turn them
into a lead sales guy.
That's not going
to happen anymore
than I'm going to change
a tiger's stripes.
So that's what we have to do
is we have to help people--
as leaders, we have to
help people find the role
and find the thing
that they're good at.
Now, does that mean if I have
someone that loves their job,
they're going to
do better at it?
Absolutely.
Does it mean that
if I have somebody
that's driven just
by achievement
that they're going to
be good at their job?
No.
In fact, well, they can be.
There's going to be certain
roles I can put them in.
If I've got a sales
number I need to hit
and Andrew is super
into achievement,
he wants to be the
golden child, he
wants to have his
picture on the magazine
that we put out about
our industry, cool.
I can throw this task
at you, and you're
going to go and get it.
The problem is if
there's something that's
going to take more perseverance
and the reward isn't that high,
or it's a long-term
goal, you're probably not
the right guy for the job.
So liking your job is
absolutely critical.
And if you love your
job, you're going
to be able to most
likely excel at it.
Now, you could be an unfortunate
person that loves your job
and is not good at it.
That happens occasionally.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, but it seems--
JOCKO WILLINK: It's like--
sure reminds me of your--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: But
it seems pretty rare.
JOCKO WILLINK: It reminds me
of your skateboarding career.
You loved skateboarding, but you
just weren't that good at it.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
wasn't that good at it.
JOCKO WILLINK: Unfortunately.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You what I
loved more than skateboarding?
I loved the community I was in.
And I probably would have
gone to the industry side,
or worked on a company
side and not been
on the actual skateboard side,
or just skateboard for fun.
So there's a guy in the
skateboarding community.
His name is Jim Thiebaud.
And he's the not-so-hidden
secret in that community.
He's an amazing guy.
And he early on left
professional skateboarding
to run a company, Real, Deluxe,
a bunch of other companies.
He's an amazing guy.
And he told me--
we've become friends
recently-- and he
said he realized he wasn't
going to be one of the big guys,
but he knew he wanted
to be in this community,
so he found his place.
And I think everyone
in skateboarding
looks to Jim as like the guy.
He truly cares about the
sport and about the people.
And so he learned to
just wrap his arms
and his heart around the whole
thing, and it just works.
And so I do think everyone has
a certain place in a community
or in a team.
I think that as you're
describing this,
I have to imagine that people
are listening and thinking,
wow, this team thing is awesome.
It's just amazing.
I wish I had that.
I'm fortunate to have
that in my podcast.
I've had that in my lab.
Certainly, in my
podcast team, I always
say, these guys go, I go.
It's not just people that press
buttons, and run equipment,
take photos.
They go, I go.
They go, it's over.
And I'm fine with that.
I actually love that
because yes, it's
about the podcast and
about the information
and getting it out there, but
it's as much about the team
and working together just like
it was with skateboarding.
So hopefully, I'm
better at podcasting
than I was at skateboarding.
I kept getting broke off
as the skateboarders say
in skateboarding too often.
But I want to ask
in your family life,
do you look at that as a team?
Do you think this is my
team, and they're different
and how can we synergize?
JOCKO WILLINK:
Yeah, and you've got
to look at every team like that.
What are the strengths and
weaknesses of the team?
And who's going to
be good at what?
And how do you put people
in positions where they're
going to be able to excel?
I mean, what's his
name, Thiebaud?
Is that--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Jim Thiebaud.
JOCKO WILLINK: Jim Thiebaud?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
JOCKO WILLINK: Imagine if he
had a mentor that was saying,
listen, you got to
be a pro skater.
This is your only opportunity.
There's nothing else.
And he didn't have the ability
to take a step back and say,
you know what, man, I'm not
going to be good enough,
but I really love this industry.
So luckily for him
he figured that out.
And you talked
about the superpower
of being like loving your job.
The one thing I claim to be
a superpower is the ability
to take a step back and
detach, which I guess
is going back to your
meditation thing.
But being able to take a step
back and look at your life
and say, man, I've
been skateboarding
longer than that guy,
and he's better than me.
And I've been skateboarding
longer than that other guy,
and he's better than me.
I'm probably not going to
be-- this probably is not
the right job for me.
What could I do where I
could use my skill set?
And obviously, he had some
entrepreneurial spirit
and was able to figure that out.
So being able to be
a part of a team.
And it goes to what I was
saying earlier about the mob.
Being able to be part of
a team, part of the mob,
part of the gang but
still have the ability
to take a step back,
detach from that,
and assess what is the best way
for this team to move forward.
I mean, you could have
this brilliant idea
that from now on you're going
to make all of your podcasts
about the molecular
structure of whatever.
And the rest of
the team probably
need to pull you
aside and say, hey,
man, I know you really care
about that, and that's awesome,
but everyone really wants to
hear about this other stuff.
So let's tie it in together.
Let's expand what the specific
thing you want to talk about.
So being able to take
a step back, detach,
and see the bigger picture to me
is the true superpower of life.
And it's a lot harder
than it sounds.
And this goes back
to when you start
talking about people that
are going through struggles
in life.
And I've described this before
as if I'm looking at you,
and you're in a bad state.
You're depressed.
You're sad.
You're moping around.
You're not getting
anything done.
And I'm looking at
you from the outside,
and I'm thinking for me,
I see this storm cloud
around your head.
I see the storm cloud
And you're in there, and
all you see no matter what
direction you look is storm.
All you see is darkness.
I'm outside and I'm looking,
oh, hey, man, this guy's
got a great education.
He's healthy.
He's got a good team around him.
He's got all these
things going for him.
But you in that state, you
literally cannot see anything
but the darkness of the storm.
And that's what's so scary
about when people enter
that mode is you can look--
I can look at it from
the outside and be like,
Andrew, you've just got to
move like four feet forward,
and you're going to
be through this thing.
And yet you might hear me say
that, and you go, no, Jock.
I'm looking ahead, there's
nothing but darkness.
So helping people move
forward, take action, and be
able to get that
perspective, detach,
and get outside themselves,
get outside their own heads.
Tim Ferriss said get
out of your head.
Get into your body.
That's one way to do it.
Take action.
Go do things.
But it's very scary.
And I'm sure you've had
this experience where you're
talking to someone that
you know, and they're
bogged down in
whatever problem it is,
whatever stress they're under.
And you're looking
at them going, hey,
man, it's going to be OK.
You can clearly
see that whatever
is bothering them and dragging
them, now, you can clearly see.
A lot of times it's
a relationship.
The girl or the guy
they got dumped,
and you go, hey, man, that
person was a disaster anyways.
You're better off without them.
And they cannot compute that.
They are stuck there.
Or maybe it's the school
that they didn't get into,
or the job that they didn't get.
And they get so
wrapped up in that.
They can't get
out of that storm.
And it's such a helpless feeling
to sit there and tell someone,
hey you just move a
little bit towards me,
and you're going to
get out of this storm.
And it's so much
easier said than done.
And that's why trying
to engage with people
and trying to give people that
super power of detachment where
they can take a
step back and say,
you know what,
you're right, man.
That girl she wasn't who
I really thought she was.
I should move on.
Yes.
But easier said than done.
And that's one of the
biggest challenges
I think that we have
as friends and parents
and teammates is helping
people learn to detach,
learn to see the bigger picture,
learn to see that the problem
that you have that your
whole world is actually
not that big of a deal.
I've written a bunch
of kids' books.
And one of the things that
triggered me to write kids
books is realizing that-- one
day my daughter came home--
it's my oldest daughter-- and
she came home from school,
and she says, I'm stupid.
What do you mean you're stupid?
I'm stupid.
I'm dumb.
Why do you think that?
You know whatever grade
it is when you're supposed
to know your timetables?
I don't know my timetables.
I said, oh, well, how
much have you studied?
She gave me the confused look.
What do you mean studied?
I said, have you studied
yet have you made flashcards
to learn them?
And she didn't.
She hadn't.
She thought she
should just know them.
From the teacher went
over what they are,
now she should know them like
some other kids in the class
did.
And so I'm sitting there
going, oh, yeah, cool.
We'll make some flashcards.
And she made flashcards.
She learned her timetables in
45 minutes, and we were good.
But what struck me was to me,
I was like, oh, no big deal.
To her, it was her whole life.
And then I got to see
that with my other kids.
Somebody said something to
them in the recess yard.
And I'm like, oh,
screw that kid.
They don't know what--
don't worry about them.
But when you're-- that's
their whole world and that
unfortunately doesn't
only apply to kids.
It applies to adults as well.
And they get this
problem in their world
that seems so insurmountable
and so massive
because that little ecosystem
that they're stuck in
is their world.
And they run into
this problem, and it's
disruptive in that
world, and they don't
know how to get out of it.
I did a podcast talking
about these ecosystems
that people get into.
And there's all
these ecosystems.
You're in an ecosystem.
We're both in a shared
ecosystem of podcasting
and we could be
like, oh, my gosh,
Lex just came out
with a new podcast,
and it's been the
biggest success.
And what can I do to
catch up with Lex?
And all of a sudden, I
could get really bothered,
you could get really bothered,
we could be bothered by that.
And think, man, I'm a failure.
Meanwhile, there's people
that don't listen to podcasts.
There's people that don't
even know what a podcast is.
And yet it's our whole
world if we let it be.
You're in the academic world.
Hey, you go-- you're a
professor at Stanford, which
is a big deal in that world.
I know people that
don't give a rat's ass.
They don't know
where Stanford is.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
get that all the time.
JOCKO WILLINK: They don't
know where Stanford is.
It's no big deal.
In the SEAL Teams, same thing.
Somebody has a problem
in the SEAL Teams,
and they think this is the
whole world, and I blew it.
And now what are
they going to do?
When you're facing a
significant problem
in life, a relationship,
a problem with a job,
you got to remember that
you're in one ecosystem,
and if you step outside of that
ecosystem, no one really cares.
And you could go move into
a whole totally different
ecosystem and find
happiness there.
But at least utilize that
to get out of that storm
cloud that you're
in, and you're going
to find that there's plenty of
light out there in the world.
Move towards that and it's going
to be a much better situation.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Well, in the spirit
of authenticity, everything
you're saying hits
directly home for me.
I don't know what people's
perceptions of me are.
I actually try not to spend too
much time thinking about that
and just really try and stay
in touch with the source.
And I really do believe in this
notion that our love of things
is what can generate energy.
And I try and use action
to generate energy
but also I happen to
also love exercise.
So that's an easy
one there for me.
But I try and stay in that mode.
But to be quite honest, I've
spent much of my adult life
and probably too much of
my teenage life and 20s--
you're not quite an
adult in your 20s,
at least I certainly wasn't--
in challenging relationships
that admittedly
were challenging because of my
role in them also, of course.
And each and every
time, I remember
thinking, moving on from this is
like this insurmountable thing.
In part because I am a
caretaker, and I cared.
And it wasn't just about
me and a selfishness,
it was about wanting
to right all the wrongs
of that person's past.
I found myself trying to be
a time machine for people.
I found myself trying to
fix their family lives.
I found myself doing
all of that and also
ignoring all the things
I need to focus on
in terms of bettering myself
and making sure I was showing
up correct and on and on.
And there are data in the world
in the form of these people
that know me very, very
well that I think would
say that and a whole lot more.
The point isn't those
specific relationships
but each and every time someone
would come along and say,
listen, if this isn't good for
you, it's not good for them,
or this is a bad
situation, or this isn't
serving either of you well.
But I was myopic, this big.
And not even soda
straw view of the world
like sand speck of the
world and trying to solve
because that's my nature.
I'm going to solve this.
I'm going to solve it.
And sometimes things were
solved for some period of time
and sometimes they weren't.
And I think one thing that just
as a confessional, I will say,
I could really learn
the art of detachment.
to focus on that more,
if that's the proper
language for it.
I think I'm pretty
good at adapting.
I think I'm pretty good
at finding good people.
I'm certainly love
my team, and that all
feels like natural
synergy although it's
hard work in lab
and in the podcast.
But I think the tendency that
I have as a problem solver
is to assume that every
problem can be solved,
and therefore, staying on this
problem until it is solved
is the answer.
And maybe the art of detachment
and getting some perspective
would help because
if I look back,
I certainly don't regret the
experiences that I've had.
But I wasted far too much time.
And frankly, I probably
wasted far too much
of other people's time
trying to solve problems
that could not be solved.
And I think without going
into this in any more detail,
and of course, you can send me
a bill at the end by the way.
I think--
JOCKO WILLINK: Confessions
sessions are free, man
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --yeah.
So I think that being a
problem solver is great,
being forward center
mass is great.
I think learning the systems
of the brain and body
and understanding psychology
and learning about oneself.
The Oracle had it right,
know thyself in ways
that you can
maneuver functionally
in your life and career and
relationship, et cetera.
Great.
But I think there's
also a downside
to being overly fixated.
It's like my bulldog,
Costello, used
to be like chewing on
something, chewing on something.
Next thing I know he's
chewing on his foot.
And you're like, hey.
And you'd have to rip
him off his own foot.
He'd be like--
[PANTING] --because that
chew reflex was just so
strong that sometimes it
would turn on himself.
That's how it feels.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, I wrote a
book called Leadership Strategy
and Tactics.
And one of the things that
I wrote about in that book
is understanding what's
important and what's not.
And this is very similar to
what you're talking about.
Looking at a problem
and taking a step back.
And going, well, A, is
this important or not?
And B, is this
solvable or is it not?
And C, what's the ROI
on getting it solved?
And what's the effort
it's going to take
to get this problem solved?
And how much is it really going
to impact my world and my life
if I focus on it?
So knowing and
understanding when
something is important or
not is a very good skill.
And again, it's a skill that's
directly related to detachment.
Because when you're
in that relationship--
this is another thing I've
been telling people lately--
the solution to
your problem is not
going to be found
in the problem.
It's not going to
be found in there.
You have to get
out of the problem
so that you can look at
it, make an assessment.
And you can assess how
to solve the problem
or whether you need to
solve the problem or not.
I mean, there's a lot
of things in my life
right now where I shrug
my shoulders and go, OK.
But-- It's OK.
Oh, someone's saying this, OK.
Roger that.
Carry on.
No factor.
Move on.
And then occasionally,
you go, OK, this
is something I need
to contend with.
This is something I
need to deal with this.
This is something I need
to shape or adjust or move
or solve, to use your word.
The reason I laugh when I
say that is because problems
you have to get in there.
But if you take a step
back, you can usually
say, oh, a little
adjustment here,
a little adjustment
there, and that thing
is going to sort itself out.
So detachment is a superpower.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Certainly
is and it certainly one
that I need to focus on more.
I'm grateful for you
bringing that up.
This is the biologist
in me, but what
is your process for engaging
detachment or for disengaging?
Is it an active
process, where you go,
I'm going to detach from this.
I'm going to put myself
in a situation that
is pulling on me.
There's this
gravitational force,
and I'm going to create some
imagery in my mind of walking
away from it.
Do I physically
walk away from it?
Do I outsource it
to somebody else?
What are some tools
for detachment?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, this is
one of those situations where
you and I had a discussion
about the science
and the practical
application aligned.
So my original experience
with detachment
was-- and this is one
of those moments where
I said a lot of times things are
just small moments over time,
and you make a
little adjustment.
This is one of those
moments in my life.
And I wrote about in
Leadership Strategy and Tactics
where I recognized like in
a moment what detachment was
and how helpful it was.
I'm on an oil rig doing
a training mission.
My whole platoon is
in a skirmish line
looking at a large
area of the oil rig
that we're supposed
to be clearing.
Again, this is not combat.
This is in the 90s.
There's nothing going on.
We're just doing training.
And I'm standing in
the skirmish line.
And by the way, I'm the
youngest and most junior guy
in my platoon.
And I'm standing there looking
down the sight of my weapon,
and I'm waiting for
someone to make a call
and tell us what to do.
And I wait for 5 seconds,
and I wait for 10 seconds,
and I wait for 20 seconds,
and no one's saying anything.
And we're waiting for
a leader in my platoon
to make a call to tell us what
to do, to tell me what to do.
And finally after 30 seconds
which seems like an eternity,
I can't take it anymore.
And so I take a step like a
foot, a 1-foot step, 12 inches.
I take a step off
the skirmish line.
I look to my left.
I look to my right.
And what I see is every
other guy in my platoon
is staring down their
weapon, staring down
the sight of the weapon, which
means their field of view
is tiny.
It's like a 20-degree
field of view.
You're looking down the
scope of your weapon,
or the sight of your
weapon, and that's
how big their field of view is.
And I'm looking,
and I'm thinking,
oh, there's my
platoon commander.
He's looking down the scope--
the sight of his weapon.
There's my platoon
chief, he's looking down
the sight of his weapon.
There's my leading
petty officer,
he's looking down the
sight of his weapon.
There's my assistant
platoon commander,
he's looking down-- so
everyone in the platoon
is looking down sight side
of their weapon, which
means they all have a very
narrow field of vision.
Well, when I take a step
back and look to my left
and look to my right, guess what
kind of field of vision I got?
I got a massive one.
I can see the whole scene,
and I can see exactly what
it is we need to do.
And at that moment--
look, as a new guy, you need
to keep your mouth shut.
You don't say anything.
And I'm thinking, well, but no
one else is saying anything.
So I muster up all the courage
I can, and I open my mouth
and I say, hold left,
clear right, which
is a basic tactical call.
No, this is not a
patent-level genius maneuver.
It's just a normal call to make
in a situation that we were in.
I say, hold left, clear right.
And I'm expecting
to get slapped,
told, shut up, new guy.
But instead,
everyone just repeats
the call, hold left, clear
right, hold left, clear right.
And we execute the
maneuver, and we finish
the clearance of this oil rig.
And we get done,
we get to the top
of the oil rig, which means
we cleared the whole thing.
We're on the helo deck at the
top, and we go into a debrief.
And now I'm expecting,
OK, now, I'm
going to get told, hey,
what were you doing?
You need to keep
your mouth shut.
And instead, the
platoon chief goes,
hey, Jocko, good call on
the cellar deck down there.
And I was like,
yeah, that's right.
But then I thought to
myself, hold on a second.
Why if I'm the youngest most
junior guy in this platoon,
why was I able to
see what we needed
to do and make that call?
Why did that just happen?
And then I realized it was
because I took a step back.
To use your term, I
broadened my field
of view, which
allowed me to think
more clearly because instead of
being hyperfocused and narrowly
focused, I broadened
my range of vision.
I took a breath
before I made my call.
I had take a nice
breath to speak clearly.
And I realized that taking
a step back and detaching,
I got to see infinitely
more than even the most
experienced guys in my platoon.
And I started doing
it all the time.
it in land warfare.
I started doing it
in urban combat.
I started doing it in all these
tactical training scenarios.
These are just training.
This is the '90s.
I started doing these
training scenarios,
and it always allowed me to
see what we needed to do.
And then I started doing it
when I was having conversations
with people.
And having a conversation
with my platoon chief,
and I can see that
he's starting to turn
a little red in the face.
And we're about to
argue about something.
I said, oh, wait a second.
I'm taking a step back look and
go, he's getting mad right now,
and he's the platoon chief.
You better just de-escalate
this thing real quick.
And I'd say, hey, you know
what, chief, that sounds good.
Let me go relook at
the plan or whatever.
And so I started to do
this with my normal life.
It was to not get wrapped
up in my own emotions.
Not get wrapped up in the gun
fight that was happening right
in front of my face.
Not to get wrapped up in the
details of what was going on,
but instead, take a step
back, detach, look around
and then you can make a
much, much better decision.
And it's not-- it's exponential.
If you're looking down
the sights of your weapon,
and you take a step back,
and you look around,
it's exponential how
much more you can see.
Now, listen, if you are the
only person in a gunfight,
it's going to be harder for
you to do that because you've
got to be focused on
whatever you're shooting at.
But when you have 16 guys
or 20 guys they're all
looking in the same
direction, it's very easy
to be the guy that goes,
I'm going take a step back,
look around, make a call.
So when you talk
about the mechanics--
when I teach this
to people now--
the mechanics of it, take
a step back literally.
You and I are at
a meeting, there's
a bunch of people this starts
to get heated argument,
I will literally push my chair
back away from the table.
Change my perspective.
Widen my field of view.
The other thing in the SEAL
Teams you don't want to sound
panicked on the radio
for a couple of reasons.
Number one, because when
you panic on the radio,
it's going to cause
other people to panic.
Number two, if you panic
on the radio, and you sound
panicked, everyone's
going to make fun of you.
So when you get back
from the mission
everyone is going to go--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Double whammy.
JOCKO WILLINK: --yeah.
You sounded like
a baby out there.
So what would I do before
I would key up my radio,
take a breath.
And so here I'm manually
slowing down my breath.
I'm broadening my field of view.
So if you're in a
meeting, or you're in a--
you're at the
supermarket parking lot,
and someone starts
to yell at you,
take a step back, take a breath,
broaden your field of view.
Detach from those
emotions that you're
having and make some space.
And that's how I go through
the mechanics of detachment.
Now, I can tell you
right now I mean,
when you do this all the time,
which I do this all the time.
Yeah, I don't really
have to step back.
But when you're starting to
be able to try and do this,
absolutely.
Make-- And I'll tell
you here's another
like weird little nuance
thing, lift your chin up,
and put your hands down.
Now, this is not in a combat
situation, not in a fight.
But here's the thing,
when I get defensive
what am I going to do?
I'll raise my hands up
and put my chin down.
That's like a fighting mode.
So if you and I are
having a discussion,
and I'm starting to get heated,
and I'm starting to like,
oh, he's not listening to me.
Instead of me putting my chin
down and put my hands like
up to where I can put them
in your face a little bit,
no, I'm actually going
to take a step back
and say, put my chin up.
It changes my perspective
a little bit more,
changes my visual
perspective just by changing
the angle of my head.
Take a step back,
put my hands down.
I'm not being in a defensible--
I actually want to hear
what you have to say.
And if I start listening
to what you have to say
and not talking--
it's very hard to be
detached when you're talking.
It's another key component.
You want to detach,
shut your mouth.
So I'm in meetings in a
bunch of different companies.
I'm running-- I
have a bunch of--
I own a bunch of
different companies.
I'm in a meeting
in my companies,
I'm not the one that's
doing all the talking.
In fact, I'm doing
mostly listening.
When I'm in Task Unit
Bruiser, my task unit,
I'm not sitting there
giving the entire brief.
No, I'm letting
the platoon chief
and the platoon commanders
give those briefs.
And that way, I'm detached.
I'm listening to what
they have to say.
I'm more capable of seeing what
holes there are in their plans
by not moving my mouth,
not talking, I'm listening.
So those are some of the
methodologies that I use
and that I advise people to use
in order to effectively start
down the pathway of being able
to detach in various scenarios.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I love it.
Again, I'm saying I love
it because I do love it.
And thank you.
I think it's a
wonderful technique.
We've talked before
on your podcast
and some of my listeners,
maybe not all to this podcast
will be familiar with the
fact that when we narrowly
focus our gaze on one target,
a number of things happen.
Our visual world becomes
constricted, of course,
but also that we start
slicing time more finely.
And the dopamine
system tends to start
doing anticipation and trying
to guide and direct things
in that narrow tunnel of view,
whereas when we literally
take on panoramic vision,
so not necessarily moving
our head around,
although, one could,
broadening our field of view
or looking at a horizon,
especially if we're walking.
But getting that kind of--
not kind of getting a
broader field of view,
we slice time differently.
Things don't feel
as imposing on us.
This is the physiological
substrate underlying
what you're describing.
And I think it
goes a step further
because in that
open, larger aperture
of visual understanding,
there's an open larger window
of cognitive understanding, and
new options start to surface.
I mean, I think this is--
I have long been
fascinated by the fact
that this actually became--
I'll tell this real quick story.
In 2015, I went over to Spain
to do some mountaineering
with Wim Hof.
And this wasn't because
I wanted a podcast.
I didn't have any social media.
I just went over
there because I'd
heard this guy, Wim, contacted
him, and somehow arranged
a trip for myself.
And I went over there, and
we did some crazy dangerous
mountaineering that I
had no business doing.
Almost ripped my left
leg off in a stunt
that was organized
by others there
that I never should have done.
In any case, one
day I look and Wim
is like crouched
on the ground next
to like a curb in this
parking lot before our hike.
And he's down there on the
ground with a little stick.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
He's like, look.
And there were ants
climbing up this thing.
And he's like, there
mountaineering this curb.
And I thought, this
guy's different.
But then I realized we were
about to do the same thing
up this big face.
And I thought, wow, he's able to
think at these different scales
and see similarities.
That's pretty cool.
I would have never
stopped to look there,
and I still remember it.
And was it profound?
No.
But was it interesting?
yeah, in the sense
that things are happening
at all scales all the time.
And we think we know the
scale to pay attention to,
and we think that that's
the one that matters most.
And I think it's fair to
say that in a gunfight,
there is a scale
that matters most
but new options, new
perspectives actually come
from that broader
field of view, which
is what you're describing.
And later that day-- it's
interesting because this group
going up, some of them were
really challenged in the climb.
And Wim went back
to this example
of how the ants would stack
on top of one another.
And he used an analogy
from that to help people
through this climb.
And there was a beautiful
pool at the top,
et cetera, et cetera.
Anyway, I think
that these examples
are in fact meaningful,
especially the ones
that you gave because they
don't just relate to military.
I mean, you can imagine
around the dinner table.
I've had this.
Kids are there and
partners there.
And sometimes it's really
nice to sit back and just
hear it all and bask in it all.
But oftentimes, new
information will surface.
Like you said, all I'm hearing
is worries out of this person.
Or they're not even really here.
They're all talking
about what we're
going to do next time,
next time, next time.
And you can reanchor people
like, hey, look, maybe
let's focus on what
we're doing here.
Or sometimes people
are hyperfocused
on what's happening
there, and they
need to think about
something in the future.
I love this.
I need to practice detachment
in a number of different domains
in my life.
One thing that I am realizing
after hearing you describe
the process that I
really need to do
is I need to start taking
some time away from my work.
Maybe even a little bit of
time parallel to relationship
to get better perspective on it.
Because I think the problem
solving nature in us
really makes us myopic,
really makes us nearsighted.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah that's--
you see this a lot.
I mean, I get to see this a lot.
We do events with
companies, businesses.
And we go offsite somewhere
where they're detached.
They're just they're
defacto detached
from their day-to-day business.
You pull someone out of
their business for two days
and all of a sudden, they
start seeing the solutions.
They never see them like it's a
lot harder for them to see them
when they're in the firefight.
You get them out of the
firefight, it's hard for them
to see it when they're in that
acquisition that they're doing.
How are we going to
merge these two cultures?
This is going to be impossible.
Boom, pull them out.
All right, let's talk
about the two cultures.
And let's talk about what
possible outcomes are.
And all of a sudden, when you
get them to take a step back,
the solutions will appear.
And it is true in a gunfight.
Now, listen, if it's a
one-on-one gunfight, even then
the ability to take a step
back and look around or use
your peripheral vision, you
have to be able to do this.
It's going to increase.
It's exponential
how much it-- that's
why it's like a superpower.
It's like cheating.
I was speaking of Seth Stone.
Seth Stone took over--
he became a task unit
commander, troop commander
when we got back from Ramadi.
And so now he's
the guy in charge,
and now I was
running the training.
And a couple of months into his
training, he broke his neck.
Broke his vertebrae in his neck.
His spinal cord was OK, so he
was the guy with the big neck
brace on, and he couldn't
do any arduous training.
And his SEAL task unit,
which is two platoons,
was going through their
land warfare training.
And he couldn't do it.
He couldn't carry a rucksack,
couldn't carry a machine gun,
so he couldn't do it.
So I said, hey, I'm coming out.
Let's go out, and you
can observe your guys,
and see how they're doing.
And so there we are.
We're out in the desert.
His troop is going through
field training exercise,
our full mission profile.
So it's like a big
fake operation,
there's a fake target,
there's fake bad guys.
We're using these high
speed laser guns to shoot.
And we're standing
on this little berm.
And at a certain point
in the operation,
his whole task
unit, like 40 guys,
gets pinned down in
this little ravine.
And so we're standing in
the ravine with these guys,
and no one's making
any decisions.
And the enemy with these laser
guns are starting to maneuver
and starting to--
they're killing guys
because these laser
guns you can die.
And Seth he hits me on the arm.
He said, can I tell
him what to do?
And I was like, no.
Let them figure it out.
So another 30 seconds
pass, another guy
gets killed with laser.
He hits me again, bro, let
me say something to them.
And I was like, no,
let them figure it out.
Another minute goes by,
two more guys are now dead.
Just laser dead
but they're dead.
And he hits me again, and he's
like, bro, let me tell them.
And I go, all right,
go ahead and tell them.
And so he just crouches down
next to one of the guys,
and bangs him on the
shoulder, goes, peel right.
And which is again, it's just
a fundamental basic call.
And the guy shouts
it out, peel right.
And they start
peeling peeling right.
And another minute later,
they're all out of the kill
zone and everything's OK.
And then Seth looks at
me, and he goes, man, this
is so easy way up here.
And I said, bro,
look at where we are.
We are in the ravine
with the guys.
Now, we're on a knee and
the guys are laying down,
but it's not this--
we weren't on some
elevated position.
And I said, hey, it's not that
we're in an elevated position.
It's just that we're
detached and looking around.
And he goes, oh, my God.
And I said, hey, you
remember when you and I went
through this training?
And he goes, yeah.
And I go, this is what it
was like for me all the time.
I was constantly
just looking around,
so that's why it seems
like a magic power, right?
It's like a superpower because
Seth's down there with his gun,
and he's shooting.
And I'm like, hey, bro, move
your guys over to that--
go to that ridgeline right
there, set security, boom.
And how did Jocko see that?
Jocko must be a tactical genius.
No, I'm not a tactical genius.
I'm just taking a step
back and looking around.
And like you just said,
it applies to everything
that we do.
If you're having a conversation
with your significant other,
and you start to see that
they're getting frustrated
about something,
now, look, if you're
in the conversation 100%, you're
going to get frustrated too.
You're going to get
frustrated, they're frustrated.
Next thing you know you've got
an emotional argument going on,
whereas if you take a mental
step back and say, wait,
why are they
frustrated right now?
Oh, because I'm trying to solve
their problem when really what
they're looking to do is vent.
OK, got it.
Let them vent.
OK, cool.
Oh, that sounds horrible.
What do you think
you're going to do?
Instead of saying, well,
if that's the problem,
here's what you should do
because people aren't always
looking for that.
So yeah, this
thing, this ability
is-- and it's something that
can absolutely be trained,
and that's what's cool about it.
It can absolutely be trained.
It's not a natural gift.
It's some people we're be
better at it than others,
but it's something
that you can train.
And I used to see
guys develop it.
And I see people develop it
now in the business world where
they'll report back to me, we
had a meeting with the union
today, and the union
started escalating
what they wanted to do.
And I just took--
I detached, and we
ended up de-escalating,
and now we got a solution.
So this is an absolute skill
set that can be learned,
and that's what makes
it especially nice.
Because there's
some people-- look,
if you're very articulate,
born very-- some people
are born more articulate
than other people.
Some people are
born with an ability
to simplify things
more than others.
And you can train.
You can become more articulate.
You can become-- you can
learn to simplify things more.
And some people are going to
be naturally good at detaching,
but everyone can
get better at it,
and that's a beautiful thing.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's
a beautiful thing,
and I'm highly
incentivized to do this.
I mean, there are
areas of my life
that are going really well that
I also want to apply it there.
I think that I've tended to
rely on people close to me
as a way to access
this detachment.
I will be very direct
in saying that I am not
the leader of my podcast.
There is a leader, it is not me.
I'm part of the team,
but it is not me.
And I often rely on his input.
And sometimes that
input is solicited
and sometimes it's not.
One place for instance where
you see people getting really
myopic is on social media.
And I've experienced this.
I'd love to say that
I'm always nonreactive.
And I think in general I take
the stance that I have filters.
So I have filters.
I know why I'm there.
I'm interested in being
a teacher and a giver
and informing people about the
beauty and utility of biology.
That's why I say, it's not a
mission statement, it's a fact.
That's what I care about.
Anything that doesn't
fit through that filter,
I don't really have
any business doing.
But occasionally, I like to
make a joke or something.
But occasionally
something comes through.
And I find myself
saying, wait a second.
And you get sucked
into that tunnel.
And sometimes it's observing
other people in tunnels.
And when you're
not in the tunnel,
it's so obvious
what's happening.
You're watching, in some
cases, people just dragging
their lives, and some cases,
sinking their entire careers.
I mean, the former
chair of Psychiatry
at Columbia
University in New York
made an absolutely foolish,
truly insensitive, totally
inappropriate tweet.
That's my opinion.
And I think it was the
opinion of all the people
that fired him from his job.
This person was at the
apex of his career.
Lost his job for saying
something terrible.
And in retrospect,
was said something
like, I don't know
what I was thinking.
And so this guy
is a psychiatrist,
so he lives in the
study and the treatment
of the mind, which just goes
to show that everyone I think
is susceptible to being
pulled into these tunnels.
And fortunately, everyone
is susceptible to learning
to teach themselves how to
latch themselves out of it.
So I love this idea
of a teachable skill.
I'm certainly going
to practice it
in one on one and
in group situations
and in a variety of situations.
I think that the tunnel
has a gravitational pull.
There's like an
allure to that tunnel.
And I always just go right
back to the neurochemistry.
I think that there's
something about solving
a problem inside of a tunnel
like an animal on a chase.
But at some point, that
animal could get picked off,
run over by a truck
because it was--
didn't have enough
situational awareness.
I'm definitely going to practice
this through opening the gaze
and broadening gaze.
And I think I also I'm due for
a couple of days off from things
to just walk and
think about work.
On these retreats, do
people work on work
or are they just there
to do other things,
and that's where
the ideas surface?
JOCKO WILLINK: We'll do
a little bit of both.
So we'll do some stuff
that is focused on work,
but then we'll pull
out and do things
that are completely unrelated
to work for that very reason.
Whether we do
something physical,
whether we do some
mental exercise,
but we do things
that are completely
unrelated to their
work and take those
breaks in order for
them to free their mind.
And you know what bothers
you about social media?
This is when you say there's
some things that make you mad--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I mean,
not me, but it could be.
Of course, I'm human.
Little things
prevent-- and it's not
the things that are obvious.
It's actually not
direct critique of me.
It's when people exploit
misunderstandings
to try and create a greater
misunderstanding that
doesn't exist.
That's what gets me because
to a scientist, that's
like the most irritating thing.
I don't know what the analogy
would be in the SEAL Teams,
but it's someone
hijacking something--
They didn't mean that but then
they distort the argument.
The word gaslighting gets
thrown around a lot now.
A lot of people actually
think that anytime someone
states a boundary.
No, I don't believe
that's gaslighting.
Trust me, the psychiatrist, who
are all professionally trained,
tell me that is not gaslighting.
Gaslighting is a
very particular thing
where you're trying to alter
someone's reality in a very
active almost like
sociopathic way.
So I that's a little
editorializing right there.
What bothers me is
when people hijack--
sometimes someone
in an argument isn't
as sophisticated with their
language as somebody else.
So someone will hijack
that lack of sophistication
and try and flip
them on their back.
That sort of thing
really gets under my skin
because I feel that creates
an unnecessary divide.
There are a few other things.
But I always joke in my lab.
And I'll say, I have
3,000 pet peeves,
but I also have
3,000 flaws to match
each one of those pet peeves.
JOCKO WILLINK: So
yeah, whenever--
This is not just social
media, but it's just
life when somebody says
something about me or to me
that I don't like.
What I realized years
ago is the reason
I don't like it
is because there's
some truth in what
they're saying.
And the best thing to do is
to say either to yourself
if you're by
yourself or to them,
is to say, yeah, you're right.
I am a knucklehead sometimes.
Or yeah, you're right.
I sometimes do jump
to conclusions.
Or yeah, you're right.
I was completely
wrong about that.
And that is just so
much more liberating
and healthy than
saying, you don't
know what you're talking about.
Or no, I don't--
just going into
that defensive mode
and trying to close your mind
instead of opening your mind up
to listen to what somebody
else has to say, and say,
yeah, that's a good point.
You're spot on with that one.
Next question, next
comment, let's go.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: One thing
I appreciate about you
on social media is
the limited number
of words in each
of your responses.
It's a great thing forcing you
to be efficient and concise
actually is a huge advantage.
It also forces you to be
precise at least about category.
I think there's something
to be said for that.
JOCKO WILLINK: Well,
there's a good example.
So I was on Twitter
the other day
since Twitter is getting a
lot of traction right now.
There's a lot of
mayhem going on.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
the other gun fight.
JOCKO WILLINK: And
somebody asked me,
somebody said, hey, I'm
going to boot camp soon.
What advice do you have for me?
And I wrote back, enjoy.
Boom.
And like you said, I
mean, it's Twitter.
I'm responding to
a bunch of people.
And then somebody else
chimed in and said,
you might as well not
even answer, Jocko
that's not helping
this guy at all.
And look at your face.
For those of you
that are watching,
your face just got a
little bit mad, right?
You got a little bit
defensive for me.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, well,
I think, that's my nature.
I don't like seeing
other people attacked.
I think that's just my nature.
JOCKO WILLINK: I had
a split second off
who the hell is this guy?
And then I said, you
know what, he's right.
And then I tweeted again back.
I said, sorry, man.
You're right.
What I should have
said was, hey,
read the book Leadership
Strategy and Tactics.
It's a good book
for someone that
is going to be in an environment
that's going to be challenging
and where you're going to
be faced with leadership
challenges.
And enjoy boot camp because
if your mindset is this sucks
and this is terrible,
it's going to be terrible,
and it's going to suck.
And if you go with a mindset of
hey, this is a cool experience,
and I should enjoy
it, you're going
to have a much better time.
That's my full answer.
I'm sorry I didn't give you--
and it's perfectly fine.
That guy was right
to critique me.
And he was right in saying that.
And there was a bunch--
what's funny is a bunch of
other people came to my defense
and said, this guy--
that's really great.
But my point is instead of me
getting defensive and crazy
and letting it drive me crazy,
open my mind a little bit,
listen to what they have to say,
accept that there's got to be
some level of truth in it.
And there was.
I gave a guy a very,
very terse response,
and I could have
expanded on it more.
And I did.
No big deal.
Good times.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Right.
A few minutes ago, I
was thinking to myself,
I wonder where your mind
is at in the few moments
before you fall asleep.
Are you able to make yourself
go mind blank pretty easily?
It's something I've been
practicing more because I
tend to, again ruminate--
I like to drill into
problems, obviously.
Yesterday I did a solo episode,
which when we do those,
they are usually anywhere
from five to 20 hours of prep.
And then the recordings, I
won't say how long they take.
But I love going
into the tunnel.
The tunnel is that's
where the juice is for me.
And finding the structure.
And I have the benefit
of an amazing producer
who helps me sort through it.
And I came out of this
thing, and then went home,
couldn't eat.
Because I was like,
I don't want dinner.
And then I was
explaining a call I had
with a colleague the other day.
My partner-- my girlfriend
she was just like, OK.
I'm going to sleep.
And I was up and texting and
thinking and writing notes out.
And I thought, oh,
man, I'm like Costello
like chewing on the stick
and chewing into my paw.
I need sleep.
I need to go to sleep.
So I think I have a bit of
a harder time disengaging,
clearly.
And this is why I never
touch cocaine or amphetamine
because I think
that some of us have
a love of the dopamine
circuitry that--
I always sensed if I were to
have tried drugs like that,
they might have been
the thing that would hit
my neural circuits just right.
Some people talk about
alcohol that way.
I've read books by
alcoholics like the book
Dry and few other--
Rich Roll talks about
this, that he drank alcohol
for the first time in college.
It was like this
elixir that filled
his body that made him feel
right for the first time.
That is not how I feel
after a couple of drinks.
I feel a little relaxed,
but I can do without it.
But this drilling into
something is really that's my--
I guess, maybe that's my--
I don't think it's a superpower,
but I have some strength there.
But I think it's also the thing
that can cut on the other side.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
when you started off
this conversation
early you talked
about getting up in the
morning, and you just get up,
and you have these--
I was about to go down
the path of it's--
at nighttime when I'm
trying to go to sleep
and I have some random
thought about some thing, that
can be a hard--
I have a visual thing
that's going on.
It seems like I'm
on a roller coaster,
and I'm going in like
a new idea comes,
and I'm just on
this awesome ride,
and it's not going to stop.
And I can't-- I don't
know how to stop that.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oh, no.
I mean, I think it goes with
people who are very driven
and like to master
different crafts.
I have a colleague, his
name is Karl Deisseroth.
He's a bioengineer.
He has five children,
and he's a psychiatrist.
He's like an incredible-- one
of these people that does a ton.
Very likely will
win the Nobel Prize.
I mean, he's an amazing
scientists, amazing guy.
And he does this
practice that he does,
which is not a
meditation, which he
sits for an hour late at
night after his kids have gone
to sleep, and he
forces himself, forces
himself to think in
complete sentences
with punctuation
about some problem.
I tried doing that for about
five minutes, and I fell off.
But it's something that
he's cultivated in himself,
which helps him in his career.
I don't think-- it's certainly
not something I recommend.
If I did that at 1:00
or 2:00 in the morning,
I think that would
be bad for my sleep.
Because falling asleep
actually requires
drifting into these
kind of liminal states.
It's one of the reasons why
I'm a big proponent of things
like nonsleep deep rest, or
these yoga nidra practices,
which are basically
body scans where
you're trying to learn to
detach from the sensory world.
And they're very effective at--
certainly for me
they've been very
effective at teaching
me to turn off
thinking, which is
an interesting notion
in its own right.
But I like the
idea of detachment
by stepping back and
getting perspective.
My father is much
better at that.
He's a very calm guy in
the world of confrontation.
I always knew it when I was
a kid because he would blink,
which meant like something
was going to happen
like I was going to get it.
And now-- but I've always
known that he can control
his responses, his behavior.
Others of us in the family you
know beside from New Jersey,
we're more like
go to loggerheads.
So I don't know.
This raises a
question, and I think
it's one that I and several
other people I talked to
in anticipation of this
podcast were asking.
I think one reason
why people are
drawn to people who have
been in the SEAL Teams,
and you in particular, are that
I think everybody, not just
males but females too.
I think everybody wants to know
like their calibration point
on their level of toughness.
I think people wonder.
I think when people
talk about BUD/S and all
that, I think a lot
of people wonder,
would I make it through?
I've certainly wondered it.
I haven't spent hours on it.
I went my path.
I'm happy for the path I went.
But I think people wonder,
do I have this thing
that supposedly
BUD/S selects for?
And if I don't, how tough
am I or not tough am I?
I think that we all can look
at other people physically--
and I'm not somebody
that does a lot of this.
I know some people are
really obsessed by this like,
oh, that person has an eight
pack with veins on their leg.
I don't understand that.
That's not me, but I
understand some people do that
even to the point of pathology.
But I think most people
wonder, how resilient am I?
And they can look to experiences
that they've survived
and say, oh, I made it through,
or I'm resilient or not.
But is there a way that we can--
certainly that we can train
it by doing hard things?
Cold showers, this kind of thing
are small examples of those.
But do you think it's even
an important question to ask?
And if it is, how does
one go about thinking,
how resilient am I?
Should we put ourselves into
situations of discomfort just
to test that?
Because I will say, I
think a lot of people
look to SEAL Teams and team guys
in particular as a calibration
point of like, OK, they
know how to do hard things.
They were selected
for the ability
to carry logs, and get into
cold water over and over,
and roll in the sand, and go
without sleep for a week or so.
But that's probably not
what they were doing
when they were on deployment.
It's clearly a pressure
test for something else.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, it's
a strange, strange thing.
The Basic Underwater
Demolition SEAL training.
And quite frankly, going
and getting wet and cold
and being miserable is
actually nothing compared
to being on deployment.
And a good example that
I use to compare this to
is, when I was on deployment
in 2006 in Ramadi, there was--
as you were driving off base
to go into the city and conduct
operations, as you drove out
of the compound, on your right
was this area that was
called the vehicle graveyard.
And the vehicle graveyard was
exactly what it sounds like.
It was probably
75 or 100 vehicles
that were blown up,
destroyed, burned,
in various twisted conditions
that had been dragged back
through the city and put
into this vehicle graveyard.
And as you drove by
that vehicle graveyard,
you know without
question that every one
of those twisted vehicles
represented one, two, three,
four, five, American casualties
horribly wounded, killed.
And there you are in a
vehicle about to roll out
into that city where
what you're looking at
can easily be you in
the next three minutes.
And you're going
to do that today.
You're going to
do that tomorrow.
You can do that the next day and
the day after that and the day
after that.
That compared to--
and by the way,
this isn't just seals
that are doing that.
This is Marines, this is the
army guys that are over there.
This is what everyone is doing.
And they do it.
They do it.
I talk about Marc Lee
who was one of my guys.
First CO killed in Iraq.
And he was the lead turret
gunner in the lead Humvee.
And in Vietnam, if you were
the point man in Vietnam,
if you're in infantry
patrol, you're
the point man in Vietnam,
you were at risk--
booby traps, ambush.
So they rotated you out.
You didn't have to stay
up there all the time.
You do an hour up as point man,
they get someone else up there.
And that guy, the
lead turret gunner
in a Humvee column of four,
or five, or six vehicles,
if you hit an IED, that's the
vehicle that's going to hit it.
If you go into an
ambush, that's the guy
that's going to get hits.
The guy that's standing up in
a 50 caliber turret, that's
the guy that's going to die.
And Marc-- he was
a new guy, so he's
in that lead turret, 50 Cal.
And he never asked
to get rotated out.
And I remember he was a very--
I like to say very.
He was extremely charismatic,
funny, gregarious comedian.
And we got all kinds
of stories about Marc.
But one of them, we were in
Vegas, and we're all gambling.
And I come down
from my hotel room,
and I see Marc across the--
he's playing blackjack.
When he sees me,
he goes, hey, sir,
when are the new
Cadillacs coming out.
Like he's just lighting
up everybody, just having
a fantastic time.
But I remember one night he's
getting ready to roll out.
And if I wasn't going
out with the platoons,
I would go out see the guys
off, give them a hands salute
as they're leaving.
And I'm like, how are
you feeling, Marc?
How you doing, Marc?
Are you good to go?
And he's like,
feeling lucky, sir.
That was his attitude.
And he's a guy that's going
to drive by that vehicle
graveyard, drive right
out of that city,
and he's going to do it the next
day, and the day after that,
and the day after that.
So-- and like I said, that's
what the army guys are doing.
That's what the Marine
Corps guys are doing.
They're doing it.
And so as much as the mythology
around basic SEAL training
goes, to me that experience
in combat and what guys do
is infinitely harder and
infinitely more important.
Now, all that being
said, basic SEAL training
is a very strange
laboratory for human beings.
It is a very strange
And it's crazy the way it works.
It's obviously extremely
difficult, but there's no--
I wouldn't put money.
You could put odds
on somebody making it
through like, hey,
that guy seems
like he's going be good to go.
But I wouldn't put a
bunch of money on it.
And I wouldn't take like 100%,
I would never take 100% bet
on anybody because
there's no one that's
100% going to make it
through that training.
And there's just
random-- some people say,
well, it's because your why.
There's people that make
it through SEAL training
because their ex-girlfriend
said they couldn't make it.
There's some other
guy that makes it
through because they promised
God that they would make it.
There's some other
guy that made it
through because their dad
said they could never.
There's lie every one of these
examples you can come up with.
And it's good enough for some
random dude to make it through.
And it doesn't matter
what your pedigree is.
It doesn't matter
where you're from.
There's guys from Iowa.
There's guys from Florida.
There's guys from
wherever that make it.
And those guys from Iowa,
and those guys from Florida,
and those guys from
wherever, that don't make it.
Guys from farms.
Guys from silver
spoon in their mouth,
and you just can't predict it.
And I mean, it has to have
something to do with the fact
that how bad you
actually want to do it.
That's-- it's a strange thing.
And I wouldn't try and--
if I was in the world, if
I didn't do that training,
I wouldn't be trying to
figure out if I could make it
or not because you don't know.
You don't know.
It's a very strange thing.
And it's so mythical
almost right now.
It's mythical that
how hard it is.
And this is not too many
people make it through, man.
It's--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: 15%.
JOCKO WILLINK: --yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
from all the folks
that I've talked to there, or
gone through, been instructors
there, some we
both know, it seem
that that 15% number is unlikely
to change as long as they
keep the process the same.
It just seems
about 15% of people
seem to have something
in them that can perhaps
grow during that training.
But that it is being
identified and selected for
rather than somehow
being built up
across at least that phase,
the early phases of training.
And then at some point they
build on that capacity.
And this gets to this really
somewhat controversial issue
frankly, are people
wired differently?
And listen, I started off
in neural development.
And I'll tell you that there
are some universal properties
of neural development
in all surviving humans.
Like that you're going
to breathe without having
to think about it.
Your heart is going
to beat without having
to think about it.
But beyond that, there's a lot
of variation in natural levels
of dopamine and serotonin.
There's nature plays a
powerful role and nurture.
And what's
interesting, though, is
we can't always
predict from parents
what nature is going to do.
Recently we had
someone on the podcast.
I'm excited for you to listen
to it if perhaps you will
if I send it to you.
There's a guy who talks about
inheritable acquired traits.
You don't expect that
because you work out
that your grandkids
will be more muscular
and have better endurance.
But there's actually
some evidence
that that may be the case.
And you go, well,
how could that be?
We got two kinds of
cells in your body.
It turns out you
have what are called
somatic cells, which
are all of them.
Then you have the
germ cells, which
are your sperm and
your wife's eggs.
Well, why wouldn't the DNA of
the sperm cells and the egg
cells be modifiable
by experience
if all the other cells are?
And it turns out there's
some evidence that maybe it's
not the DNA but the rNRA.
Think about that.
That means that whether-- and
we know this that people that
have been in a famine,
several generations later,
their implications for
blood sugar regulation
in their great grandkids.
So the idea that experience
and acquired traits
can change us is actually
has some validity.
And this gets into
really complicated things
to people who go, oh, this
is like the giraffe that
had to crane its neck,
and then gave birth
to longer necked giraffes.
And it's like, well, not exactly
but also not entirely untrue
either.
So I love the idea that
there are inherited traits
and that nature and
nurture play a role,
but that hard work may actually
transmit across generations.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah,
there's in SEAL training
you have kids that come through
that they call legacies, which
means that they have a dad--
I think a dad,
brother, whatever.
And they do have a better
chance of making it,
but it's not a
guaranteed chance at all.
And my personal
opinion is I think
a legacy kid would have a
better chance of making it just
due to the Thanksgiving
dinner that you're
going to have to go through
for the rest of your life
with your family--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: If you don't.
JOCKO WILLINK: --yeah,
if you're even invited,
which you might be on your own.
But yeah, maybe there's
something to that as well.
But I think that's
just more the pressure
that someone must feel
like, hey, there's
no way I'm going to be
allowed back in my home
if I don't make it
through this training.
So I'm going to have to just
go ahead and suck it up.
But not everyone makes it.
And it's a bummer
when that does occur.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Well, for people
who are not thinking about going
through SEAL training, or who
miss the opportunity, or who
are not interested in that
for whatever
reason, do you think
there's value to
doing things each day
that suck a little bit?
Or from time to
time doing something
that puts one into a state
of deliberate discomfort?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, 100%.
Yeah, I mean, 100%.
I mean, even in order
to improve yourself,
you've got to impose some
discipline on yourself.
If you want to get
stronger, you've
got to do things that
require strength.
If you want to be
tougher, you've
got to do things that
require you to be tougher.
I think that's pretty
straightforward.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Does
that mean doing things
that are not pleasurable?
So for instance, I've
done some long podcasts.
And a few weeks ago, we were
doing a series with Andy Galpin
all about exercise
and exercise science.
And we did six podcasts in that
week, the most I've ever done,
which made doing four or five
the next week not so bad.
But I loved every second of it.
And I love every
second of podcasting.
And so it didn't suck, but it
built up a greater capacity.
I guess, I'm asking
specifically about things that
really feel like a splinter.
Is there any value to that?
Because I have to say there
are some people I know,
some of them are former team--
are team guys, I guess, you
don't say former team guys.
They are out of the Teams now,
but they're team guys forever,
who seem to not be
rattled by little things.
Those guys in particular,
they don't seem
to be rattled by little things.
And then I know people that
they get the wrong size
coffee at a coffee
shop, and they dissolve
into a puddle of tears.
So there does seem
to be something
to this whole like
mental resilience thing
and flexibility thing.
And I try and do something
that's uncomfortable to me
about once a week, something
I really don't like.
It doesn't matter what
that is, but I try and do
something that's unpleasant.
Or do something in a
way that's unpleasant.
I guess, the example would be
getting into the cold water
the first thing in the morning.
And making that decision
from under the blankets
is a rough one for me.
But then it gets easier.
And then you wonder, is it
still serving the purpose
that it's building me up?
So should people seek
truly bad experiences
provided that they're
done in a safe way?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think that you're
going to, just like you,
would develop your
legs by doing squats.
And you would develop your
back by doing pull ups.
I think you would
develop your resiliency
by doing repetitions of things
that require you to be tougher.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
That actually suck.
OK, good.
And the reason I ask this is
because I think a lot of people
think, well, I
work out every day.
But then you probe them a
little bit, and they're like,
but I love exercise.
And then well, then
that doesn't quite
qualify as something
that makes you tougher.
Or they think oh, the last
reps of a set are really tough.
But if you love hitting
failure on a set because that's
what I seek in the gym.
I love that aspect
of the training.
That's actually where I
know I'm getting better.
It no longer serves as
resilience training,
it more just serves as training.
In any case, I think
that the point is clear,
and I appreciate your answer.
I have to ask about something.
This is going to seem
like a total divergence
but it's not, which is animals.
Because first of
all, they're a love
of mine in terms of
understanding the animal
kingdom and placing humans
into the animal kingdom.
Second of all, I
know you're a hunter.
And also I know you own dogs.
And the question I have is,
do you ever look at people,
or did you ever work
in Teams of guys
when you were on active duty--
see that the difference
is you mentioned
before, this person is really
good at problem solving,
this person's a little
bit more creative.
Do you ever wonder
whether or not
people embody different
animal archetypes?
Because I do.
JOCKO WILLINK: Well, that thing
where people say that dogs
or owners look like their dogs,
dogs look like their owners,
I think that's--
I've seen all kinds of examples.
You can go on the
internet and find
a bunch of examples
of dogs that look
like their owners and owners
that look like their dogs.
So I think that's true.
And I think my dog is awesome.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Tell
me about your dog.
What kind of dog is it?
JOCKO WILLINK: My dog
is a German Shepherd.
His name is Odin, and
he's an awesome dog.
And he's got a personality.
He's got an interesting
personality.
So like he doesn't
like to cuddle.
My kids will be like oh,
he doesn't like to cuddle.
No.
Even when we go to
bed at night, he
goes to 4 feet away
from the foot of my bed.
Even if I was
like, hey, jump up.
I've told him, jump up in here.
We want to pet you.
He'll jump up in
there, and he just
like goes in that
low crouch position.
And then waits until
I say, free dog,
and then he goes back down,
and he goes 4 feet away
from the foot of the
bed and sits there.
Because that's
his personality is
to protect, and set
security, and do his job.
And that's what he's like.
And so you've got
other dogs that are--
they're in a totally
different mindset.
So yeah, dogs have
definite personalities.
And look, I also have--
it's not all genetic.
So two of my friends got
dogs that were brothers.
What are they called?
Dogo Argentinos.
You know those?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oh, the Dogoes?
Yeah, those are hard
to get in the US.
They're not-- They
might not even
be legal in the United
States, so don't tell me
who these people are.
Not that I care, but I'm
not going to report them.
JOCKO WILLINK: I won't
tell you who they are.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
JOCKO WILLINK: But
these two guys--
and those two guys had
different personalities.
One guy is a very
happy-go-lucky,
likes to smoke pot, likes
to hang out, very just
a chill, playful guy.
The other guy is not.
He's the opposite
in every category.
And they both got these dogs.
And you fast
forward like a year,
the dog that was owned
by the playful guy,
his dog was just a
big puppy licking
at-- just wagging the tail.
The other dog, you had
to keep it in a cage
or it would murder
everything in sight.
And these dogs were brothers
from the same litter,
and they were
completely opposite.
And so I think it has a lot
more to do with nurture than it
does to do with nature.
But that being said, when
you look at Malinois I mean,
Malinois have a personality
that is very distinct compared
to a German Shepherd.
Now, look there's
outlying Malinois,
there's outlying
German Shepherds,
there's outlying you name
whatever kind of Golden
Retriever or whatever dog is
known for being more playful.
You get around the Malinois,
Malinois are Malinois.
And they're that way.
Have you been around
Malinois before?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Mm-hmm.
Oh, uh--
JOCKO WILLINK: The
Belgian Malinois?
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, a few of them.
My neighbor has one, and that
thing is not terribly friendly.
But it's a security dog,
so I don't expect it to be.
JOCKO WILLINK: Exactly.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's
yeah, I know they use them
for work in the Teams.
And I've heard that you
have to keep a close eye
on your relationship with
them because if you get lax
about it, they'll bite you.
JOCKO WILLINK: That's for true.
The first time I saw one
we were doing a drill using
dogs for the first time.
And then one of the Team
guide dog handlers came out.
And so we hit this
target building,
and they prebriefed
us like, hey, you
hit this target
building, and this guy
is going to be a
runner, a squirter.
And so we pull up
in the Humvees,
assault team jumps out,
I'm staying external,
I want to see what's
going to happen.
So the squirter
goes running off.
And the dog handler--
whatever-- tracks his dog on
this guy, and then releases it,
gives him whatever commands--
[GROWLS]
--or whatever the commands are.
That thing is totally primed.
Unlike anything you've
ever seen in your life.
It is just primed.
It's tracking that guy.
He hits that release
on that leash,
and that thing takes off
at 1,000 miles an hour.
It jumps like, I'm
not kidding, 15 feet,
maybe 10 feet in the air away
and just chomps onto this dude.
The dude goes down.
It was freaking awesome.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, I've seen
some videos of those Malinois.
I guess, I didn't--
forgive me because
before I didn't
know what you were referring
to Belgian Malinois.
Those dogs like
running up trees,
jumping over little rivers.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Incredibly powerful animals.
Yeah.
Well, the idea that
they mimic their owners
has me a little concerned
because my last dog,
I had to put him down.
It was my bulldog Costello.
He's a Bulldog Mastiff.
I got him because I went to
pick out a puppy, basically.
And there were eight
of these bulldogs.
And all of them
were running around,
and then there's one in the
background just eating out
of all of their bowls.
And I was like, I want that one.
Big bulldog, biggest
one in the litter.
Laziest creature.
Not just dog but laziest
creature that ever existed.
But if you need to
activate, he would.
He was just very
efficient with his energy.
And I don't think I have
a bulldog personality,
and that's why I got
him to balance me out.
Never retrieved,
never did anything.
Stole and destroyed every toy,
every dog park in San Diego.
He was famous there.
I had to bring $5 bills to
pay people for all the balls
and things he would destroy.
So anyway, my apologies
to all the dog owners.
Not really.
I miss him.
Did you train your dog, or
did someone else in the house?
JOCKO WILLINK: I did.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
And was he trained
to be a security dog, or
family dog, or a mixture?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, I mean,
they're true working dogs.
Unless you have the time
and effort to put into him,
or you buy them that way, you
don't want one of those dogs
that I was just
describing in your house.
They're not for a house
unless there's that level.
My dog is not that level.
He's awesome.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Did you apply
some of the same principles
that you use in leadership
of humans with your dog?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, there are
a lot of similar principles,
but there's some differences.
They're pack animals, and they
respond to the pack leader.
it's funny.
My dog obeys me as if
it's the command of God.
And my wife, he's like
maybe I'll do what you say.
So they pick up on that stuff.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Dogs
are very intuitive.
I love this idea that I
was told early on that they
can feel your emotions.
I think they actually can
sense how we feel not just
by the intonation of our voice.
But I hope someday someone will
figure out in a noninvasive way
because I don't like
the idea of people
doing experiments on
dogs in an invasive way.
Like what they're picking up on?
Like for instance, we know that
sharks are paying attention
to the amount of activity
in the lateral line of fish.
Fish have these
stretches of neurons
that they call the lateral line
that allows them to school,
and know the distance
to different things,
and be able to
steer around coral.
They feel proximity.
It would be like if
you're turning a corner,
you go-- vrrt.
--and they can even recognize
specific lateral line
signatures.
So it'd be like you and
Marc Lee walking together
through the dark.
But maybe people sift around.
But you're like, you don't have
to look at them, that's Marc.
You learn him intuitively.
A fish can do that.
Sharks can sense whether or
not the lateral line is--
let's say vibrating but firing
at a particular frequency
to know oh, that fish
is a little bit slower
than the rest.
I mean, hunting
animals just they
develop these incredible senses.
And I think humans have
some of these senses in more
rudimentary way.
We're just not forced to
use them unless, of course,
you become a hunter of
animals, or a hunter of humans,
and you tap into these
neural circuits that
are very primitive and
hardwired in everybody.
But of course, they're
honed in warriors.
Well, I could spiral off into
animal biology in ways that
truly would take us 26 hours.
I don't want to do that.
I'm almost hesitant
to ask this question,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
Many times online, you
are asked whether or not
you will run for office?
And I want to say that I
think it's a true compliment.
I don't think people are asking
just to entertain themselves.
I think that this
country certainly
and a lot of the world is
desperate for certain kinds
of leaders and people
that have experience
in high risk, high consequence,
chaotic situations,
and have shown prowess at
leadership in multiple domains.
And you are certainly
one of those individuals.
And so they ask for that
reason among others.
And I've heard you
give your answer,
and you can repeat
it again here.
But as a more broad theme that I
think people are interested in,
do you think it's an
important criteria
or it would be
great to see people
in positions of leadership
who've had wartime experience?
And do you think that some
of the shifts that we've
seen in terms of
patterns of leadership
over the last-- let's
just make it real broad
so that this isn't related
to any particular person
or stretch of history--
but over the last,
let's just say 25
years, reflect the fact
that we haven't
seen a lot of that,
at least at the top
tiers of leadership?
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah, I think
it'd be excellent if people--
if the president had
military experience for sure.
I think that then they
understand the way
the military works better.
They understand that each--
the civilians that control
the military.
Because a lot of times
people that are civilians
don't understand that the
civilians control the military.
And I think that you do get to
appreciate what war actually is
and what the costs are.
I think that I've seen in
the same vein of people
asking me to run for
political office,
I've heard, seen
comments saying, oh,
that's what we
need, another war--
a warmonger in office.
And I've responded
a few of those.
I think if there's any group
of people that don't want war,
it's people that have seen it.
People that understand
what the sacrifices are.
And I think that
being in the military,
people understand that better.
So yeah, I think it'd be
a great qualification.
I don't think it's mandatory.
I mean, clearly it's not.
We've had a bunch of
presidents that haven't ever
served anything.
Really, we've had a bunch of
presidents that haven't ever
served anything but themselves.
So yeah, hopefully, we'll
get some more people that
have some experience
in the military,
some combat experience
would be especially nice.
And that would be
good in my opinion.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Well
I'm certainly not one
to tell people what to do,
and I'm certainly not going
to tell you what to do.
But should you
ever choose to run,
I would certainly be very
enthusiastic about that.
And I will just say
that with that stated,
I hope people do hear
what you just said.
I share that sentiment.
People who have led others
besides themselves, I think
is the key statement there.
JOCKO WILLINK: Yeah.
And look, I just--
I have friends that
are politicians,
and I really appreciate
what they're doing.
And it looks miserable to me.
I don't like what--
good for them.
I'm happy that they're in there
trying to make a difference.
And I guess, this is me being
selfish of me saying, look,
I don't think I
could stomach that.
And I also think that right
now, I'm trying to help out.
For instance, we have
obviously got the leadership
consulting in
Echelon Front, we're
trying to help businesses grow.
I've got Origin
USA, we're bringing
manufacturing back to America.
We've got 100, 400,
450 employees right
now that are here in
America working and growing
that business.
Obviously, that
supplements-- so everything
that I'm doing here right
now is to try and move
the needle with America.
Bringing manufacturing back,
helping the economy as much
as I can right now.
So that's what I'm
doing right now.
And my standard answer,
which you alluded to,
is if things got
bad enough, then
I would do what I had to do.
But I don't think people
appreciate my level of bad.
I'm talking real bad.
So it's not there yet.
And hopefully, it
never will get there.
I'd rather surf and
hang out with my friends
and hang out with my
family than do that.
And hopefully, America can
find some level of balance.
I think that's the problem
that we're having right now.
And a lot of these things
that you talked about,
specifically the thing
you talked about,
social media is not very
good for political balance.
It's actually horrible
for political balance,
and a lot of it has to
do with just the way
that those
conversations are had.
A lot of it has to do with ego
as well because I don't ever
want to admit that I'm
wrong about anything.
And if I can find
something that I
think you might be
wrong about, it's
so satisfying to my ego to
just call you out on that thing
and attack you.
And I think that's what a lot
of people are doing right now.
Now, that being said, I also
usually say this as well.
I travel around the
country all the time.
I work with companies
of all sizes, work
with people in every
different industry.
And they're not sitting
around arguing with each other
about the political scenery.
They're talking about, hey,
how can we grow our business?
How can we take
care of our workers?
care of our clients?
How can we take care
of our customer?
That's what people
are focused on.
And when you jump
on social media,
you can get sucked into the
political scene very easily.
And that being said,
also we do have
to pay attention
because we as citizens
have to make sure
that America stays
on the correct path within
the guardrails of what
this country is based on.
So we do have to pay attention.
But I will be doing
my part as a civilian
until there's total mayhem
and chaos in the streets.
Then I'll probably just
be a benevolent dictator
that takes over.
[LAUGHS]
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Should be
an interesting one, but, hey,
you would be the man to
lead under any conditions.
But thank you for
stating your threshold.
Certainly, you've
earned the right
to make whatever decision is
that you feel is right for you.
And I want to say that I agree.
I feel like we are a
country that still includes
a ton of generators
and a ton of projectors
that are interested
in projecting the good
and growing the good.
I do believe both those
phenotypes are important.
I also want to
just say thank you
for being a generator of
so much useful knowledge.
In science, we have a saying,
which is somebody is an n of 1.
This is a rare thing
to hear about oneself
or to hear about somebody
because what it means
is that somebody is in a
category in which pretty
much everything that
they do and they say
matters and serves
a purpose, which
is a useful and important
building purpose.
And I will look at you and tell
you that you are an n of 1.
You certainly would meet that
criteria under any conditions.
And it's evident in
the many companies
that you're running and the
leadership that you're doing.
And also in your
online presence.
I mean, that's how I initially
came to learn about you.
I'm now fortunate to have two
lengthy conversations with you
and a few interspersed as well.
And I think of myself as
a reasonable perhaps good
observer of how people
behave in different domains.
And every time you post,
or every time you speak,
or every time you go on a
podcast or host a podcast,
it's clear that not
only are you prepared
and not only are you approaching
it with a spirit of seriousness
that it deserves
but sometimes also
lightness that it deserves.
But there's always
an element of give
and that you're trying to
encourage people to do better
for themselves.
So as somebody who's greatly
benefited from the knowledge
that you've put out there from
the very first Tim Ferriss
and Joe Rogan episodes
to your own podcast,
I want to extend
a personal thanks.
I also want to
extend great thanks
for coming on here
today, talking
to a geek scientist
who also happens
to be a fellow punk rocker.
Because that spirit and
the heart that's behind it,
I think some people think it's
all about noise and chaos,
it's actually about being
really true to yourself.
That's how I think about
the punk rock spirit.
It's really about
being true to yourself
and realizing that the
thing that you like,
while it might be
quite different,
is actually, if that's you,
you have to live in that vein
and stick with it.
It certainly served
me well, and it
sounds like it served you well.
But mostly I just want to
extend an enormous thank you.
As a civilian, thank
you for the work
you did in the military
but also teaching people
about the military.
I think a lot of
people don't realize
what it's about at any level.
And learning about
your experience
there, and what you've
observed, bringing
other people's experiences
from the military more broadly
is super important.
And sharing this and
being able to entertain
some of my scientific riffs.
So thank you, thank
you, thank you.
JOCKO WILLINK: Well,
I appreciate it.
it's weird you say all
these nice things to me.
I definitely don't deserve them.
I'm a regular dude
that just showed up,
I guess, at the right
time and told some stories
about some guys that
were true heroes,
and just trying to
share my perspective.
But it's not just
my perspective,
I'm talking about
stories that I lived.
But there's plenty
of people that
have done way more
than I've ever
done and sacrificed infinitely
more than I ever sacrificed.
So I'm thankful for being here.
I know that you put all kinds
of information and the same back
at you.
I have greatly benefited
from the information
that you put out.
And so I thank you as well.
And I appreciate coming
on here and appreciate
you spreading the word about how
people can be better yourself.
So thanks for having me.
I appreciate it, man.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
I appreciate you,
and I appreciate this time,
and let's do it again.
JOCKO WILLINK: Check.
JOCKO WILLINK: Thank
you for joining me
for today's discussion
with Jocko Willink.
I hope you learned
as much as I did
in terms of actionable knowledge
to use in our everyday lives.
If you'd like to learn
more about Jocko's work
and the various things
he's involved in, please
check out the Jocko Podcast.
Please also check
out the various links
in the show note captions
to Jocko's excellent books
on leadership both for
adults and for kids.
And check out some
of the other links
that relate to some of his
other business ventures.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero-cost
way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can leave us up to
a five star review.
If you have questions
for us, or topics
that you'd like us
to cover, or guests
that you'd like me to include
on the Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those suggestions
in the comments section
on YouTube.
I do read all the comments.
In addition, please
check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
On various episodes of
the Huberman Lab podcast,
we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things
like enhancing sleep,
focus, hormone support,
and many other features of
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
The Huberman Lab podcast
is proud to be partnered
with Momentous supplements.
Momentous supplements are
of the very highest quality,
and they focus on single
ingredient formulations, which
is very important if you are
going to develop the most
cost effective and
biologically effective
supplement regimen for you.
In addition, they
ship internationally,
which is important
because I know many of you
reside outside of
the United States.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed on this
podcast, you can go to
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And there you can
also get 20% off any
of Momentous supplements.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
we are Huberman Lab on
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook,
and LinkedIn.
And in particular
on Instagram, I
cover science and science
related tools, some of which
overlap with the contents
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
Much of which is
distinct however
from the contents of the
Huberman Lab podcast.
Again, its Huberman Lab on
all social media platforms.
And if you haven't already
subscribed to our Neural
Network Newsletter, it's a
zero-cost monthly newsletter.
You simply sign
up with your email
by going to hubermanlab.com.
The newsletter includes
summaries of podcast episodes.
We have toolkits for
sleep, toolkits for focus,
toolkits related to
deliberate cold exposure, heat
exposure and much, much
more, again, all zero cost.
You provide your
email to sign up.
We do not share your
email with anybody.
There are also
sample newsletters
there that you don't
even need to sign up for.
You can just download
the PDF or just
view them on your
computer or phone screen.
Thank you once
again for joining me
for my discussion
with Jocko Willink.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]